Und jetzt heißt es wieder BINGO! Sie wollen Spaß und Nerven, Kidsie? Ihnen macht so schnell keiner was vor? Dann machen Sie jetzt mit beim Freak Show BINGO! Legen Sie sich schon einmal Bleistift und Papier bereit und notieren Sie die Adresse freakxohbingo.de und kreuzen Sie mit, wenn zu spannende Begriffe fallen wie DSE oder IPV6 und nicht zu vergessen BITCOIN Seien auch Sie mit dabei, denn Freakshow BINGU ist immer noch toll.
Ich bin super laut selber, aber höre die Musik und die Schleife sehr leise.
Ja, du bist super laut. Ich werd da gleich mal was gegen machen.
Expand und kompresse mich.
Naja, ich meine, du hast ja auch was zu sagen. Dann kann man ja auch mal aufdrehen. Dennis, hast du auch was zu sagen? Nö. Roddy, hast du was zu sagen?
Eventuell.
Das trifft sich gut, denn wir haben hier die 172. Folge der Freak Show am Start und wir begrüßen alle ganz herzlich und wir widmen diese Sendung. Nein.
Nein.
Also das können wir später mal machen, wenn du verstorben bist. Doch, dann machen wir eine Extrasendung.
Schaffen wir vielleicht bis zum Ende der Sendung noch.
Genau, Stimme der Jugend, nennen wir die dann.
Ich bin hier der Letzte, der noch podcastet.
Ja, nee, wir widmen das natürlich Herrn Peter Lustig, der nun leider heute von uns gegangen ist. Oder nee, heute ist er gar nicht von uns gegangen, sondern heute kam das irgendwie raus, dass er von uns gegangen ist. War wohl schon ein paar Tage her. Ja, was soll man dazu sagen?
Ist das eigentlich ein Künstler-Anname?
Nee.
War so ein lustiger Name.
Der heißt wirklich so, oder hieß.
Der Aktuelle, der Fritz Fuchs, das ist ein Künstler-Anname.
Das ist ein Künstler-Anname, genau. Aber Peter Lustig hieß tatsächlich Peter Lustig.
Was hab ich heute gelesen? Der hat, ich bin Elmer Liener als Tonmeister aufgezeichnet.
Ja, genau.
War da gleich gemerkt mit dem Politiker, weil er nichts zu tun hat, die Lügen haben die gedruckt. Und ist gleich, hat er sich gemacht, der macht das Wort vernünftig.
Hab ich jetzt gerade keinen Link zur Hand, aber da gab's ein Interview beim Tagesspiegel 2013. Würde mich nicht wundern, wenn das heute irgendwo nochmal verlinkt ist auf der Webseite, wo er dazu befragt wurde oder das irgendwie erzählt hat in so einem Interview. Ja, nee, aber ich meine, wer von uns hat nicht Löwenzahn geguckt? Keiner. Haben alle Löwenzahn geguckt, oder?
Richtig.
Und war geil, oder?
Nö, die ist Pusteblume.
Das hieß wann? Pusteblume?
Ich glaube, das hieß erst ein Jahr lang Pusteblume und dann haben sie den Löwenzahn umbenannt.
Nee, hieß nicht danach. Was?
Wir sind wie immer gut informiert und widmen dieser Sendung auf jeden Fall. Also Pustezahn.
Also momentan heißt es Löwenzahn und die Auskopplung da draußen nur mit dem Hund heißt Löwenzähnchen.
Guck an, 79.
Ja, die kann ich mir auch noch erinnern.
Ja, nee, fantastisch, weil einfach, also wir haben ja auch heute noch mal ein, zwei Folgen, nicht komplett, aber so ein bisschen angeguckt. Ich bin immer wieder beeindruckt von dieser Ruhe, die der Mensch ausgestrahlt hat. Also ich glaube, das ist auch schon mal so ein Schlüssel zum Erfolg. Dieses total unprätentiöse, ich meine, er war ja auch so ein bisschen hippie, in seinem Bauwagen, so in seinem Gärtchen.
Bisschen hippie, also bis auf die Haare war er hippie.
Du meinst jetzt, in seinem eigentlichen Leben war er hippie? Nein.
Na hörst du so die ganze Figur, die er da so darstellt.
Ja, so grün irgendwie auch ein bisschen, ne?
Er war aber schon so Aussteigermäßig.
Er hat sich für die Spiele eingesetzt. Wer umfällt denn hier so mit seinem Mikrofon?
Muss Roddy sein. Nein.
Ne, ich rumpel nicht. Ich hab so nur Stimme, das reicht.
Und du meinst Ruhe auszustrahlen.
Ja, ich versuche das. Das ist auch manchmal ganz hilfreich hier. Kann ich dir sagen. Ja, hat jetzt noch jemand was Schönes zu sagen?
Es war meine allerliebste Lieblings-Kindersendung.
Ja, parallel mit der Sendung mit der Maus natürlich. Ich hab mir auch immer erklärt.
So ein bisschen advanced, ne?
Ich weiß nicht mehr, welches jetzt besser oder schlechter war, aber die waren immer... Da ist man immer automatisch hängen geblieben. Man hat es nicht geplant, du hast eingeschaltet und dann warst du gleich, oh.
Genau, aber...
Vor allem, weil gab es ja nichts anderes.
Ja, aber was man dem deutschen Fernsehen an der Stelle auch wirklich zumindest diesem Kinderfernsehen und Lernfernsehen-Wesen nachsagen muss, ist, dass es denen doch schon in den letzten 50 Jahren gelungen ist, wirklich hervorragende Formate auf den Tisch zu legen. Und das hat sich auch bis heute nicht geändert.
Das stimmt.
Also es gibt immer noch wirklich außerordentlich gute Sachen. Also auch so Sachen, die es halt früher nicht gab, also die wir jetzt so aktiv, glaube ich, als Kind nicht begleitet haben. Also heutzutage...
Na, dieses PUR Plus ist schon ganz gut.
PUR Plus zum Beispiel, genau.
Also ich kenn's nur vom Kika.
Ja, genau. Also überhaupt ist auf Kika alles voll mit ziemlich brauchbaren Zeug und halt auch so Lernsachen oder halt auch einfach, ich weiß nicht, ich kann das jedes Mal gucken und lernen was dazu. Und die sind auch irgendwie so ein bisschen auf der Höhe der Zeiten, was ich auch gut finde, ist zum Beispiel dieses Logo, also auch so dieses Nachrichten für...
Ja, am Anfang dachte ich so, das ist irgendwie albern, aber eigentlich ist ziemlich cool.
Das ist ziemlich, ziemlich gut und vor allem, was ich sehr daran schätze, ist, dass sie sich auch trauen oder in gewisser Hinsicht das glaube ich sogar auch als ihre Aufgabe sehen, auch so richtig tagesaktuellen Kram, aber eben auch wirklich so die ganzen schlimmen Sachen. Auch Terroranschläge und so weiter, das wird da alles verwurstet und ja, halt geschildert und wird halt...
Und vor allen Dingen erklärt wird's.
Und erklärt und das könnten sich glaube ich auch ein paar große mal anschauen, weil ich habe auch das Gefühl, da kommt mehr bei rüber, als jetzt in einer Tagesschau, weil die Tagesschau hat eigentlich permanent so ein, weiß nicht, da muss immer so ein Grundwissen Weltpolitik mitbringen, was glaube ich die wenigsten Leute wirklich haben, um eigentlich diese Nachrichten richtig einsortieren zu können. Und bei Logo ist dieses Einsortieren quasi immer noch ein bisschen mit dabei.
Das ist schon gut.
Also nicht so wie ich hier. Ich meine, hier setzen wir ja alles voraus.
Ja, auf jeden Fall anderer Anspruch durchaus.
Das Delta ist sehr gering.
Also Peter, Peter ist jetzt in die Cloud umgezogen sozusagen.
Auf anderer Leute Computer oder was? Ja, übrigens.
Peter in the Cloud with Diamonds.
Aber dann ist die Abkürzung doch gar nicht mehr LSD.
Aber du hast leider den falschen. Das ist nicht der Süße, das ist der EFF-Aufkleber.
Welches ist denn der Süße?
Redet der schon wieder über Dinge, die man nur sehen kann?
Nein, wir reden über Dinge, die der Hörer in der letzten Sendung natürlich verfolgt hat. Und schon geklickt hat. Das ist der süße Aufkleber für There is no cloud. It's just someone else.
Nee, ich hab nur den von der SF-F-S-F-E. Hätten die sich nicht mal eine andere Abkürzung geben können?
Immer noch besser als F-F-I-E.
F-F-I-E? Na wie auch immer.
Ja, diese ganze Freiheitsszene war mit so obskuren Abkürzungen ganz gut unterwegs.
Müssen die dann auch immer rekursiv sein?
Ich weiß es nicht, aber F-F-I-E, da weiß ich nicht nur jedes Mal nicht, was es genau heißt, sondern es geht einem auch einfach gar nicht von der Zunge. Ich meine, wie willst du das sagen?
F-2-I-2.
Das wär immer noch was gewesen.
F-Quadrat.
Ich bin von der Fie.
Ja, klingt so ein bisschen, als hätte man zu viel Schalldruck abgekriegt.
Oder Feedback. Apropos Feedback.
Na Mann, was für eine Überleitung. König der Überleiter.
Goldene Brücken.
Es läuft, oder? Also wir haben Flow, würde ich mal sagen. Ja, mindestens. Also, ähm, ich weiß nicht, was ich sagen soll, aber wir haben mal über Kalender gesprochen das letzte Mal und ich hab mich mit Clemens in so einen schönen Rand hineingesteigert und das war insofern mal wieder sehr sehenswert, weil natürlich der geneigte Hörer mit größerer Fachkenntnis sofort sich die Hände vor dem Gesicht zusammengeschlagen hat und, ähm, also das übliche, und festgestellt hat, dass wir natürlich nur wieder dummes Zeug reden. Also sagen wir mal so ein bisschen. Worum ging's? Es ging unter anderem darum, dass wir beklagt haben, dass man in der Kalender-Software der gängigen keine separaten Zeitzonen für Anfang und Ende eines Events eintragen konnten. Wurden natürlich eines besseren belehrt und wie peinlich, peinlich, peinlich es geht auf dem iPhone.
Ja, einfaches Nachgucken hätte die Lösung erbracht.
Hätte gereicht, aber das ist natürlich jetzt auch eine Menge verlangt, ne? Ja, aber ich hab dann auch noch mal nachgeschaut. iCal oder Kalender, wie das jetzt heißt auf dem Mac, kann es halt auch tatsächlich nicht, was insofern auch schon mal wirklich absurd ist, weil man ja nun wirklich nicht erwarten würde, dass man jetzt auf dem Mobilgerät auf einmal mehr Features hat als auf dem Desktop. Also das...
In welcher Welt lebst du denn? Also ich hab das Gefühl, dass das schon länger so ist irgendwie. Ja, besonders halt so, wenn du irgendwie einen ordentlichen Client halt für Mobil hast und für Desktop nur die olle Webseite.
Ja gut, aber es gibt ja nun einen, in Anführungszeichen, ordentlichen Client für den Desktop und es gibt ja auch alternative Clients und auch dieses Busy Cal kann es nicht. Also das ist...
In Anführungszeichen ist das so wichtig.
Ja, ich wurde dann darauf hingewiesen, dass es wohl im Google-Kalender auch geht und so weiter.
Es geht eigentlich überall außer auf dem Mac.
Und teilweise gibt es wohl auch Systeme, wo man tatsächlich, Thunderbird wurde da glaub ich genannt im Google-Kalender, die auch tatsächlich, die man so einstellen kann, dass der Alarm sich sozusagen auf das Ende eines Events bezieht und nicht auf den Anfang, das geht aber auch nicht auf iOS, es sei denn, es geht auf iOS und ich hab's nur wieder nicht gesehen. Dann ist es halt anders. Ja ja und dann sehr schön finde ich das ja auch immer, wenn man hier irgendwas beklagt und der Meinung ist, die Welt hätte dann noch so ein schwarzes Loch, das doch mal gefüllt gehört und dann kommt irgendjemand und füllt dieses Loch und zwar sprachen wir ja über den Kalendereintrag, den man so von bahn.de vor die Nase geworfen bekommt, wenn man da mal eine Buchung gemacht hat oder sich zumindest aus dem Fahrplan eine Zugverbindung rausgesucht hat. Ja, unabhängig jetzt von Tickets, nur Planung und wenn man halt mehrere Umsteigephasen hat, dann wäre es doch sehr naheliegend, wenn man eben einzelne Einträge bekäme für jede einzelne Strecke, weil natürlich man Pausen sehen will, Umsteigezeiten sehen will und vor allem separate Notifizierungen gegebenenfalls auch noch haben möchte.
Da muss ich jetzt aber mal sagen, benutzt du denn nicht die Watch-App von dem DB-Navigator? Du kannst, wenn du auf dem DB-Navigator-App, auf dem iPhone, dir eine Verbindung raussuchst, dann kannst du sagen, zu meinen Reisen hinzufügen und auf der Watch-App von der Uhr wird dir dann diese Reise angezeigt, im Sinne von noch eine Stunde, vier Minuten, bis der Zug geht. Und dann sitzt du da und dann steht da noch 25 Minuten bis planmäßig, aber der Zug hat vier Minuten Verspätung und dann noch so und so lange, bis du aussteigen musst und dann musst du aber da auf das Gleis und dann hast du so und so vier Minuten, um dann da wieder einzusteigen.
Das macht es nur auf der Watch und nicht auf dem Phone?
Aber da macht es das sehr schön.
Achso, aber auch nur, wenn man diese App startet auf der Watch. Was ja mit gewissen Hindernissen.
Ja, diese Homescreen auf der App ist irgendwie ein Train-Drag, das ist schon klar, aber ja.
Genau. Auch dieser Wahn von Apple, alles erstmal bei Default dahin zu populieren.
Aber du kriegst ja eine Notification und wenn du da drauf tappst, dann kommst du ja in die App rein. Also insofern, das geht dann schon.
Ja, gut, die Experience hatte ich noch nicht, aber das ist nicht so genau das, wonach ich jetzt gesucht habe. Wonach ich gesucht habe, ist aber das, was Yannick gemacht hat und zwar hat er das einfach mal gemacht. Sehr schön, Train to ICS und koppelt sich interessanterweise an die API des Schweizer Bahnauskunftsystems, was das eben ermöglicht, dass man da mal so eben mal eine Web-App macht und dann darüber die Daten bekommt, was natürlich mit den Bahndaten nicht geht, sondern immer auf diese Bahn-App.
Das erinnert mich daran, als ich mal in Belgien eine Fahrkarte kaufen wollte, in Brüssel am Bahnhof nach London und der auf dem belgischen System rumgetippt hat, zugemacht. Dann das französische System, er ist aufgemacht, rumgetippt, zugemacht. Das deutsche System aufgemacht. Ah, hier ist es ja. Tap, tap, tap, tap, tap. Ja, das ist der Zug und da und da und da. Also es scheint irgendwie normal zu sein, dass man nicht das System des eigenen Landes hat.
Das war jetzt aber kein Sprachproblem in dem Fall.
Nee, das war kein Sprachproblem, sondern es war ein Problem davon, dass die Belgier und die Franzosen beide nicht hingekriegt haben, Züge in ihrem Land irgendwie auf die Reihe zu kriegen. Nur dieses komische deutsche System, das funktionierte dann.
Ja, das kenn ich auch, diesen Effekt, dass man mit dem deutschen Bahnplan doch sehr weit kommt. Allerdings hatte ich in England wiederum relativ unterperformante Daten aus dem deutschen System. Da war ich dann teilweise wirklich auf englische Systeme angewiesen. Die waren allerdings auch furchtbar. Die kriegen das halt überhaupt nicht auf die Backe da mit ihren unterschiedlichen Unternehmen und so.
Erinnerst du dich an diese Auskunftsdinger, die es mal gab mit so einem Rollrad, wo man auf so einer Windows-Oberfläche irgendwie sich Züge raussuchen lassen konnte? Auf einem relativ unterpowereden 486er war das. Das weiß ich deswegen, weil ich dachte, ach das ist ja interessant, lass uns mal einen Zug raussuchen. Von Porto nach Vladivostok. Und das System dachte zwei, drei Minuten nach und dann sah man halt den Bios Bootbildschirm.
Oh man, oh man, oh man.
Also den hat es direkt komplett zerlegt.
Naja, auf jeden Fall hier imjannik.me slash train zwei ICS liefert und fragt einfach Zugverbindungen ab und macht dann irgendwie ganz hübsche Einträge. Das heißt, man klickt auf einen Button, kriegt einen ICS-Fall, in dem dann mehrere separate Termine drin sind und sollte jemand von der Bahn zuhören, no, hätte ich das gern.
Hört uns jemand von der Bahn zu?
Das glaube ich nicht.
Kann ich mir auch nicht vorstellen. Und wenn, dann weinen sie alle nur.
Wir würden ja so gerne, aber wir können nicht, weil X...
Weil wir haben diesen externen Dienstleister und der ist nicht in der Lage, das zu liefern.
Ja, und wir haben eine Hierarchie, eine Bürokratie, ein Pipapo. Das ist auch nicht nur bei der Bahn so. Das ist, glaube ich, bei jedem Unternehmen mit mehr als drei Mitarbeitern. Da fangen die Leute dann alle an, schon zu schwitzen.
Also ich kann euch sagen, uns wurde schon hier von höchster Bahnstelle zugehört.
Höchster?
Fast.
Herr Grube?
Hat er gesagt fast höchster?
Fast. Wie viel Ebenen muss man das Treppchen noch runtergehen, bis man mal bei der Freak Show ist?
Darfst du das sagen?
Nee, darfst du nicht sagen.
Darf ich nicht sagen. Oh Gott, hoffentlich haben wir keinen Unsinn erzählt.
Ich tick mir ja gerade Bahntickets, weil umso früher, umso besser ist das nicht so teuer.
Für was?
Für ein Zugfahren.
Ja, jetzt für welchen Event?
Für meine privaten Events.
Ach so, ich dachte du bist schon bei Kongressplanung oder was?
Könntest du auch mal machen.
Man weiß es ja nie. Man weiß es ja nie.
So viel billiger könnt ihr noch gar nicht sein.
Also so viel zum Thema Kalender. Auch noch Feedback gab es zu Wetter. Haben wir uns über Wetter unterhalten?
Nein, überhaupt nicht.
Das kennt der Roddy gar nicht.
Ich weiß nicht mehr.
Doch, wir hatten uns über Wetter unterhalten. Diese Wunder-App WunderGround und Kachelmann und so weiter. Zwei Wochen ist eine lange Zeit.
Ja, der ging dieser Link rum mit diesem Curl-Kommando, was ich ganz sehe.
Oder Huckel und der Tom Staers meint, das geht ja gar nicht.
Ja, das aber auch wirklich. Da muss ich gleich noch was zu sagen.
Ich fand's einfach schnuffig. Ich meine, technisch eventuell nicht, dass dahinter ist, was man haben will.
Also es rendert schön, aber was das eigentlich ist, ist ein wirklich einfachstes Python-Webfrontend vor einer in Go geschriebenen Bibliothek, die eigentlich das ganze Heavylifting macht. Und dieser Typ, der das auf getwittert und auf Hacker News den ganzen Fame abbekommen hat, der hat, wie gesagt, eigentlich nur da so einen komischen Rapper drum gebaut und macht dann halt einmal Terminal to ASCII und dann wieder ASCII to HTML und irgendwie so Kram. Und es ist halt auch wirklich nur so ein kleines Python-Skript, was halt einen Webserver aufmacht und dann über einen Bash-Port sozusagen da den Output sich holt.
Ich finde es aber sehr schön. Also eigentlich ist das was, was ich öfter sehen möchte, nämlich dass man mit Curl an Informationen rankommt. Warum nicht dieses ganze HTTP mal weglassen? Oder dieses ganze HTML mal weglassen?
Genau, wenn du das HTTP weglassen willst, dann gehst du zu dem Typen, der diese Go-Bibliothek geschrieben hat, die kann ich jetzt hier immer noch rein...
Entzimmerst du mir das selber dann in Go?
Nee, du compiles das einfach so und dann kannst du das immer auf deinem Endgerät laufen lassen. Musste gar nicht Internet... doch Internet brauchst du ja noch.
Macht der denn auch so eine schöne Farbe aus?
Das ist, du, das ist wirklich, der Output ist eins zu eins von dieser Go-Library. Der macht nur, dieser Webservice, der rappt das halt nur einmal in HTML, das ist alles. So, warte mal, ich mach mal den Link hier in die Show Notes zu dem Github Repository.
Ja, dann ist es natürlich eine schwache Leistung, aber...
Ja, vor allen Dingen, wenn du das Python-Script, das Originale, dann siehst du von dem Typen, der das rappt, das ist halt wirklich so halt ein Hack mal zusammengeschustet und als das auf Hacker News war, ist das ja auch gnadenlos abgeranzt die ganze Zeit. Also dieser Schach-Math-Vego, das ist der Typ, der die Go-Library geschrieben hat, ist auch in Deutschland, der ist also bestimmt Freak Show-Hörer und hört auch Feature-Requests von Tim, die jetzt bestimmt gleich kommen, noch wahnsinnig gerne. Und das ist das GitHub-Repository von dem Typen, der es gewrappt hat, wo eben dieses eine Python-File drin ist, wo man halt sieht, wie man so mit so einer Skript-Sprache halt mal sowas zusammendängelt, aber das skaliert nicht, Freunde. Ich bin der Skalier-Vampir. So, also dieses Python-Ding, das muss man sich jetzt nicht unbedingt angucken. Wie gesagt, die Go-Library finde ich schon ein bisschen interessanter, weil da sieht man halt auch, wo er die Daten herkriegt und so weiter. Ist auch nicht viel Code. Da habe ich meine elitären Social-Engineering-Hackerskills ausgepackt und habe quasi einfach geguckt, ob der einen GitHub-Account hat und dann hat er das da drauf und dann gleich alles gecheckt. Glücklicherweise oder sagen wir mal, ehrenhafterweise hat er dann die Original-Bibliothek noch verlinkt gehabt. Also er hat nicht den ganzen Fame für sich eingeheimst. Naja, Wetter. Im Terminal, schön. Heiter bis wolkig. Teils, teils. Das ist auch immer diese schöne Formulierung.
Ja, was auch noch schön war, war, dass mir dann tatsächlich ein paar Leute auch noch ihre alten iPod Touches, die sie wohl noch irgendwo im Regal rumliegen hatten, geschickt haben. Da bedanke ich mich konkret bei Julian Vitalis und natürlich habe ich den dritten Namen jetzt wieder nicht...
Oh man, Tim ey...
.wieder verzettelt.
Das ist so unprofessionell.
Es ist wirklich unprofessionell. Das ist wirklich schlimm. Also ich wundere mich auch, warum ich eigentlich noch nicht abgesetzt bin hier.
Schlimm.
Aber ich bin trotzdem dankbar und werde zusehen, dass ich jetzt hier mal was zusammen bekomme. Jetzt müsste ich eigentlich als nächstes bräuchte ich mal so ein... Das gibt es bestimmt auch.
Tims wünscht dir was.
Naja, ich meine, ich sage ja nicht... Also das muss jetzt nicht unbedingt geschaffen werden, weil ich vermute mal, dass so was schon geschaffen wurde. Also irgendjemand wird doch bestimmt in dieser 3D-Druckerszene so eine 3D-Vorlage gemacht haben für ich spanne meinen iPod, iPhone, was auch immer, also ein längliches Device, flach. Dass man da sich das sozusagen wie so ein kleinen...
Ja klar gibt es das.
Wie so einen kleinen Ständer...
Es gibt so Sachen.
Genau, also Ständer gibt es ohne Ende, aber konkret würde ich mir halt so einen Ständer wünschen, der so relativ kompakt ist. Also wo das sozusagen wie so ein Block, als wäre das wie aus Holz, also ja so voll umschließt, wo man das stabil rein macht und wo auch Stromversorgung quasi mit Kabellauf noch irgendwie mit vorgesehen ist. Und das wäre ja für mich mal wirklich mal ein Grund. Weil dann kann man das so schön hinstellen, hat irgendwie Strom dran und dann ja... Dann hätte man diese Touch-Devices, mit denen man hier so schön steuern kann.
Das ist das einzige Mal, dass ich im Apple Store den Typen da tatsächlich irgendwie ins Leere hab laufen lassen. Weil die haben ja, um die iPads auszustellen, haben die ja so schöne runde Dinger. Das ist wie so ein ganz flacher Zylinder, der so angeschrägt ist, wo das so einfach drauf liegt. Sodass man da so schön drum greifen kann und das so aber auch hochnehmen und wieder hinlegen und so weiter. Dann hab ich ihn mal gefragt, ob sie die Dinger eigentlich auch verkaufen. Ah, ne, ja, da gibt's irgendwie so, ah, er wüsst jetzt aber auch nicht.
Die verkaufen die nicht. Ich hab ja noch irgendwo so ein Ding rumliegen. Irgendwie hat mich mal so eins, was da ausgemustert wurde, erreicht. Aber es ist auch jetzt nicht so richtig praktisch. Also für so einen Store ist das irgendwie gut, aber...
Naja, als Entwickler wär's schon auch gut, weil du hast dann das iPad so, dass du quasi die Hände auf dem Tisch hast und das Ding da drunter greifen kannst.
Also wenn du das haben willst, kannst du das haben. Weil ich hab das nicht wirklich zum Einsatz gebracht. Das muss ja auch irgendwo rumliegen.
Was ich an diesen ganzen Ständern immer nicht mag, ist, dass du auch für die Phones, du kannst zwar dein Phone nach rein stellen, und ja, die haben das auch ein bisschen schwerer gemacht, damit es nicht ganz so easy umfällt, aber wenn du einfach nur so drauftatscht, besonders wenn es weiter oben ist, würde das immer nach hinten umkippen. Ich hätte gerne eins, was irgendwie schwer ist und gummiert. Nicht wegrutscht, nicht umkippt, einfach da steht wie ein Amboss. Und den gibt es noch nicht oder kostet wahrscheinlich einen armen Fuß.
Aber hatten nicht die Firma, die diese Schnupsis machen, womit man den Adapter von Strom auf Strom festhält, die haben doch auch so Teile aus Beton gegossen. So Ständer für iPads und iPhones und so weiter. Wie heißen die Hardwirk?
Warte mal, hier ist noch irgendein Mikrofon an, was wir nicht brauchen.
Hier, ich berühre das Mikro hier immer genau.
Hardwirk, so heißen die doch. Die haben doch so Betonständer für allerlei Kram.
Richtig, genau.
Aber eigentlich wäre schön, wenn das so in den Tisch eingelassen wäre und wenn man es sehen würde, drückt man das so kurz rein, dann fährt das so ganz sanft mit so einer ganz leichten E-Sink-Kurve so hoch. Nee, einfach so hydraulisch am besten.
Ich glaube, das entspricht deiner Beschreibung. Ein massives Stück Beton. Das fällt, glaube ich, wirklich nicht so leicht um.
Die Domain war noch frei.
Ja, das war mal eine Weile in, dass man irgendwo den letzten Vokal weglässt.
Das ist sozusagen ein Zeichen für das letzte Quäntchen Effizienz, was aus dem Start-up noch rausgepresst wurde.
Aber ich glaube, die Erklärung, dass die Domain frei war, ist auch einfach eine sehr gute. Das war vielleicht noch aus Zeiten, wo es keine dreivzigtausend Top-Level-Domains gab. Hast du schon Metaebene.Berlin und so?
Nee, ich brauch auch nicht Metaebene Berlin. Ich hätte gerne mal metaebene.de, aber der Typ meldet sich bei mir nicht. Dabei habe ich ihm schon so oft so liebe Briefe geschrieben.
Und Punkt-Metebene ist dir zu teuer, wa?
Also wenn es das überhaupt gibt, ist es bestimmt zu teuer. Ich glaube auch nicht, dass jemand dafür eine Top-Level-Börse aufmacht. Aber mittlerweile lassen die auch jeden Scheiß durch. Also Top-Level-Domain ist jetzt irgendwie auch total durch. Mittlerweile ist irgendwie alles, was einen Punkt enthält, hat irgendwie einen Domain. Gibt es da die auch schon Punkt exe? Punkt com gibt es ja auch.
Wenn, dann will ich Punkt bad.
Punkt ini.
Punkt virus.
Das wären mal wirklich richtig geile Domains.
Du brauchst ja nur Punkt bad, dann kannst du noch was anderes als Subdomain und so.
Oh man, dass man da alles vollkommen verrückt macht. Ich glaub, die darf man nie in die Welt lassen.
Und Punkt ab gibt es aber schon, oder? Oh weia, das ist auch eine Schlacht.
Freak Show Punkt exe.
Ich pack jetzt diesen Beton-Klopper mal in meinen Wunschzettel.
Was kostet der?
60.
Das ist schon ein ziemlicher Klopper. Man muss doch nochmal die Url in unsere Dokumente reinwerfen hier. Da, wo ich nachher die...
Nee, aber welche Url? Die vom Hersteller direkt oder die Amazon-Url?
Ja, alles.
Alles. Gib mir alles.
Gib mir alles. Genau.
Wo willst du die hinhaben?
Na, hier in unser Work Flurry. Naja, das ist ganz gut für sowas. Ist ein bisschen müßig, wenn ich mir danach die ganzen Links nochmal aus dem Chat zusammensuchen muss.
Ich komm mir mit der Bedienung von diesem Teil immer noch nicht klar.
Ja, das ist leider auch nicht optimal.
Das ist für Superintelligente oder für ganz durch. Ich bin irgendwo dazwischen.
Alle Leute, mit denen ich irgendwie mal eine halbe Stunde erkläre, wie du das eigentlich laufen musst, die laufen ja dann immer gleich wieder weg.
Wo soll ich denn hier drin kloppen?
Liegt wahrscheinlich an den anderen, ne?
Wo bist denn gerade?
So läuft's, Dennis. Deine Medienkompetenz lässt auch zu wünschen, überig. Ich hab es auch erst geschafft, mir einen Apple Store-Termin zu...
Jetzt noch einen zweiten meinste, ja?
Wie einen zweiten?
Du hast doch letztes Mal schon erzählt, dass du einen hast. Und dass sie aber irgendwas gemacht haben. Und dass du noch mal kommen sollst. Und die dir nicht einen neuen gemacht haben, sondern du den selber machen musstest.
Was hab ich in der letzten Sendung schon erzählt?
Oder hast du das per...
Mir kommt das auch bekannt vor.
Tweet erzählt.
Hat er das nicht erzählt? Definitiv nicht.
Das hab ich dir wahrscheinlich im Club erzählt oder so. Na ja, auf jeden Fall war das alles erst letzte Woche. Und es wäre auch alles gut geworden, weil sie haben dann irgendwie dieses... Also ich wollte ja unbedingt da einen Termin haben, weil ich ja auch damit rechne, dass da also demnächst die Apokalypse über die hineinbricht. So ob der ganzen Leute, die sie dazu supporten haben und dieser Terminmangel erschien mir ja schon so ein erstes Zeichen zu sein. Aber das war dann wohl vielleicht auch nur temporär, keine Ahnung, auf jeden Fall habe ich dann tatsächlich mal da drauf geklickt und auf einmal gab es wieder Termine. Naja, und dann ist mein Telefon ein Batterietest unterzogen worden. Und es ist schon ganz interessant, was sie da so Auswertungstools haben. Die starten halt so eine App und lutschen dann irgendwie alle möglichen Betriebsdaten aus diesem Phone raus. Unter anderem können sie halt die ganze Ladehistorie der letzten, weiß ich nicht, irgendeines längeren Zeitraums, Wochen, Tage, Wochen ausziehen.
Und dann kriegst du jetzt so, ah Herr Prittler, wir sehen, wie sie ihr Telefon laden und gucken dann so ganz wissend und dich schuldig machend, oder wie?
Also wenn man falsch lädt, dann hat Apple was falsch gemacht, weil die können das ja verhindern, wenn sie meinen, das sollte jetzt nicht geladen werden, dann sollen sie einfach nicht laden, wenn ich Strom ranmache. Das ist ja deren Problem.
Nö, es war einfach relativ klar, dass mein Akku durch ist. Also einerseits hat er irgendwie 640 Ladezyklen wohl schon durchlebt und sie meinten halt so ab 520 würden sie für nichts mehr garantieren.
640 komplette, das ist allerdings ganz schön viel.
Ob das jetzt komplett ist und wann für sie ein Ladezykluswert ist angefangen, also wann sie anfangen zu zählen, kann ich dir nicht beantworten.
Ich glaube, man zählt einfach, wenn du halb entladen hast, dann ist es ein halber Ladezyklus irgendwie so.
Keine Ahnung. Auf jeden Fall war das...
Aber das sind ja über zwei Jahre, ne? Nee, knapp zwei Jahre.
Ja, je nachdem.
Na, wenn du jeden Tag lädst, was du ja wahrscheinlich tust.
Ja.
Na gut, dann ist es nicht immer ein ganzer, aber...
Das ist nicht mal zwei Jahre.
Nicht mal zwei Jahre, ja.
Angeblich hält das ja auch viel länger. Aber das kenne ich nicht. Also ich habe noch kein iPhone besessen, was irgendwie einen Tag durchgehalten hat. Also nicht, weil man vielleicht so standby, wenn es auf der Kommode liegen gelassen wird.
Ausgeschaltet im Schrank, das geht ganz gut.
Ja, also...
Also ich lade nicht täglich.
Auf jeden Fall sehen sie nicht nur, wann so geladen wurde, sondern sie sagen, ich bin mir gerade nicht so sicher, ich habe das leider nicht fotografiert, aber man konnte auch sehen, dass wenn... Man konnte das glaube ich noch mit CPU-Last korrelieren in dieser Grafik, oder war korreliert. Und auf jeden Fall gab es immer wieder diese Effekte, dass das Gerät unter CPU-Beanspruchung auf einmal der Meinung war, der Akku wäre niedrig, der stand, und kaum dass diese CPU-Last aber weg war, ging dann diese Kurve wieder nach oben. Das heißt, ohne dass das Gerät geladen wurde, nahm das Telefon auf einmal an. Da sei jetzt wieder mehr Ladung. Und das entspricht auch so ziemlich genau der User Experience. Wenn ich so Kamera gestartet habe, dass sich das Ding dann einfach mal ausgeschaltet hat, aber ich konnte es dann nach 20 Sekunden Problem wieder anschalten und noch eine Stunde betreiben.
Das heißt doch aber im Prinzip, dass der Innenwiderstand von dem Akku schon größer ist.
Das heißt, dass da auf jeden Fall alles nicht in Ordnung ist. Und ich hätte mir dann auch gleich einen neuen Akku einbauen lassen, aber das sollte dann irgendwie drei Stunden dauern. Und die Zeit hatte ich dann in dem Moment nicht, weil ich weiter musste.
Dann gehst du in so eine iPhone-Klinik und dann machen die das so billig.
Genau, dann hab ich Fehler 53.
Na ja, haben sie ja abgestellt jetzt.
Ja, na gut, nur für diesen, keine Ahnung. Ja, iPhone-Klinik, was auch immer. Ich mein, da kann man wahrscheinlich auch zu Gravis laufen. Die sind ja genauso autorisiert, da ein Akku zu tauschen. Mach ich vielleicht auch. Ist wahrscheinlich am Ende sogar noch ein Funken billiger. Das wär es jetzt nicht gewesen. Ich hätte das jetzt einfach gemacht, dann wäre das Ding irgendwie durch gewesen. Aber mir fehlt da halt die Zeit. Was bloß ein bisschen blöd war, ist, dass sie mir sozusagen in dem Moment ja nicht helfen konnten, weil ich nicht die Zeit hatte, aber sie dann auch nicht in der Lage waren, einem auch gleich noch einen Anschlusstermin zu klicken. Wovon ich ja jetzt mal ausgegangen wäre. Also mit so einer fertigen Diagnose und so weiter wär das ja auch ein überschaubarer Zeitrahmen gewesen. Man hätte in dem Sinne ja dann auch gleich die Reparaturzeit auch mit Buchen reservieren vorsehen können. Und dazu waren sie aber irgendwie nicht in der Lage. Da muss man dann irgendwie selber nochmal loslaufen und Apple Store Termin Bingo spielen.
Ja, vor allen Dingen, ich meine, eigentlich musst du ja nur das Ding da abwerfen und irgendwie dann drei Stunden später wieder abholen.
Das möchte man ja meinen, aber es ist ja so, dass sie dann immer noch diesen Aufnahmeprozess haben. Das heißt, da muss sie dann schon so einen Vogel mit dir hinstellen und dann muss dann nochmal alles unterschrieben werden und la und abgecheckt werden und Sicherheitsmechanismen und Pins und so weiter, dass sie das Ding halt auch wieder problemlos hochbekommen etc. Und dann musst du vielleicht sogar noch, keine Ahnung, musst du vielleicht noch dein Find My iPhone ausschalten und so was, bevor sie die Reparatur machen.
Damit du nicht siehst, wo sie den Akku tauschen.
Nee, das krieg ich jetzt gerade nicht zusammen erklärt, aber wenn sie jetzt signifikante, also wenn sie so Gerätewechsel, Platinwechsel oder sowas hast, wo sich dann die ID ändert, dann können sie das halt selber nicht ausschalten. Und deswegen musst du das machen und stellen sie sicher, dass du das gemacht hast, etc. Egal. Auf jeden Fall ist das jetzt nicht so, dass du einfach einen Termin machen kannst. Du kannst sagen, hier ist mein Telefon, ich geh dann gleich mal wieder. Nein, es gibt dann sozusagen in dem Moment noch mal so einen Prozess, den man durchlaufen muss. Und deswegen ist ein Termin erforderlich, aber den können sie dir halt nicht bereitstellen. Naja, wie auch immer. So ist das halt mit dem Store. Jetzt weiß ich zumindest, dass mein Telefon akkubraun ist und ansonsten ist alles in Ordnung. Ah ja, das hat die Sache leider etwas in die Länge gezogen. Ich hatte ja noch diesen mega obskuren Bug. Ich weiß gar nicht, ob ich das schon mal erzählt hab.
Einen? Zeitig.
Naja, kennst du dieses Gefühl?
Hast du nicht immer obskure Bugs?
Kann schon sein. Und vor allem, ich hab noch nie jemanden gefunden, der denselben Bug hatte. Aber ich hatte ihn gleich auf zwei Geräten. Gleichzeitig. Naja, und zwar kam das wirklich genau in dem Moment, wo iOS 9 installiert wurde. Und ich hab das auf meinem Telefon und auf meinem iPad Mini gemacht. Danach hatten beide denselben Bug. Und der Bug war, dass wenn das Gerät ausgeschaltet, also entweder runtergefahren wurde, oder sich selber runtergefahren hat und ich es dann wieder gebootet hab, nachdem es Strom hatte, oder einfach nur ausschalten und wieder einschalten, ging für 10 Minuten kein Netz.
Das hast du mal erzählt, ja.
Und zwar sowohl kein LTE-Netz, als auch WLAN-Netz. Und es war irgendwie alles bekloppt. Nach einer Viertelstunde war das alles wieder gut. Lösung des Problems, also eine richtige Lösung im Sinne von, ich dachte ja, jetzt hier, Bug des Monats, ne? Ich so, tüdeh, guck mal was ich für einen geilen Bug habe und so. Und dann denkst du ja gleich, dass dann sofort die Jalousien irgendwie runtergehen und so rote Warnlampen angehen und dann so drei...
Keine Information verlässt den Raum.
Apple-Techniker mit so weißen Overalls irgendwie so aus so einer Geheimwand herausstürzen, ne große Glasglocke über mein Telefon rüber stellen und dann irgendwie diesen Fehler lokalisieren und...
Dream on, Timme. Und dann?
Scheiß haben die sich dafür interessiert. Dann natürlich schon probiert, das noch zu beheben. Ich mach's kurz. Was geholfen hat, ist etwas, was ich bisher so noch nie gemacht habe, weil ich immer ein bisschen Angst davor hatte. Und zwar, wenn du dein iPhone löscht oder löschen möchtest, gibt's ja zwei Optionen. Nämlich Inhalte, ne, die erste Option heißt alle Einstellungen und das andere heißt Inhalte und Einstellungen löschen.
Genau, dann ist es wieder jungfräulich, wie man so schön sagt.
Genau, aber was würdest du vom Gefühl her so meinen, welche von den beiden destruktiver klingen?
Inhalte und Einstellungen.
Na gut, aber bei dem anderen Teil heißt es ja alle Einstellungen.
Ja, aber nur Einstellungen, aber nicht die Inhalte.
Aber es steht nicht Inhalte und alle Einstellungen, sondern nur so Inhalte und Einstellungen.
Da hat der Platz nicht mehr gereicht.
Wie auch immer. Alle Einstellungen hat auf jeden Fall geholfen. Und dann muss man nur seine ganzen WLAN-Passwörter wieder eingeben und so ein Kram.
Also dann ist man vielleicht auch diese ganzen komischen Wi-Fi-Hotspots los, die andauern, wenn man unterwegs ist, aufploppen.
Ja, das ist ganz hilfreich. Wobei ich mich ehrlich gesagt wunderbar rum, weil wenn die Dinger sowieso in der Keychain sind und man iCloud-Keychain benutzt und die sind da auch alle noch, ich weiß es nicht, wie auch immer. Auf jeden Fall ist das Problem jetzt weg und das Problem existiert nicht mehr. Insofern brauche ich nur noch einen neuen Akku und dann bin ich schon wieder ein Happy User. Dann müssen sie auch noch das mit dem Kalender fixen.
Und dann müssen sie noch... Aber ansonsten... Was haben die Römer je für uns getan?
Aber ich habe auch alle Einstellungen gelöscht kürzlich. Und Inhalte.
Und dann?
Ja, ich hab ja hier auf meinem Mac so seit Generatoren, also ich weiß nicht, also bestimmt vier OS-Releases einfach mal drüber installiert. Und ich hab es jetzt nicht mehr ausgehalten. Und hab dann mir eines Wochenendes ein Herz gefasst. Hab den Kapitän runtergeladen und ihn auf einen USB-Stick geschmissen. Dafür gibt es ja so ein tolles Kommando, wenn man einen El Capitan runterlädt. In den Untiefen des Paketes gibt es dann so ein Command, um das auf so einen USB-Stick zu kriegen.
Kannst du nicht eh über Netz installieren einfach?
Egal, ich wollte jetzt mal den USB-Stickweg gehen. Klar!
Wieso, da ist im Bundle ein Disk-Image drin und das brätst du auf einen Stick.
Ja, aber da gibt es ein Kommando, was dann alles dir gleich so richtig Partition-Table usw. alles schön macht. Dann gebootet und dann tatsächlich so erstmal in das Disk-Itility rein und weg damit, mein angesammelter Scheiß von Generatoren von Jahren. Und dann clean installed und das ist, ich muss sagen, ich hab's lange nicht gemacht und jetzt frage ich mich, wieso eigentlich? Das ist wirklich so eine schöne Erfahrung. Es dauert, aber es macht alles besser.
Na, ich hatte die Erfahrung jetzt in der Firma, weil nach dem Update von El Capitan war's das dann gewesen. Wir haben da so einen komischen VPN-Dingens und das VPN-Dingens guckt immer nach, ob der Viren-Scanner noch aktuell ist. Und der war's aber nicht mehr und es war nicht mehr möglich, den zu aktualisieren und dann ging irgendwie gar nichts mehr.
Dann musstest du auch.
Und dann hab ich gesagt, hier, komm, mach einfach neues Image drauf und gut ist.
Also ich hab gebootet, dann war das leer. Und dann normalerweise, wir haben ja schon oft darüber gesprochen, über unsere Clean-Install-Prozeduren, aber jetzt ich jahrelang nicht mehr. Und normalerweise habe ich mir dann immer so ein paar Sachen so noch wieder ins Home kopiert, von dem ich mir dann so einzelne Einstellungen, Application Support und so einzeln dann rüberziehen kann, wieder in die eigentliche Library. Aber das habe ich diesmal nicht gemacht, sondern ich saß halt, weil ich das am Samstag gemacht habe, dachte ich mir, okay, ich bin jetzt zwei Tage zu Hause und wenn ich was brauche, dann mache ich jetzt die Time Machine Platte ran und hol es mir manuell rüber oder hol es mir aus meinem Cloud-Backup von ARK. Und das habe ich erst mal so gemacht und dachte auch, ich wäre für den Montag arbeitstechnisch vorbereitet, habe mir meinen Airlang installiert und alles, was ich sonst so habe. Und dann habe ich natürlich festgestellt in meinem Backup, in der Cloud, da backe ich ja mein ganzes Home ab. Und so eigentlich so Library und so ganzen Scheiß. Aber eine Sache habe ich nicht gebacked up, die mich total in meinem Arbeitsflow gestört hat, und das war ETC Hosts. Weil da habe ich eine kilometerlange Liste von Shortcuts und Server auf IP-Mappings für unsere Infrastruktur. Und das ist halt auch mein Nachschlagewerk, so wenn ich nochmal für ein altes Spiel irgendwie nachrufe, wie war der Load Balancer nochmal, wie war die URL, und ich hab das halt so schön gruppiert. Also mein ETC Hosts Fall ist halt echt so ein, mein ganz persönliches Server-Telefonbuch. Und das hatte ich nicht, und das war nicht im Cloud-Backup drin, und dann saß ich halt so einen Tag lang da, SSH, keine Completion, Hostfall weg, nein. Und ja, das hab ich jetzt sofort in meinen Backup noch mit hinzugefügt in meinen Cloud-Backup, also das passiert mir nicht nochmal, aber ja, konnte ich dann halt auch zu Hause wieder rüber kopieren. Ich hab keine Applikation rübergezogen, sondern alles frisch installiert.
Aber wait a minute, das File müsste doch in deinem normalen Backup mit drin sein.
Ein Time Machine, ja, aber nicht im Cloud. Da hab ich nicht die ganze Disk drin.
Er hatte die Disk nicht mit.
Und zum Beispiel auch mein Audio-Setup, da hab ich mich ja auch sehr drauf gefreut, weil ich hab ja so in meinem Audio-Experimentierleben jetzt auch viele Plugins installiert und viel Schrott, und das legt sich einfach auch quer ins System an die unterschiedlichsten Orte. Und dann probierst du hier was, dann musst du so ein iLog, Pain in the Ass, wie heißt das, Dongle, Software, hast du nicht gesehen, Silvian? Egal, alles weggemacht. Und auch so die eine oder andere Software, wo ich jetzt nicht die Lizenz so richtig irgendwie, also wo mich die Lizenz auf, sagen wir mal, unofficiellem, inoffiziellem Wege erreicht hat, bin ich halt auch durchgegangen und dachte mir, okay, ich installiere jetzt die ganzen Sachen, die ich brauche und kaufe halt auch alles, was ich brauche. Also ich hab so richtig clean, rein Tisch gemacht. Das war halt auch eine moralische Reinigung. Und ja, jetzt ist mein Rechner, hab ich wieder irgendwie 200 GB frei auf der Platte. Und alles, was ich jetzt so in den letzten, in den letzten Wochen nicht vermisst hab, das bleibt dann halt auch auf der Backup. Das geht jetzt erstmal für immer und ewig verschollen. Also es ist halt ja auch immer so eine Entschlackung. Man denkt ja immer so, ich brauch das ja und das will ich auch immer dabei haben. Letztendlich benutzt man es oder ruft man es eh nie auf.
Ja, aber es gibt doch so viele Programme. Hast du auch die ganzen Prefs von allen Programmen weggeschmissen?
Also wie gesagt, ein, zwei kopier ich mir dann schon aus dem Backup wieder zurück. Aber zum Beispiel heute hab ich gerade erst gemerkt, ich hatte ja immer diesen Chatclient Linkinus für Irk. Hab ich gesehen, die Webseite gibt's gar nicht mehr, ist seit 2011 nicht mehr entwickelt. Jetzt chatte ich mit Irc in der Konsole gerade weil die App gibt's gar nicht mehr. Die wird dann halt gleich auch mal mit so Abandonware wird dann halt auch gleich weg recycelt, weil's die einfach gar nicht mehr gibt. Also ich hab keine alte Software so von Hand nochmal rüber kopiert bisher. Mein Homebrew hab ich auch komplett dargelassen, also mein User Local und hab das alles wieder von Hand mir zusammengehören.
Ja gut, da geht das ja ganz gut, aber ich hab halt so viele Programme, wo ich halt, was weiß ich, irgendwelche Hostlisten und Settings und Logins und so weiter, das alles von Hand, nee.
Ja, wie gesagt, ich hab meine Sachen eigentlich, also meine Keychain, die kopier ich halt immer rüber, das ist halt das Allerwichtigste.
Keychain und One Password, das braucht man natürlich, ne?
Mein Punkt SSH-Folder, aber der ist eh im Home drin, also meine Dot-Files und so, die kopier ich halt auch natürlich rüber. Aber Apps, zum Beispiel, hab ich's endlich geschafft, TextMate 1, also den hatte ich ja auch immer drauf und TextMate 2 so daneben. Letztendlich hab ich immer TextMate 1 dann aufgemacht, jetzt hab ich nur TextMate 2 installiert. Das ist jetzt auch ein Generationswechsel. Und dann, ja dann, wie gesagt, ein paar Mal denkt man sich schon so, ach die Software gibt's auch gar nicht mehr, naja, ich hab ich eh nie benutzt und so, ne? Und dann hab ich einen Wechsel gemacht, der relativ fundamental war. Ich hab ja statt Little Snitch, was alle ja so meistens benutzen, hab ich ja hands-off benutzt, weil das damals halt auch so dieses Feature, oder das hat's auch immer noch, dass man ja nicht nur Network-Access, sondern auch File-Access, also File-System-Access verbieten konnte in der App.
Ja, vor allem nicht nur von innen nach außen, sondern auch von außen nach innen, ne?
Weiß ich jetzt gar, ehrlich gesagt gar nicht genau. Auf jeden Fall dachte ich mir, okay, ich geb jetzt mal Little Snitch nochmal, auch in diesem Zuge eine Chance, weil eine Lizenz für Hands-Off hab ich eh, und das wird halt auch nicht so richtig weiterentwickelt. Und bei OpDev oder wie die heißen, sind die ja schon so ein bisschen fitter oder öfter so dabei, ne?
Oh ja, die sind extrem beständig sogar.
Ja, und jetzt hab ich halt auch in dem Zuge halt, weil ich wieder so da saß, okay, jetzt muss ich mir wieder so eine kleine Personal Firewall installieren. Okay, probier ich mal Little Snitch, jetzt hab ich wieder Little Snitch installiert, weil der halt so ein bisschen snitchiger ist halt, ne? Die hatten ja übrigens so ein Tool, kürzlich released, ne, Micro Snitch oder wie der hieß, wo es darum geht, dass sie dir Bescheid sagen, wenn irgendeine Applikation dein Mikrofon oder deine Kamera access und fragt dich sozusagen, ob du das erlauben willst. Ja, ich glaube so heißt das wohl.
Wenn es nach mir geht, könnte Apple da auch mal Jails einführen, also hier dieses Sandboxen wie auf dem Phone.
Ja, siehst du mal, hier mein Cleaninstall hat schon eine tolle Information hervorgebracht. Habe ich allerdings noch nicht installiert. Ich hatte noch eine... Ich hatte noch eine Littlesnitch II Lizenz und konnte dann günstig für 14 Euro upgraden. Dann habe ich erstmal nur den Littlesnitch genommen. Und eine tolle bahnbrechende Entdeckung hatte ich halt auch noch bei El Capitan Upgrade. Das hat auch was damit zu tun, was ich letztes Mal erwähnt hatte mit HostMux und TMux, die große TMUX versus Screen Diskussion. Das nämlich das El Capitan Terminal Mouse Event jetzt kann. Schrecklich. Nach Jahrzehnten. Kannste ja ausschalten.
Hab ich ja auch.
Aber ich persönlich finde das total geil, weil jetzt kann ich endlich auch den Wim direkt in der Konsole benutzen bzw. in TMUX halt auch die Fenster resizen und Copy und Paste und scrollen.
Ja, aber du bist in so einem VI und willst mal hochscrollen, weil du weißt vorher noch irgendwie in deinem List Output oder so hast du noch was, was du in deinem VI Fenster jetzt brauchst und willst hochscrollen und dann scrollt er halt innerhalb von VI und denkst dir, what the fuck. Ja, kannst du ausschalten, musst du dann aber.
Nee, da gibt auch ein Modifier Key dafür. Wenn ich richtig informiert bin.
Na, was mich wahnsinnig gemacht hat, war, dass er, ich wollte scrollen und er macht unten die History der Kommandos, dreht er dann durch und dann denkst du so, was soll denn das jetzt?
Also bei mir in der Shell macht er das nicht mit den Kommandos, aber. Also auf jeden Fall, ich persönlich finde Maus Events toll, denn ich fand iTerm hatte dieses Feature ja schon immer und ich fand iTerm immer scheiße und alle Kollegen fragen mich, wieso findest du den iTerm scheiße? Es hat doch so viele Features und ich meine, ja genau, weil das hat Feature Creep ohne Ende. Die haben jetzt irgendwie ein Feature eingebaut, dass du Images cutten kannst und dann zeigen sie die Images im Terminal an. Und lauter so... Das ist jetzt das Feature, das Neue in der neuen iTerm Beta.
Was, du machst Cut-Bild auf Standard Out und dann ist da ein Bild?
Ja, guck mal, iTerm, also vielleicht ist es nicht Cut, aber es ist auf jeden Fall, sie können jetzt da Bilder im Terminal erinnern, wenn du iTerm 2 Beta oder irgendwie so, da haben sie das announced. Oder du kannst wahrscheinlich googeln, wär wahrscheinlich schneller nach iTerm 2 und Images. Irgendwo gab's da die Beta und da war das, glaube ich, jetzt freigeschaltet. Auf jeden Fall, das war der einzige Grund, warum ich immer mal damit geliebäugelt hab, iTerm 2 zu benutzen. Jetzt kann das das OS X Terminal glücklicherweise und jetzt mach ich das mit weiter Terminal. Ich such dir das mal kurz raus, dass wir mit dem Images cutten. Moment, wo war denn das? iTerm 2, Display, Image. Und dann gibt's hier dieses tolle... Genau, Version 3 Beta ist das und... Wo ist jetzt dieser Screenshot davon? Das war halt auch total sauer.
Die anderen Screenshots sind aber noch von vor drei Versionen.
Also es gibt einen Skript, das heißt Image cut und dann... Hier warte, ich schicke dir den Link in den...
Auf der Feature-Seite unter Inline Images.
Also die machen halt einfach so viel und das ist einfach nur ein fucking Terminal. Also das ist wirklich...
Es geht aber eh nur mit lokalen Files, oder wie versteht ihr das?
Aber was muss man denn dazu eingeben?
Na Image cut.
Ja, das ist halt ein Skript, was wahrscheinlich damit iTerm noch gleich geschippt wird und...
Ja, aber das geht nur mit lokalen Bildern, richtig? Wenn ich irgendwo remote bin, dann geht das natürlich nicht.
Das hab ich nicht ausprobiert.
Keine Ahnung, wenn du das pipest oder so? Im remote Terminal halt nicht.
Image cut ist ein Bash-Skript, kannst du dir runterladen. Ist ein Bash-Skript, das sagt ja schon wieder alles.
Naja, wer hatte denn diesen tollen, diesen tollen...
Bug...
.zwanzig Jahre alten Bug da drin? War doch die Bash.
Aber, genau, also das war so eigentlich von dem Clean Install die dramatischsten Sachen, außer dass das Font-Rendering sich auch geändert hat im Terminal und mich das total nervt. Und die Messages-App, also ich weiß nicht, ob es daran liegt, dass ich kein Retina-Display habe, aber der Font in der Messages-App ist so ekelhaft hässlich gerendert.
Könnte sein, dass es daran liegt, ja.
Also, mit anderen Worten, du bist zufrieden, du bist jetzt glücklich, dass du auf den Kapitän gegangen bist und fragst dich, warum du das nicht schon früher gemacht hast.
Vor allen Dingen, warum ich nicht früher einen Clean Install gemacht hab. Weil diese reinigende Kraft des Clean Installs ist wirklich unbeschreiblich. Also, ich hab mich echt gefreut. Ich weiß, dass es Arbeit ist.
Das Purgatorium.
Dass dieses manuelle noch mal alles zusammensuchen und so weiter. Aber danach merkst du einfach, der Rechner, der atmet jetzt auf beiden Lungenhälften.
Also, ich wüsste, wenn ich wirklich einen richtigen Clean, Clean, Clean Install, im Sinne von auch alle Prefs aller Programme, die ich verwende.
Nein, wie gesagt, ein paar kopier ich mir schon.
Boah, das dauert so lange.
Aber du kopierst ja den ganzen Pref-Orden, oder was?
Dann die ganzen Dictionaries.
Ja, das meinste, wie lange es aber auch immer dauert, so ein total zerfahrenes System irgendwie am Leben zu halten. Das dauert ja auch. Nur verteilt da.
Vor allen Dingen am Ende des Tages. So viele Tools braucht man ja auch gar nicht jeden Tag. Man hat so viel Scheiß da drin, den man mal ausprobiert hat. Das ist wirklich krass. Also, ich hab ja mein Preferences-Order vorher nachher nebeneinander gelegt. Und das ist einfach Kilometer Scheiß, der da drin ist. Und wie gesagt, mit den Audio-Tools und Plugins, die ich so ausprobiert hab, an welchen Stellen im System sich da diese VST und AU und sonst was-Dateien ablegen. Das hab ich auch endlich alles weggeschmissen und jetzt wieder nur die Plugins frisch installiert, die ich wirklich auch regelmäßig benutze. Gleich die frischen Updates dafür bekommen.
Alles super.
Sprudelt sauber, sprudelt frisch.
Ich mach das eigentlich vor allen Dingen dann, wenn ich einen Rechner wechsle. Dann fang ich frisch an mit dem neuen Rechner.
Hab ich letztens auch gemacht. Hab mir eine neue SSD geholt und hab frisch installiert. Hab aber dann meinen Backup eingespielt. Und ja, tut. Backup hat mich schon frisch.
Dann hatte ich nicht eingespielt. Das hab ich bei dem Rechner gemacht. Und dann halt einfach so, ah, was brauchst du?
Also vor allen Dingen auch Application Support, was da rumlungelt. Und dann in diesen Containers, wenn du Apps aus dem App Store hast, die haben ja da auch ihre eigene File-Struktur und cashen da rein, was du auch so, wenn du mal die Caches klärst, nie erwischt oder so. Und das bleibt dann erstmal alles weg.
Der Trick ist, dass du in Library Preferences reingehst mit ls-lart irgendwie nach Zeit, der das ausgeben lässt. Die neuesten sind dann unten. Und dann gehst du mal oben hin, welche Preferences schon seit 10 Jahren nicht mehr berührt wurden und dann weißt du, ah, das tun. Dann kannst du die auch alle mal entfernen.
Das kannst du auch im Finder machen.
Ja, ich kenn diese Strategien und hatte da immer so hab dann doch wieder so festgestellt, dass es so Prefs gibt, die ich seit 5 Jahren nicht anfasse, aber die echt gold sind.
Ja, du weißt ja zu welchem Programm du dran erinnert.
Aber deswegen hat man ja einen Fullback-Up noch.
Ja, aber das bedeutet auch, du kommst zwar nach 1, 2, 3 Tagen vielleicht auf so ein 90% Level, aber dann bist du halt noch mal 3 bis 5 Wochen damit beschäftigt und vor allem sind es immer so Sachen wie oh, jetzt bist du remote, jetzt musst du ja irgendein Key, irgendein SSH-Key, irgendein Excess, irgendein fucking Passwort, Server, wo war denn das denn?
Deswegen ist ja der schlaue Moment, so wie ich das mache, neue SSD einbauen, alte rausnehmen, installieren, Backup einspielen, dann arbeiten, alte SSD erst mal 2, 3 Wochen links liegen lassen, wenn du sie noch mal brauchst, rangehen und dir die Files holen, wenn da noch was sein sollte und wenn du nach so einem Monat da nicht mehr dran warst, dann weißt du alles klar, da wird wohl nichts mehr sein und backploppen.
Hab ich ja gerade auch genauso beschrieben, nur dass ich halt nur ein Wochenende hatte und das Einzige, was ich wirklich vergessen hatte, war dieses ETC-Host-File. Also die wichtigen Sachen habe ich ja eben, Cloud-Backup, sodass ich mir die halt auch von überall her holen kann.
Ja, bloß manchmal brauchen wir auch Clean Cloud.
Clean Cloud?
Ja, aber wie wir jetzt gelernt haben, wenn wir vielleicht zum nächsten Thema kommen, Cloud-Backup ist eh nicht so.
Also ich habe zum Beispiel auch mit diesem, ich meine, das ist wahrscheinlich auch einfach der Schritt in die Hölle mit dieser ganzen Cloud, aber ich habe so Sachen wie, auf einem meiner Macs tauchen die Kontakte alle doppelt auf. Das heißt da ist so links zweimal iCloud. Steht aber nur einmal in der Liste drin, weißt du? Nimmst sie raus und beide weg, tust sie rein, du sitzt zweimal da, wo du auch echt nicht genau weißt, wen du jetzt eigentlich als erstes umbringen sollst. Und man ist auch so hilflos irgendwie, das ist wirklich schlimm. Ich gucke gerade mal hier so durch meine Programme, was mich denn nun wahrscheinlich extrem beschäftigen würde, aber es sind auch so Sachen, die ich immer so in das System dazu installiere, wie zum Beispiel diese ganzen Dictionaries, diese ganzen Thesauren und Übersetzungs-Dictionaries.
Eine Sache, die mir auch aufgefallen ist, ich hab ja früher mal Outbank benutzt auf dem Mac, das ist ja auch so quasi Abandonware mittlerweile. Und auch in diesem Zuge des El-Kapitan-Wechsels habe ich jetzt auch mal Money-Money quasi konfiguriert.
Du hast jetzt aber Outbank, du meinst, dass die Desktop-Version nicht die auf dem Phone.
Aber weißt du, das sind halt so die Sachen dann, wenn man eben die Programme nicht mit rüber nimmt und sagt so, so, was liegt an und dann feststellt halt, ah, Moment mal, diese gamme Software, die kommt mir jetzt auch nicht mehr auf dem Rechner.
Ja, das stimmt schon. Das ist so ein bisschen Scheidung. Man muss da einfach mal so durch.
Ein bisschen Scheidung wagen, ja.
Ja, und manchmal gibt es auch wirklich solche Platzhirschen, die man immer benutzt und man weiß irgendwie auch schon gar nicht mehr warum. Eigentlich nur, weil man es schon immer gemacht hat. Und man freut sich geradezu auf den Tag, wo die mal irgendwie gegen die Wand fahren, dass man wirklich mal gezwungen ist, die Alternativen zu testen. Money Money ist ein gutes Beispiel, wenn man mal vor allem sieht, wie schnell Money Money von so vier, fünf Accounts seine Updates macht. Machst du so Refresh, so, da ist Outbank noch irgendwie dabei, dir eine Warnung anzuzeigen, dass es jetzt vielleicht dauern könnte oder so.
Eine Sache, die ich auch noch neu evaluiert habe, war Parallels oder Vmware. Da erinnert sich ja auch mit jeder Generation immer so ein bisschen das Kräfteverhältnis. Das kann man dann auch erstmal wieder neu recherchieren und lauter so Sachen.
Das ist super. Also ich hab irgendwann Parallels aufgegeben, weil Virtual Box besser wurde als Parallels. Da dachte ich so, hey, das kann nicht sein.
Aber performance-mäßig war das noch nie der Fall.
Ja, aber einfach vom User-Feeling und so weiter her, das hat es einfach irgendwie nicht gebracht.
Ja, mittlerweile ist das ganz schnuffig eigentlich.
Inzwischen bin ich bei Fusion gelandet. Ich finde das eigentlich ganz gut.
VmWare Fusion.
Die nehmen sich nicht so viel letztendlich. Mittlerweile, ich hab jetzt Parallels benutzt, weil meine, weiß nicht, hab halt Vms in Parallels. Und flutscht. Also das ist auch erstaunlich. Da gab es so eine Seite, wo sie so Performance-Graphs pro Version zwischen Virtual Box, VmWare und Parallels hatten. Und VmWare und Parallels, die sind halt einfach Kilometer entfernt, Performance-mäßig bei ungefähr allem. Und dann gibt's so bei jeder, also VmWare hat jetzt in den letzten Versionen halt auch irgendwie immer so ganz schön nah, also ist ganz schön da rangekommen. Anyway, so genug vom Clean Install. Alle Einstellungen löschen. Ist eine gute Sache, kann man machen.
Ja, ich hab jetzt ja auch gleich mal ein paar Sachen noch.
Hast du gleich mal Clean Install veranlasst.
Ja, was ich hier alles so rumliegen habe, ich war ganz überrascht.
Bestimmt, weil du es für irgendeine Porno-Seite gebraucht hast. Ja, wozu sollte man das sonst benutzen?
Die alten Herren sprechen aus Erfahrung hier.
Ja, ich überleg gerade, es gab mal was, was ich mal...
Sky benutzt Silverlight, du kannst nicht noch rausreden, du wolltest Fußball gucken.
So, jetzt hab ich auch mal wieder ein bisschen Platz geschafft, nicht schlecht. Ich hab trotzdem Angst.
Irgendwann wird es auch dich ereilen und dann werden wir wahrscheinlich eine Sondersendung hier machen, wenn Tim Clean installen macht.
Nächstes Thema, sag ich.
Ja, nächstes Thema. Ja, wir müssen mal hier über Apple rettet die Welt oder auch nicht reden.
Apple gegen die Welt.
Ja, genau. Also ihr werdet es ja sicherlich alle irgendwie mitbekommen haben. Es war ja so richtig nicht zu vermeiden, das Thema. Dass Apple vom FBI gezwungen werden soll, da einen Zugang zu legen zu dem Terror-Phone. Welcome to the Terror-Phone. Also von diesem Shooting, was ja in den USA nur dann irgendwelche News erzeugt, wenn es nicht von weißen Männern gemacht wird. Oder Polizisten.
Ja, aber ich meine, was soll das? In Amerika erschießt jemand jemand anders. Das ist doch keine News. Also das ist irgendwie...
Nee, für uns ist das jetzt keine News. Aber es ist halt immer noch eine News, wenn es halt irgendwie Leute machen, die irgendwie Allah akbar rufen, während sie das machen oder irgendwas Vergleichbares. Da drinnen sind alle total durch. Darum geht es ja, ne? Ich habe irgendwie einen Tweet gesehen, wo so eine Statistik war, damit wie viele Leute in diesem Jahr bereits von der Polizei erschossen wurden. Und es gab keinen einzigen Tag, wo es weniger als sechs waren.
Keinen Tag, wo es weniger als sechs waren? Rass.
30.000 Leute werden im Jahr erschossen, oder?
Von der Polizei, würde ich merken. Nicht überhaupt erschossen, sondern von der Polizei.
Das sind aber jetzt nicht die 30.000, sondern die sechs am Tag.
Von den 30.000 habe ich nichts gesagt, weiß ich nicht. Also ich habe das auch nicht in dem Moment dann komplett hinterher recherchiert. Von daher, wenn es jetzt einer besser weiß. Aber dass das ein Problem ist, glaube ich, kann als...
Das ist irgendwie offensichtlich.
Und ein befreundeter Comedian hat dann so getwittert, übrigens Joshwithpowers auf Twitter, falls ihr interessiert seid. Der meinte dann, als hier dieser Uber-Mörder war, also dieser Typ, der irgendwie Uber-Fahrer war und dann die Leute gekillt hat, meinte dann so hinterher noch, also er ist auch Amerikaner, das Traurige ist, dass wir jetzt Uber mehr reglementieren werden oder regulieren werden als die Waffengesetze. Also so die Essenz aus dieser ganzen Diskussion, oh mein Gott, wir müssen die Uber-Fahrer besser überprüfen. Keine Ahnung. Und ja, das ist leider auch die Meinung.
Genau so, jetzt ist auch das Smartphone, wird jetzt irgendwie als gefährlicher angesehen. Das ist die Tatsache, dass man sich jederzeit in so einem Shop mal Repetiergewehre holen kann. Ach, das ist alles so kaputt. Na gut, da müssen wir uns sozusagen nicht unmittelbar mit beschäftigen, aber mittelbar schon, weil Apple sich jetzt halt querstellt. Das FBI kam irgendwie an und meinte so, ja, wir haben da so ein Telefon, und da kommen wir nicht ran. Da kriegen wir keine aktuellen Daten von. Und dieses Telefon befindet sich halt in so einem Zustand, es ist halt an sich noch operabel, will aber den Passcode haben. Und nun hat halt Apple das iPhone so abgesichert seit iOS 8, dass eben auf dem Telefon alle Daten ja grundsätzlich verschlüsselt vorliegen. Also sozusagen der SSD-Speicher, der eigentliche Flash-Speicher. Und beim RAM bin ich mir jetzt gerade gar nicht so sicher.
Ich hab hier so ein Artikel gecryptet.
Moment, ich wollte das erstmal zusammenfassen, weil vielleicht nicht unbedingt jeder so verfolgt hat. Und es war wohl auch so, dass dieses Telefon eingestellt war, ein Backup auf iCloud zu machen.
Und die haben auch alle Backups.
Und dieses Backup hat Apple denen auch gegeben, dem FBI.
Aber es war halt 6 Wochen alt schon.
Genau, es war 6 Wochen alt. Und der Grund, warum dieses Telefon noch kein neues Backup angelegt hat in den 6 Wochen, ist unklar. Das kann halt verschiedene Gründe haben. Grund 1, das Telefon gehörte ja nicht diesem Attentäter, sondern es gehörte dieser, was war das, ein Krankenhaus, Health Department, irgendwas. Genau, das Höllen-Department. Und kann sein, dass das Gerät sozusagen nur dann Backup macht, wenn es eben in einen trusted W-Laden kommt. Und es kann sein, dass das halt nur da war und dass dieses Telefon da nicht da war. Auf jeden Fall stellt sich jetzt irgendwie das FBI auf die Hinterbeine und versucht halt aus Apple irgendeine technische Maßnahme heraus zu pressen bzw. eine spezielle Software, mit der sie eben dieses Telefon freischalten könnten. Und technisch wäre das wohl machbar, weil sie ja schon irgendwie die Möglichkeit, also ich bin mir nicht so ganz so sicher, ich bin mir da nicht so hundertprozentig sicher, aber man kann nicht komplett ausschließen, dass sie unter Umständen in der Lage wären, diesem Telefon von außen schon irgendwie ein Update noch irgendwie auch auf Fernwärme eben da irgendwie rein zu drücken. Weiß ich aber jetzt auch nicht so ganz genau.
Ist aber auch schon eine neue Information, dass die das können, ne?
Na so wie ich es verstanden hab, geht es wohl darum, auszuschalten, dass wenn du ein Passcode versuchst und so und so oft fehlt daneben liegst, dass es dann langsamer geht, sondern die wollten eine Möglichkeit haben...
Ja, aber dazu müssten sie ja auch irgendwas von Remote ändern.
Ja, die wollten eine Möglichkeit haben, den Passcode brute-forcen zu können.
Ja, aber nicht nur das, sondern sie wollten auch das elektronisch machen. Die wollten auch nicht auf dem Disko tippen, sondern wollten das irgendwie über eine Schnittstelle machen, von extern. Also dazu brauchten sie eine neue Software auf dem Phone.
Genau, wobei ich jetzt nicht wirklich die Frage beantworten könnte, ob Apple eine Chance hätte, diesem Telefon tatsächlich in dem Zustand, in dem es sich gerade befindet, einen...
Na, wenn sie es nicht könnten, dann würden sie das jetzt genau so sagen. Also heißt das, sie können es. Deswegen stellt sich Apple ja so auf die Hinterbeine, weil das genau das Problem ist.
Kann gut sein. Lustig in dieser ganzen Sache ist auch noch, dass die Polizei, also das FBI, hat wohl dann dieser Gesundheitsbude...
Der durchs Telefon gehört...
.dem eigentlichen Owner und damit auch der iCloud-Account. Die haben sie dazu genötigt, diese Passwort-Recovery anzuschmeißen. Das heißt, sie haben das Passwort geändert.
Ja, aber das macht auch ein bisschen Sinn. Weil ich nehme an, das ist ja auch ein Problem, dass die Behörde dieses Passwort hat und der Typ halt auch, der Terrorist. Ja, aber er hat es ja. Das heißt, wenn der das noch irgend wem anders gegeben hat, und es reicht ja, dass er das hätte machen können, dann könnte die Person jetzt von Remote dieses Telefon löschen lassen. Deswegen haben sie das abgestellt, damit da keiner mehr herankommt außer sie selbst. Sie haben dabei aber vergessen, dass dadurch dieses Backup nicht mehr getriggert werden kann. Hast du die Geschichte jetzt gerade schon erzählt gehabt? Also die haben das Passwort deswegen ändern lassen, nämlich weil das der Grund war. Und gleichzeitig waren sie aber mit Apple in den Gesprächen, wie sie noch irgendwie an die Daten rankommen könnten. Also da ging es ja erstmal noch nicht um das, was sie jetzt von Apple verlangen, sondern die sind ja schon seit Januar da mit Apple am Machen. Und Apple hat ja grundsätzlich auch nichts dagegen, denen da zu helfen und haben denen ja auch die ganzen alten iCloud-Backups gegeben. Und dann hat Apple gesagt, naja, noch eine Idee wäre, um an die restlichen Daten des Telefons ranzukommen, indem wir das Telefon halt zu einer bekannten WLAN-Station bringen und gucken, ob das Telefon, wenn es halt in einem WLAN ist und wenn es Strom hat, dass es automatisch wieder halt ein Backup auslöst. Und das ging dann aber nicht mehr, weil das FBI ja die Apple-ID hat ändern lassen. Und dann würde das Telefon, kann dann kein iCloud-Backup mehr machen. Also das ist sozusagen nicht das lokale Passwort, das man ja für das Backup braucht, sondern die Apple-ID und die war dann halt anders, also das Passwort.
Ja, und vor allem, sie hätten nicht unbedingt das Passwort jetzt ändern müssen, um das zu verhindern, weil sie hätten sicherlich Apple auch noch dazu bekommen, das explizit für diesen Account, dieses Löschens, dieses Demol-Löschen abzuschalten.
Ja, aber das war wahrscheinlich so ein Standard-Procedure, was die da machen, oder irgendwie so. Das war auch ein paar Stunden, nachdem sie den Typen halt erschossen haben oder sein Telefon in ihren Besitz gebracht haben. Und dann haben die wahrscheinlich noch nicht so weit reisen gedacht und auch noch nicht mit Apple gesprochen, zu dem Zeitpunkt, an dem ich meine, oder noch nicht allzu viel.
Naja, auf jeden Fall machen sie da jetzt einen riesen Tamtam drum. Und Apple macht jetzt auch einen riesen Tamtam drum. Über die Motivation kann man sicherlich geteilter Meinung sein. Es macht so ein bisschen den Eindruck, als ob das FBI halt hier auch versucht, so Apple da mehr oder weniger öffentlich in die Knie zu zwingen. Nach dem Motto, ihr seid ja hier alle, ihr fördert ja den Terrorismus und das übliche Spielchen, haben sich aber irgendwie so richtig, ja, haben wohl nicht damit gerechnet, dass Tim Cook sich da so dermaßen quer stellt.
Ja, aber was ich nicht ganz verstehe ist, wenn das FBI Apple braucht, um da eine neue Software zu erstellen, damit diese Beschränkungen da umgangen werden, dann liegt das ja wohl da dran, weil nur Apple das kann, weil nur Apple den Key hat zum Signieren von neuer Software, damit das Telefon diese Software überhaupt annimmt. Wenn das so ist, warum kann dann Apple nicht eine Software erstellen, die genau die Bedingungen des FPIs erfüllt, gleichzeitig aber auch reinkoden, dass das nur genau mit diesem Gerät funktioniert, weil das FBI kann das ja auch nicht wieder raushacken, weil dann wär's ja nicht mehr signiert. Also eigentlich müsste das doch so gehen, wenn der Vorgang mit diesem Signieren so ist und anders kann ich es mir nicht vorstellen. Aber wenn es nicht signiert wird, dann würde das FBI sich die Software wahrscheinlich selber schreiben, auch wenn es teurer wird. Oder sie hätten sie schon längst geschrieben in Ruhe. So schnell geht das jetzt natürlich nicht, aber dann hätten sie es ja schon längst mal machen können in der Vergangenheit.
Ich glaube, das ist der Punkt, an dem es irgendwo auch zu einer grundsätzlichen Debatte wird. Und Apple auch einfach auch gar keinen Bock hat, sich sozusagen an der Stelle zum Handlanger zu machen. Weil sie wollen eigentlich diese Telefone schlicht und ergreifend mit dem Argument verkaufen, ist sicher Punkt. Und es gibt da nicht ein vielleicht, können sie dann doch ran, wenn sie lange genug fragen und noch mal eine Ausnahme und noch mal eine Ausnahme und wenn wir einmal so einen Code erstellen, gibt es vor allem keinen Grund mehr, das Zweite Mal Nein zu sagen.
Die FBI hat jetzt schon nachgelegt. Sie wollen ja schon für 12 oder 16 weitere Phones irgendwie, wollen sie jetzt ja schon geöffnet haben. Die erhöhen natürlich jetzt alle. Also wahrscheinlich kommen jetzt alle anderen FBI-Bundesbehörden irgendwie aus dem Keller und sagen, wir haben doch auch hier und die Chinesen und die Russen und die Deutschen und wer weiß nicht, wer kommt, verstehe auch demnächst alles und die Liste ist lang.
Irgendso ein District-Thorny sagt ja davon, dass er noch im Keller 100 liegen hat, die er auch gerne mal entschlüsselt haben würde.
Ja, das ist ja auch genau das Absurde. Also die USA als Burden-Einheit hacken also jetzt auf den Herstellern rum und wollen immer maximal Backdoor-Zugang, Master-Schlüssel, was auch immer gerade so zu haben ist. Key Escrow, diese ganze Diskussion, die im Prinzip schon seit 30 Jahren läuft oder seit 20, mindestens 25.
Je nachdem, wen du fragst.
Und dann blätterst du so in den News-Seiten ein weiter und dann so Obama kritisiert, dass die Chinesen da irgendwie Unsicherheit, Software in ihre Router und was weiß ich für Produkte reinbauen. Machen aber im Prinzip genau das gleiche Spiel. Das ist natürlich auch eine der Stoßrichtungen von Apple, dass sie halt sagen, naja, was auch immer wir da so an Backdoor-Optionen und kann man irgendwie umgehen, für den Fall das da reinbauen, das stimmt ja auch. Umso unsicherer wird das Ganze. Und sie wollen halt nicht die selben Leute, die sich eigentlich den ganzen Tag darüber hinkommen, wie man nicht reinkommt, sozusagen noch mal eine Stunde am Tag damit beschäftigen lassen, wie sie das, was sie da gerade...
Wie sie doch reinkommen.
Ja, wie man dann doch wieder reinkommt. Ich meine, das wird die Sache ja dann auch echt ad absurdum. Und ich hab auch so den Eindruck, das ist jetzt auch wieder so eine Bauchinterpretation. Aber ich hab so das Gefühl, mindestens Tim Cook oder sagen wir zumindest mal die Vorstandsetage, ich denk mal, die dürften sich da halbwegs einig sein, die haben jetzt so DJ ausgerufen. Also die haben gerade einfach so richtig überhaupt gar keinen Bock auf diese Idioten. Und die sind halt auch einfach vom Kopf her erstmal grundsätzlich an der richtigen Stelle.
Ja, was der Snowden hat ja geschrieben, dass jetzt die User-Daten vom Asset zu Liability werden. Was heißt, dass Apple jetzt demnächst, weil die eben genau gar keinen Bock drauf haben und die einzig wahre Antwort für das FBI könnte ja nur sein, also ihr könnt da verlangen, was ihr wollt, wir können das einfach nicht mehr, das geht nicht. Ich hoffe, dass für iOS 10 jetzt wahrscheinlich nicht mehr, aber für 11 dann halt das so in diesen Secure Layer da auf diesem Armchip, wie auch immer die das da nennen, wenn der das dann so gut kann, dass sie das so einbauen, dass das halt in der Hardware drin ist, dass deine 10 Versuche in die Hardware reingehen und wenn die Hardware nach 10 mal, dass nicht das Richtige ist, dass es dann gelöscht wird und dass du da so viele Updates einspielen kannst, wie du willst, die Hardware rückt das halt einfach nicht raus und macht auch dieses Zeitmanagement, dass du halt nicht so schnell probieren kannst, alles in Hardware in so einem kleinen Chip und ohne den geht da nix und dann ist Ruhe im Karton Und dann sagen sie im FBI, Badge Badge!
Also meines Wissens ist das auch schon so bei den neuen Geräten?
Na anscheinend ja noch nicht so perfekt.
Moin, es handelt sich um ein 5C.
Ja, ich weiß.
Also es ist sozusagen...
Das kann das noch nicht meins sagen.
Also, es gab da auch so ein Artikel, hab ich da, das hat noch nicht gesynkt. Ich pack's mal in den Chat. Der heißt, weil Tim Cook ist so furious! Und da wird auch nochmal schön eigentlich zusammengefasst, wie diese iPhone-Encryption und Signierung und so weiter.
Den hatten wir ja auch schon mal als Gast ja in Gernot, ne?
Und da steht eigentlich ziemlich ganz so schön zusammengefasst, wie das funktionieren sollte im idealen Fall. Wir müssen uns denn weiter runter, es geht noch ein bisschen vor Geschichte und so weiter. Aber genau, dann... Also, es ist halt viel Text, kann man jetzt nicht so mal eben überfliegen, vielleicht nachher, wenn wir über...
Andere Sachen reden.
Andere Sachen reden, kann Dennis das ja nochmal studieren und uns eine Management Summary am Ende geben.
Ich hatte den auch schon mal gelesen, aber auch nur auf die Schnelle so überflogen.
Naja, ich meine, so Krypto, wenn sie funktioniert, ist eh immer schwer zu erklären.
Aber falls halt die Herrschaftener an den Hörgeräten auch nochmal das sozusagen sich reinfahren wollen, ist das auf jeden Fall ein ganz guter Artikel.
Auf jeden Fall ist das jetzt eine sehr, ja, difficile Geschichte für Apple natürlich, weil sie ja am Ende, wenn jetzt irgendwie so ein High Court beschließt mit ihr müsst das jetzt machen, sie natürlich dann auch nur begrenzte Möglichkeiten haben.
Es ist ja noch kein High Court, das ja da wird zu machen.
Na gut, aber das kann jetzt alles natürlich in diese Richtung hocheskalieren. Das ist jetzt nicht komplett ausgeschlossen, wird man sehen. Aber ich kann mir auch vorstellen, wie du eben schon sagtest, dass das jetzt bei Apple auch nochmal diese ganze Sicherheitsnummer nochmal extra hochdreht.
Ich finde das gut sogar.
Ich finde das auch total super. Und vor allem fragt man sich halt, warum gibt es nicht heute schon auch die Encrypted iCloud? Also warum?
Ja, das sehe ich auch so. Also wenn euch eure Daten lieb sind, kann iCloud benutzen, weil es jetzt auch bekannt, also nicht nur bekannt, es war voll bekannt, aber jetzt ist es sozusagen bestätigt, wenn das FBI sagt, gib uns die iCloud-Daten, dann gibt Apple die iCloud-Daten raus, weil sie müssen, weil sie können. Und wenn es encrypted wäre, dann können sie halt auch nicht mehr.
Aber eure Keychain ist bestimmt sicher da, oder?
Meine Keychain ist da auch nicht.
Na die iCloud-Keychain ist wiederum schon, die können sie nicht auslesen.
Also auslesen schon, aber nicht verschlüsselt.
Genau.
Hoffste.
Ja, also auf Papier. Also ich kann dir nicht sagen, ob das stimmt. Aber halt deine ganzen Apps, Präferenzen.
Ja das Problem ist glaube ich, warum das mit der iCloud, mal um sie das nicht verkrypten können oder nicht verkrypten wollen erstmal so, weil das ohne Krypto wesentlich billiger ist als mit Krypto, weil wenn man sich so zum Beispiel z.B. Z-Test anguckt, ich hab's geschafft. Nee, da gibt's halt schicke Features. Und nicht nur bei Z-Test, sondern bei EMC Quadrat und bei, wie heißt es denn, NetApp-Filer und so. Da gibt's das Feature auch, das De-Duplication. Das heißt, wenn du da dein Bild von deinem Kind auch an die Omis, die Verwandten, und hast nicht an 20 Verwandte schickst, dann ist das bei Apple halt eine Kopie, ein Hasch und alle anderen haben halt einen Link auf dieses Ding, aber es liegt halt nicht 20 Mal darum und das spart halt verdammt viel. Genau, die ganze Welt hat den gleichen Scheiß. Man musste nicht hunderttausendmal speichern, so ein Hasch davon reicht und dann sparen die halt eine Menge da an Storage und wenn das gekryptet ist, dann geht das halt nicht. Das wär ein Argument, das wär einfach wesentlich teurer. Aber Apple, hallo, ich hab gar kein Problem, damit auch ein paar Euros dafür zu bezahlen, aber es muss kryptomäßig dicht sein.
Das wär wirklich mal ein Mehrwert.
Ich würde ja sogar für ein Hardend OS irgendwie noch ein paar Euro extra ablöhnen, glaube ich.
Aber zum Beispiel hier bei ARK ist es ja so, da wären ja deine Blöcke, also das wird auch quasi, also das wird ja nicht so am Block entkryptet und hochgeladen, sondern der guckt sich, der teilt sich ja auch die Daten schön in Blöckchen auf und kryptet die Blöcke und schiebt die dann hoch und guckt dann, ob sich in den Blöcken was geändert hat und dann Backup dann nur die Blöcke, die sich geändert haben. Ja, das ist ja, wie nennt man das, also ist ja nicht so cloud-mäßig natürlich jetzt so im Sinne von alle Geräte greifen drauf zu und so weiter, aber zumindest liegt da bei Amazon halt ein Kryptohaufen und nicht halt...
Ja, aber der macht kein Deduplication, weil es schon verschlüsselt ist. Er kann nicht vergleichen mit anderen, ob das jetzt das gleiche Bild ist.
Du kriegst halt nur lokale Deduplication, wenn du das Bild 23 mal auf der Platte hast.
Aber das nützt ja dann auf der anderen Seite nichts, da können wir ja nichts ansparen. Okay, von dir jetzt, du müssen es von dir nicht zweimal speichern, aber ja gut, das sollte ja... Ist ja eher seltener der Fall, dass man selber die Daten auch noch alle doppelt hat.
Naja, hast du mal hier einen Duplication-Finder auf deiner Kiste? Ja, aber es ist ja jetzt nicht... Wahrscheinlich 23 Star Wars Kostüme.
Es sei ein Unterschied, ob du jetzt einen Filmchen machst, den du 20 mal verteilst, der irgendwie, weiß nicht wie groß ist, dann wirst du den gleichen Film ja nicht auch 20 mal auf deinem Rechner haben, sondern es ist eher das... Und 20 ist wahrscheinlich noch wenig. Die haben bestimmt Fälle, wo irgendein komischer Film wirklich hunderttausendmal bei den Leuten im Backup liegt.
Aber wenn du den lokal krypten würdest und dann in den Cloud schiebst und alle Leute krypten, achso, die haben ja mal andere Schlüsse.
Genau. Und du willst ja eben nicht, dass jemand weiß, was drin ist und auch nur über den Hasch würde man ja sonst schon erkennen, was es wäre. Also es geht einfach nicht.
Na, wenn man MD5 benutzt, dann...
Dann sowieso.
Dann könnte es was anderes sein.
Ja, aber Dropbox hatte doch mal dieses Problem, dass wenn man den Hasch von einer Datei wusste...
Man hat nur den Hasch so getan, als ob und schon konnte man es runterladen, weil, obwohl man es gar nicht hatte.
Weil irgendjemand hatte das dann und dann konnte man runterladen.
Da haben sie eins, zwei Checks halt vergessen. Na gut, aber man kann festhalten, Apple währt sich gerade mit Händen und Füßen.
Zumindest PA-mäßig.
Und hoffen, dass es eben kein PR-Gag ist, sondern dass sie es halt ernst meinen. Und ja, gut, muss man halt hoffen.
Das FBI hat es ihnen ja unterstellt, dass es ein PR-Gag wäre.
Ja, es kann ja auch immer noch einer sein, das heißt ja nichts. Aber ich hoffe, dass sie sich halt was einfallen lassen, so wie ich das meinte. Vielleicht ist es jetzt bei den neueren Phones auch schon so mit diesem Secure Layer oder wie auch immer das Ding heißt, dieses Security Compartment. Was ein ganz normales Feature von so Armchips ist oder von den Mondeuren ist jetzt nichts, was Apple sich da hat einfallen lassen, glaube ich. Sie benutzen das halt nur. Und ja, ich hoffe, dass es entweder schon so ist, oder sie es dann nochmal verbessern für die nächsten Versionen, die da kommen werden. Und wenn das FBI ja schon Apple im Januar genötigt hat, da zu machen, dann überlegen die ja vielleicht hoffentlich auch schon seit Januar, dass sie da mal was tun wollen. Vielleicht klappt es ja frühstmöglich.
Aber bis sie Hardware gebastelt haben?
Die Hardware ist ja da. Sie müssen sie halt nur nutzen, glaube ich. Weißt du, wenn Apple dann, Quatsch, wenn das FBI am Ende dann halt sich den Chip-Polierer kommt und die sich da an den Die ranfräsen und dann da die Kies extra hier und so weiter. Ja, ok, weißt du, dann hast du halt die Arschkarte. Dagegen könnte man wahrscheinlich sogar auch noch was tun. Ist dann aber schon vielleicht ein bisschen teurer. Aber das skaliert halt zumindest für das FBI nicht.
Ja, das macht halt dann eine NSA, aber keine FBI.
Ja, das machen die aber noch einmal und verkaufen den Service dann an die anderen.
Auf jeden Fall hatte diese ganze Aktion jetzt diesen skurrilen Effekt, dass es heute eine Freiheitsstadt-Angst-Demo in München gab. In Spuckweite vom Apple Store in München. Quasi für Apple oder zumindest nicht gegen Apple gab. Und auch die EFF und so schmeißt sich ja jetzt dahinter. Ich meine, warum auch nicht? Man kann ja jetzt alle Zweifel haben und seinen Verschwörungstheoriekoffer öffnen und sich das passende raussuchen. Aber das kriege ich jetzt schwer verteufelt, dass sie sozusagen mit dieser Argumentation an die Öffentlichkeit treten, die so ziemlich genau dieselbe Argumentation ist, die Hacker- und Privacy-Kreise eigentlich auch schon immer gehabt haben. Auf allen Leveln.
Vielleicht hat es das mit Google halt noch nie gegeben, das Problem vorher, weil Google halt immer rausrückt.
Ja, ich meine, wenn man sich mal so anschaut, wie wenig sich jetzt die anderen Unternehmen in dieser Debatte engagieren oder versuchen auch nur, Apple halbwegs den Rücken zu stärken.
Na, Google so ein klein bisschen.
So ein ganz klein bisschen.
Der Zuckerberg fand es auch super, was Apple macht.
Ja, so... Die finden es schön, dass Apple sich da sozusagen jetzt verbrennt und sie nicht.
Aber Bill Gates ist dagegen.
Ne, ne, ne, das hat er heute gesagt, dass er es gar nicht witzig findet, was sie ihm da in den Mund gelegt haben.
Aber es ist ja eigentlich alles gar kein Problem. Sorry, Roddy, du hast ja gepennt irgendwie. Du hast den Link vorhin schon rausgesucht, aber ich kenne ihn auch schon seit einer Woche. Denn John McAfee hat ja angekündigt, dass er ja das iPhone hackt. Also kein Problem. Er kennt die krassesten Hacker. Er hat die so am Start, die waren noch bei der Defcon, hat er gesagt.
Und die kiffen und die wollen eine halbe Million Dollar am Tag. Aber die können das.
Also sind ja alle happy. Apple muss nichts tun, FBI muss nichts tun.
Kann der noch was anderes als auf dicke Hose machen?
Der will einfach...
Der macht sich doch regelmäßig lächerlich.
Der wartet nur auf den Tag, wo Chuck Norris stirbt und dann will er direkt in seine Fußstapfen eintreten als Internet-Meme.
Ey du, aber ganz ehrlich, 2016 2016 ist kein...
Chuck Norris stirbt nicht....
ist kein gutes Jahr für Legenden, Tode...
Der ist Baujahr 40, also der ist jetzt auch schon 76.
Also wir haben dieses Jahr schon einige große Verloren, inklusive Peter Lustig natürlich.
Der hat schon mit Bruce Lee...
Ja, wir haben jedes Jahr große Verloren. Es gibt ja noch kurz genug große damit auch jedes Jahr einer stirbt.
Dieses Jahr waren es schon ein paar mehr. Mr. Bowie hat es ja auch schon in den Lieder gestreckt.
Ja, den Lustig.
Das stimmt.
Das ist nicht mehr lustig.
Da waren auch noch ein paar andere.
Dann diesen deutschen Moderator.
Und Lemmy natürlich.
Lemmy auch.
Roger Willem.
Und der Lustig.
Bei Grabtas Hammer, ihr werdet gerecht werden. Na, wenn du schon Ellen Rickman sagst, was fällt dir da als erstes ein?
Keine Ahnung.
Hans Gruber.
Du hast Ellen Rickman erwähnt. Und was ist das erste woran du denkst?
Du erzählst bestimmt von Harry Potter, weil das kenn ich nämlich nicht. Also kannst du nur das meinen.
Aber Hans Gruber, das ist seine erste große Star-Rolle gewesen in Die Hardt, der deutsche Terrorist. Ach echt?
Stimmt.
Was meinst du denn? Hab ich auch geguckt, das ist alles abgehakt. Das ist schon so lange her.
Man sagt nicht zu Galaxy Quest Doch? Nein.
Ich schon.
Was ist denn es denn?
Galaxy Quest kennst du nicht?
Nein? Das ist wahrscheinlich einer der lustigsten Filme mit Science Fiction Färbung.
Das ist der mit Sigourney Viva auch so?
Ja, mit Sigourney Viva.
Das hab ich auch irgendwann mal gesehen.
Der ist so lustig. Ihr könnt jetzt gerne auf Pause drücken, euch irgendwie euren Netflix-Account anschmeißen, Galaxy Quest klicken und dann lacht er euch jetzt erstmal herzlich zwei Stunden tot und danach reden wir weiter. Das ist einer der besten Filme. Der ist so lustig, von vorne bis hinten. Und das ist auch einer dieser wenigen Filme, die ich mir auf Repeat anschauen kann. Und ich finde sie sofort danach an den selben Stellen immer noch genauso komisch. Weil das ist einfach eine...
Okay, wir machen jetzt den ultimativen Test. Ist lustiger als The Life of Brian?
Das ist ganz anders als The Life of Brian. Man kann es nicht so direkt vergleichen.
Dein Glück.
Ja, The Life of Brian spielt sowieso eine eigenen Lieber. Aber ich würde sagen, so wie Office Space lustig und dauerbrennermäßig ist, da ist bei Galaxy Quest auch eine Menge zu holen. Weil Grabtas Hammer, ihr werdet gerecht werden.
Das war sein Spruch, ja.
Ja, das war sozusagen die Rolle. Kurz zusammen, Management Summary, Galaxy Quest. Warum dieser Film lustig ist, merkt man schon so ein bisschen allein vom Setting her. Das Ganze handelt sozusagen von einer Fernsehserie Galaxy Quest. Das muss man sich so ein bisschen vorstellen wie die Fernsehserie Star Trek. Aber es versucht nicht genau so jetzt zu sein wie Star Trek. Also eine Serie, die viele Leute seit vielen Jahren sehen und toll finden. Und man sieht sie halt sozusagen die ganzen Schauspieler, die diese Fernsehserie memen, die dann vollkommen gelangweilt und genervt auf irgendwelchen Fan-Cons sind, wo dann Jugendliche in den Klamotten verkleidet, wie sie in dieser Fernsehserie rumlaufen und dann immer ihre Fernsehsprüche abliefern und eine Unterschrift haben wollen. Sie sind einfach alle durch und insbesondere Alan Rickman in seiner Rolle gehört zu dem mega genervten, der einfach am liebsten morgen kündigen will und dann auch die ganze Zeit immer sagt, ich hör auf, ich kann es nicht mehr er tragen und alle anderen so nein und die Show muss weitergehen und so weiter und sie dann immer wieder überredet bekommen, weiterzumachen und dann passiert es, dass auf einmal sie entführt werden.
Das ganze Team.
Willst du jetzt den Film spoilern?
Nein, ich will den Film nicht spoilern. Ich glaub nur, dass man, naja, ich sag mal nicht mehr.
Ja, gut, hab ich ja gerade noch so reingegreht und das Foul verhindert.
Das kriegt dann sozusagen noch mal so eine Metaebene und das ist wirklich lustig.
Ich bin jetzt bei Letterboxd bei 1773.
Die Pyriliumkugel. Ja, Letterboxd, man.
Ich find das übrigens nicht nett, dass du dann die Qualität meiner Filme abwertest, nur weil es so viele sind.
Wie, was, hab ich gar nicht gesagt.
Doch, du hast geantwortet, ja und wie viel davon sind Schrott?
Na, das ist doch eine gute Frage.
Ich guck doch keinen Schrott. Nein, da ist natürlich auch eine Menge Schrott. Aber ich würd sagen, prozentual ist da jetzt auch nicht mehr Schrott als in anderen Listen von Leuten, die das sagen. Ich hab nur mehr geschaut. Auch mehr gute Sachen natürlich.
Was ist denn deine Meinung zu...
Also, wir müssen kurz erklären, was passiert ist. Also wir saßen mal wieder nachts im Club und dann hab ich irgendwie von Letterboxd erzählt und Dennis kannte das noch nicht.
Kennt ihr das denn?
Haben wir das nicht letzte Sendung auch schon?
Letzte Sendung nicht, aber wir hatten das schon vor...
Doch, ich glaube, letzte Sendung haben wir schon.
Anfang des Jahres, bei der Sendung, wo ich nicht dabei war.
Das ist eine Webseite, wo man eintragen kann, welche Filme man kennt.
Das ist nicht IMDB.
Es gibt auch noch so zwei, drei andere, die was Ähnliches machen. Ich finde Letterboxd persönlich recht schön. Also ich finde das ist einfach eine relativ runde Geschichte. Und vor allem kann ich es jetzt problemlos empfehlen, seitdem sie auch eine Exportfunktion haben. Habe ich gesehen. Man kann sich das ganze zusammengeklickte als CSV exportieren und das ist schon mal okay.
Sie sind da sehr offen.
Genau, und die machen einen ganz coolen Eindruck. Das ist glaube ich so eine Truppe aus Neuseeland.
Deswegen ist es so langsam, da hast du erklärt einiges.
Ich weiß nicht wo sie ihre Server stehen haben, aber naja, sie arbeiten wohl auch an einer iPhone-App. Und naja, wie das so ist, dann habe ich halt gesagt, ich habe 640 Filme und Dennis nur so. Da hatte ich ihn dann, und dann saß er die ganze Nacht da und dann bist du bei 1.673. Du hast in deinem Leben 1.773 Filme gesehen.
An die ich mich erinnern kann. Und die ich da gefunden habe. Ich habe da auch schon ganz viele gefunden. So John Wayne, ja ich weiß, ich habe echt eine Menge John Wayne-Filme gesehen. Von den hunderten, die er hat, habe ich bestimmt alle 95 gesehen, aber 5 nicht. Aber ich weiß nicht, welche 5. Also habe ich alle 95 nicht angeklickt, weil ich weiß ja nicht, welche. Und diese ganzen bekloppten Idiotenfilme habe ich halt alle weggelassen. Genau das gleiche mit Clint Eastwood. Der hat ja auch ohne Ende diese komischen Western gemacht. Habe ich auch alle nicht. Oder so. Steven Seagal, ich war ja auch mal, ich habe diesen Scheiß ja auch geguckt. So zwei, drei Stück von dem. Aber ich weiß halt nicht, welche. Also habe ich die alle weggelassen. Also ich habe wirklich nur die reingeklingt, die ich kenne. Und inzwischen schaffe ich auch nur noch ein oder zwei Filme am Tag dazusätzlich reinzuwenden, weil so viel Recherche kostet, um rauszufinden, ob ich den nun gesehen habe oder nicht. Das ist richtig anstrengend. Ich fange sogar schon Filme jetzt noch mal zu gucken, damit ich die da packen kann und habe schon festgestellt, Scheiße, kenne ich ja doch schon.
Was ist deine Meinung zu This Thing?
Welcher? Jetzt drei. Einer aus den 50ern, dann der von Carpenter aus den 80ern und dann diesen, der jetzt vor 5, 6 Jahren irgendwie rauskam. Also den von Carpenter. Na, der geht schon ganz schön ab, der Film. Da waren wir noch 16 oder 17 und mein Kumpel meinte, ey, er hat da so den Karte von seinem Papa. Wenn wir in die Videothek gehen, der Typ, der sagt immer nichts und wir können uns den holen. Wir haben uns fast in die Hose gemacht, besonders als der Hund sich von innen nach außen gedreht hat. War schon ganz schön übler Scheiß. Aber ob es gut war, kann ich dir jetzt nicht sagen, weil da hatte man andere Ansprüche.
Na, das, äh, jemand meinte halt, als ich so meinte, dass Alien halt auch so ein genre-definierender Film war, war halt so schockermäßig halt auch so dieses...
Ja, aber das Genre von The Thing, das gab's vorher auch schon. Das ist schon...
Ja, aber der meinte halt so, für ihn wäre zum Beispiel The Thing, das hätte ihn auch damals so irgendwie außen......aus den Socken gehauen... .aus den Socken gehauen.
Ja, guck dir mal den Nachfolgefilm an, der ist ziemlich cool. Der hat das so passend gemacht, dass er an der Story direkt anknüpft, aber andersrum.
Galaxy Quest und Office Space sind so wie Filme.
So, jetzt sind wir von Apple FBI nach Galaxy Quest nach Letterboxd gekommen. Müssen wir vielleicht nochmal zurückspulen und den Ingo-Turn machen?
Na, das Apple-Ding ist durch. Und jetzt haben wir einfach über Filme geredet. Ist doch auch mal was.
Müssen wir auch mal drüber reden.
Wir werden nachher sogar noch über Podcasting reden.
Dann kannst du den Artikel nochmal lesen.
Da können wir alle den Artikel lesen.
Podcasting ist ja wichtig.
Also Dennis, du musst noch sagen, du bist Dennis2342. Wer sich also sozusagen schon mal alle Filme anschauen wollte, die Dennis gesehen hat, da ist wirklich viel dabei. Da ist auch viel Interessantes dabei. Aber du hast ja auch so Filme. Ich meine, ich bereue jeden einzelnen Film, den ich da eintrage, wo ich weiß, der ist scheiße.
Ja, ich finde, man kann das halt auch immer erst sagen, wenn man ihn gesehen hat.
Ja, sonst kann man ihn da auch nicht eintragen. Also, na klar, man kann ihn da eintragen.
Also ich würde sagen, alles, was auf IMDb weniger als eine 6,0 hat, muss man nicht sehen.
Kann man nicht so sagen.
Also sag mir einen Film, der weniger als eine 6,0 auf IMDb hat, wo du auf Knien angeschaut hast, den musst du gesehen haben. Der hat garantiert mehr als 6,0.
Auf IMDb?
Wenn jetzt Letterboxd die Bewertung von IMDb anzeigen könnte, dann könnte man sich das mal so auflisten lassen, dann könnte ich dir das sagen, aber ich finde, man sollte nicht nach IMDb-Punkten irgendwie gehen, was ist nur der Mainstream.
Ja, aber ich finde, das ist erstmal schon mal eine ganz gute Ausrichtung.
Da meint einer im Chat gerade, dass man sich Uwe Boll sparen kann. Ja, aber Uwe Boll hat mal auch den Film gedreht, der Rampage hieß, glaube ich. Und da dachte ich auch, ich gucke jetzt mal so einen Uwe Boll, Scheiß, wie schlecht das ist. Und der war am Ende gar nicht so schlecht. Und der hat, na okay, 6.3, der hat nicht weniger als 6.
Helge Schneider ist gar nicht in IMDb.
Doch, Helge Schneider ist in der IMDb.
Na, Doc Schneider oder wie heißt der?
Da sind sie dem Urteil nochmal entgangen. Durch Nicht-Nennung.
Doch, hier Doc Schneider, Texas. Doc Schneider hält die Welt in Atem. 6,8.
Ich sag dir, sag mir ein und wo...
Das ist aber schon ganz schön wenig, finde ich.
Ja, aber Comedy sind generell schlechter gewertet auf der IMDb. Also wenn du eine Comedy findest, die über 7,5 hat, dann muss das wirklich eine absolute Weltöcher sein.
Sardos hat weniger als 6. Mehr als was? Zum Beispiel der.
Mehr als was?
7,5, das sind schon die Spitzencomedies.
Wenn man richtig durchgeknallten Filme sehen will, kann sich Sardos angucken. Mit Joe Connery 5,8.
Galaxy Quest hat 7,3. Ich finde, das sagt nichts aus.
Ja, ist auch okay.
Bei Craptors Hammer. Ihr werdet gerecht werden.
Alles über 7 ist schon gut. Bei Comedies ist wirklich... Da ist der Offset so ein bisschen anders.
Office Base 7,8. Was hat da das höchste Ranking?
Godfather oder Shawshank Redemption.
Nee, ich meine von den Comedies.
Achso, warte. Kannst du auch Filtern, Fool, Soltieren, keine Ahnung. Das ist der Advanced Search. Da kann man so eine wahnsinnig tolle Suchabfrage machen, wo man das bestimmt rausfindet. Aber das wusste ich auch mal. Du kannst so mal Life of Brian zum Beispiel. Also guck in die IMDB Top 250-Liste. Und da, wenn da eine Comedy dabei ist, dann hat die auf jeden Fall über 8.
Life of Brian hat 8,1.
Links in so einer Reihe suchen wir nach 250.
Links ist gar nichts.
Ja, die haben es irgendwie umsortiert. Jetzt warte, ich suche dir das.
Wann ist eigentlich Oscar? Ist ja auch demnächst, ne?
Wo ist denn hier die Top 250-Liste her?
Sollte nur für die Weißen jetzt, oder nicht? Die Webseite ist ein bisschen beknackt, oder?
Welche?
Da von dir, MdB. Weiß du nicht, meine schöne Internet-Webseite?
Das ist halt die älteste Webseite. Hier, guck, ich pack dir den Link in den Chat.
Mach das mal.
Da, klickst du drauf im Irrki.
So, und jetzt Sort by Genre. Nee, geht nicht. Kann man hier filtern?
Unser Hörer beschweren sich gerade, dass es langweilig ist.
Ja, aber es sind auf jeden Fall, man kann schon mal sagen, es sind sehr wenige Comedies da drin. Und wenn überhaupt, überhaupt eine. Ist überhaupt eine drin? Wir müssen jetzt kurz mal die Top 250 durchscrollen. Sorry Leute, aber das muss jetzt leider sein.
Comedy, ist die Frage, wo das anfängt.
Ja, ist Forrest Gump eine Comedy?
Darüber habe ich auch gerade nachgedacht. Ich würde sagen nein.
Also The Great Dictator zum Beispiel hat eine 8,4.
Hmm, Matrix auf Platz 18.
Ist zum Beispiel Amelie, die wunderbare Welt oder die fabelhafte Welt der Amelie, ist das eine Comedy?
Nee, definitiv nicht.
Na schon auch.
Toy Story 3 ist auf jeden Fall eine der Top.
Nee, hier ist überhaupt keine Comedy drin.
Doch, hier Monty Python und die Holy Grail. Ist auf 95.
Das ist ja eigentlich auch keine Comedy.
Ich sag halt, für Comedy-Filme, für Klamauk ist die Score halt so ein bisschen anders. Da müsste man noch mal eine andere Wertung einführen. Aber deswegen sag ich ja.
Man merkt auch, dass sie so eine Tendenz zum Neuen haben. Weil dieser Deadpool, der jetzt irgendwie gerade mal so ein paar Tagen drin ist.
Die rotieren aber auch schnell wieder raus dann.
Wenn die neu sind, dann kriegen die erstmal alle, die finden das toll. Die Leute, die das scheiße finden, gucken sich den eh nicht an.
Ja, aber der Algorithmus ist doch schon mal scheiße.
Der ist sowieso in den Arsch.
Dann muss die Zeit damit reinwirken. Dann muss man das gleich abfedern. Dann zählt sozusagen ein Rating erst nach einem Jahr voll.
Das machen sie sowieso. Sie haben auf jeden Fall schon so Dämpfer da drin. Also nicht, dass jetzt hier irgendwie, wenn da 10 Leute einen Film anklicken, dass der da hoch gemacht wird.
Aber der soll wohl ganz gut sein, ne? Welcher?
Deadpool?
Wieso nicht? Und wie meinst du, er ist zu albern?
Also der Trailer lässt es vermuten, dass er ein bisschen albern ist.
Wir werden es sehen.
Wir werden es sehen. 2001 ist er auf Platz 93. Also ich weiß nicht.
So weit hinten, ja.
Na ja, das Ende hat es glaube ich versaut.
Ja, aber nur weil die Leute es nicht verstehen.
Weil niemand gerne das Ende von 2001 guckt. Also ich kenne nicht so viele, die sagen, ja, toll, super. Also meistens laufen die Gespräche so, 2001 geiler Film, aber das Ende, na ja.
Wenn sie überhaupt mal so weit kommen und ich vorherschein sage, es war so langweilig, das konnte ich nicht gucken.
Ja, aber nur wenn man das Buch gelesen hat und weiß, was passiert.
Hier ist die erste Comedy. Some Like It Hot, Platz 112.
Manche mögen es heiß, ja. Na ja, es ist halt auch alter Scheiß.
Gut, wollen wir uns über die wichtigen Dinge des Lebens unterhalten? Wichtigen Dinge des Lebens, schweres Zeug. Ich hatte ja so eine...
Was gibt es denn schönes und schweren Zeug?
Ja, ich hatte so eine... Ich habe so einen Tweet getwötet. Und zwar... Ich twörtete einen Tweet. Und in die Twitteria hinein. Ich weiß nicht so richtig warum, aber es war so dieser Tag, wo die News dann brach, dass sie sicher jetzt sicher seien, dass dieser Zugcrash da unten...
Menschliches Versagen wäre.
Genau, menschliches Versagen sei, weil ja der Zugleiter die beiden Zügen das Befahren der eingleisigen Strecke erlaubt hat und dabei dem einen Zug explizit das Übertreten eines Rotsignals erlaubt hat. Das war ja, sagen wir mal, der Auslöser dieser Katastrophe. Und dann sind die beiden losgefahren oder weitergefahren, die Züge, und dann halt zusammengestoßen und zehn Tote und bla bla bla. Und das ist ja auch alles sehr traurig. Und dann hieß es halt sehr schnell, naja, die Technik sei ja noch über noch eine Woche vorher gecheckt worden. Es war auch alles okay. Und das stimmt wohl auch. Zumindest, wenn man jetzt diesen Berichten glauben darf, auf jeden Fall legt sich das eben so da, dass die Technik so funktioniert hat, wie sie da installiert ist. Nur dieser Zugleiter hat offensichtlich nicht so funktioniert, wie er da installiert war. Und hat eben so ein Override gegeben. Und damit eben diesen Zusammenstoß dieser beiden Züge ausgelöst. Er hat ja dann wohl noch ein Notsignal geschickt.
Nee, er wollte eins, also er wollte anrufen.
Der habe wohl eins geschickt, was...
Also mit Notsignal mein, der hat die angerufen, wenn ich das richtig verstehe. Über dieses GSMR und an der Stelle, wo die Züge waren, ist aber ein Funkloch. Und deswegen konnte er sie nicht anrufen.
Also das mit dem Funkloch finde ich ja ein bisschen skurril, weil GSMR und Funkloch geht eigentlich gar nicht. Weil wenn die nämlich keinen Kontakt haben, dann bremsen die automatisch.
Da stand irgendwo, dass sie das GSMR nicht so in der Funkleistung betreiben konnten, wie sie wollten, weil sie die anderen Funktürme da, also das normale Netz, was wir benutzen, halt stören. Deswegen mussten sie eine Leistung beschränken.
Wie auch immer.
Da wollte ich aber eigentlich drauf hinaus. Deswegen schrieb ich halt so, ich weiß nicht mehr, was habe ich jetzt genau geschrieben, dass das für mich ein technisches Versagen gewesen sei.
Also nicht von der Technik, die schon da war, sondern ein Versagen in, dass die Technik nicht da war.
Also ich bezog mich natürlich auf das Design. Das habe ich so nicht geschrieben. Das habe ich vielleicht auch in dem Moment bewusst weggelassen, um so ein bisschen Diskussionen auch anzuregen. Da kam dann das eine oder andere zurück und viele meinten so, nein, das habe ja genau so funktioniert, wie es gebaut war. Aber worauf ich eigentlich hinaus wollte... Wie kann es denn bitte sein, dass wir so im Jahr 2016 keine Systeme haben, die in der Lage ist, festzustellen, dass zwei Züge gerade auf demselben Gleis aufeinander zu fahren. Das ist irgendwie, weiß ich nicht, das will mir nicht so recht in den Kopf. Klar, da gibt es jetzt viele tausend Gründe und wie sich das alles entwickelt hat und die Standards und so weiter, was alles so vorgesehen ist und so weiter, aber das ist doch, sagen wir mal, so ein bisschen der totale Super-GAU. Das ist doch das Hauptding, was man eigentlich verhindern will. Also es gibt sicherlich noch diverse andere Konstellationen.
Da gibt es tausend verschiedene.
Züge könnten nebeneinander auf selbe Gleis kommen und sich so gegeneinander lehnen und das ist auch sicherlich auch alles ausreichend dramatisch. Aber so dieses schnelle Züge fahren direkt aufeinander zu und prallen aufeinander, das ist irgendwie so... Klar, jetzt reicht es natürlich nicht da vorne einfach nur ein Ultraschall-Sensor einzubauen, weil wenn der irgendwas merkt, dann ist es eh schon zu spät.
Es ist schon viel zu spät.
Vor allem, wenn die halt in so einer Kurve aufeinander zu fahren, wo sie sich halt irgendwie nicht sehen.
Ne, das Problem ist ja der Bremsweg von einem Zug, weil Stahl auf Stahl halt nicht so unglaublich viel Reibung hat. Und du kannst mit einem Zug halt keine, kannst eine Vollbremsung hinlegen, aber du hast trotzdem einen enormen Bremsweg. Also so ein ICE bei voller Fahrt hat fünf Kilometer Bremsweg. Das ist irgendwie...
Oder er bremst so doll und schnell, was er ja schon auch kann, aber dann sind hinten auch alle tot, weil...
Ne, kann er nicht.
Er kann in verschiedenen Stufen bremsen.
Ich führe das jetzt auch mal ganz bewusst leihenhaft, weil ich mich überhaupt nicht in Anspruch nehme, dass ich irgendwie Bahntechnik auch nur ansatzweise wirklich verinnerlicht hätte oder so. Aber so zwei Sachen kamen mir so primär in den Sinn. Erstens, ist das so angemessen so eine schwerwiegende Entscheidung, wie überfahre ein rotes Signal, nur von einer einzigen Person abhängig zu machen, oder wäre dort nicht ein Vier-Augen-Prinzip sozusagen angemessen?
Ja, jetzt ist die Antwort ja ganz einfach.
Viel zu teuer. Ja, viel zu teuer, keine Ahnung, nicht genug Leute da, was auch immer.
Ich würde sogar einen Schritt weitergehen.
Moment, ich frage mich, wie oft ein solches Signal pro Tag in Deutschland, im deutschen Zugnetz auf diese Art und Weise override wird. Ich kann mir nicht vorstellen, dass das alle zehn Minuten stattfindet.
Ich kann mir nicht vorstellen, dass das überhaupt eine gute Idee ist, so etwas zu ermöglichen.
Ja, das hat wohl mit so Situationen zu tun, wenn irgendwo, was weiß ich, mit Bauarbeiten, Blockade, hat es Leute auf dem Gleis, muss irgendwie was umroten und muss halt irgendwie eine Situation mit der halt der normale Signallauf so nicht klar kam.
Aber du hast ja das Prinzip bei der Bahn, dass sämtliche Strecken, die nicht frei gegeben sind, konkret frei gegeben sind zum Befahren, mit einem roten Signal ausgeschaltet sind. Also wenn ein Zug irgendwo hin soll, dann machen die für diesen Zug das grüne Licht an und nicht andersrum. Und, ja gut, da kann es natürlich schon mal vorkommen, dass du halt aus irgendwelchen Gründen nicht grün schalten kannst, aber die Strecke ist trotzdem frei. Aber auf der anderen Seite ist es doch auch ein totaler Fail, wenn sowas auftritt. Also dann musst du halt für den Zeitraum, weiß ich nicht, das Signal ganz weg machen. Und weiß ich nicht, andere Signale hinstellen oder so oder...
Bremsweg übrigens bei 300 kmh, 2,8 Kilometer bei 330, 3,3 Kilometer.
Ah ja, ein bisschen geringer als das schon war.
330 fährt kein Soch mehr in Deutschland. Wir waren mit 100 unterwegs. Die offiziellen Wikipedia-Zahlen.
Für den ICE3.
Na ja gut, es sind wahrscheinlich unterschiedlich pro Zug und so weiter.
Also kann ich nicht so richtig einschätzen, wer aber jetzt, sagen wir mal, für etwas, was so potentiell solche Auswirkungen haben kann, ist halt die Frage, reicht da wirklich die Entscheidung einer Person? Kann sein, dass jetzt so eine Antwort kommt, wie findet jeden Tag 100 mal statt?
Das fände ich kritisch, ehrlich gesagt.
Ja, ist aber, sagen wir mal, dann mit der Absicherung eines erfahrenen Zugleiters, führt es in der Regel einfach nie zu einem Problem. Weil das passiert ja jetzt auch nicht alle Nase lang.
Ja, aber haben denn nicht auch viele Züge so ein automatisches, ich gehe in den Bremsmodus, wenn ich das Signal überfahre?
Ja gut, aber der kann es halt... Er hat ja den Override bekommen. Er hat ja die Erlaubnis, das wird ja dann an dem Signal, ich glaube, das sind irgendwie so drei Leuchtpunkte, die da drunter aufleuchten und die erlauben sozusagen das Überfahren.
Das ist rot, aber du darfst trotzdem fahren? Was ist denn das?
Das ist halt was anderes als grün. Ich habe ja gesagt, ich habe keine Ahnung. Ich sage nur, das ist so die eine Sache, wo es nicht so sehr technisches Versagen, ich meine eher systemisches Versagen, glaube ich. Das wäre vielleicht die richtige Formulierung gewesen. Weil das das System jetzt versagt hat, das ist ja offensichtlich, weil es darf ja nicht dazu kommen. Also wenn zwei Züge zusammenstoßen, hat das System versagt. Die Frage ist jetzt nur, welchen Anteil an diesem System hat Technik und welchen Anteil hat Mensch? Und hat man dem Menschen an der Stelle nicht zu viel Entscheidungsfreiheit gegeben? Das ist eine offene Frage, könnte man so sehen. Oder hätte man nicht sogar noch mehr technische Steuerung haben müssen?
Man kann die Frage so ähnlich stellen wie damals bei dem Air France Jet, der da für Südamerika abgestürzt ist, wo ja die Analyse hinterher ergeben hat, dass das Flugzeug an allen Ecken und Enden gesagt hat, ihr macht hier was falsch, aber die Piloten, die im Cockpit waren, nicht genug Erfahrung hatten zu erkennen, was eigentlich das Problem ist. Weil diese Art von Notsituationen halt selten ist und die völlig überfordert waren. Und damit kann es natürlich auch zusammenhängen, wenn jetzt der Zug dieser Stellwerksleiter oder wer das da war, mit der Situation, die da war, einfach überhaupt nicht zur Rande kam, weil er das nicht trainiert hat, dann ist es vielleicht menschliches Versagen, aber vielleicht ist auch das Gesamtdesign so, dass das einfach zwangsläufig irgendwann dazu führt, dass derjenige, der es benutzen muss, nicht mehr in der Lage ist, es unter Kontrolle zu halten.
Zweiter Lösungsansatz, den ich so im Kopf hatte, oder was heißt Lösungsansatz? Zweites Fragezeichen, was sich bei mir so herausgebildet hat, als ich darüber nachgedacht habe, wie man dieses systemische Versagen auflösen könnte. Meiner Kenntnis nach, und auch hier gleich wieder der Super-Disclaimer, bevor ihr alle anfängt rumzumotzen in den Kommentaren, ich hab da keine wirkliche Kenntnis drüber. Es ist nur so eine Erwartungsgeschichte. Aber es gibt da so einen Zugradar. Da kann ich mittlerweile jeden Zug in Deutschland auf meiner App sehen. Wenn es einen Zugradar gibt, wo ich jeden scheiß Zug auf meiner App sehen kann, dann gibt es auch ein System, das auch jeden Zug auf jedem Gleis sehen kann, bei der Bahn. Und dann kann der auch sehen, da wär ich mir nicht so sicher, dass da zwei Züge gerade auf demselben Gleis in Geschwindigkeit X aufeinander zu fahren.
Du weißt jetzt aber natürlich nicht, was für ein Delay dieses System hat und ob das nicht auch Löcher hat. Weil wenn der Zug tatsächlich keine Datenverbindung hatte und die Position nicht aktualisieren kann, dann kann es halt einfach sein, dass der Zug nicht als, als ich fahre jetzt auf dem gleichen Gleis markiert wird, weil die Information nicht aktuell ist.
Es kann sein, dass die Daten nicht aktuell sind, aber es ist definitiv so, dass diese Züge melden, wo sie sind. Und dass es, sagen wir mal, bei Zügen nun wirklich sehr einfach ist, festzustellen, ob sich das gerade um eine einspurige Straße oder um eine zweispurige Straße handelt. Bei Autos mag das ja noch ein Problem sein, aber bei Zügen definitiv nicht, weil die fahren ja mal nicht eben mal 5 Meter neben einem Gleis. Also, das ist schon eine Information, die vorliegt. Und selbst wenn sie nicht in mega, mega super, super Echtzeit mit 10 Millisekunden Latenz vorliegt, das hätte hier an dieser Stelle auch vollkommen gereicht. Einfach zu dem Zeitpunkt, als sie da den Befehl bekommen haben, hätte mit diesem Befehl, mit diesem Override es auch ermöglicht, also hätte man auch eine Überprüfung sozusagen durchführen können, müssen, machen können, hätte sich das automatisch machen lassen können, wie auch immer, dass einfach der Computer sagt, du hast da gerade einen Override gegeben, aber meiner Meinung nach würde das dann dazu führen, dass zwei Züge zusammenführen. Diese Information müsste da eigentlich schon abfallen. Und wenn sie das nicht tut, ich sage nicht, das ist alles unbedingt jetzt so, aber so müsste dann dieses System sein. Also ich halte das für absolut vorhersagbar, wann irgendwas zusammenstößt auf Basis von Echtzeitdaten.
Ich meine, man muss ein System halt auch richtig benutzen. Also ich war irgendwann mal in meiner Jugend, war ich mal in Schottland und habe da Interrail gemacht. Und da gab es irgendwie eine Jugendherberge, die hatten sie irgendwie in so einen Bahnhof reingebaut. Der Bahnwärter hatte da das aufgemacht. Und dann standen im Prinzip die Betten da, wo normalerweise der da seinen Job macht. Und da war so eine große Maschine, die war im Prinzip irgendwie so ein Schlüsselloch, wo man so ganz spezielle Schlüssel reinstecken konnte. Und je nachdem, in welche Richtung man die gedreht hat, konnte man die dann zur Seite in so eine Schiene reinstecken, sodass irgendwie also rein mechanisch immer nur ein Schlüssel im System außerhalb dieses Schlosses sein konnte. Und je nachdem, wie der Schlüssel da gedreht wurde, wurde dann das entsprechende Signal geschaltet. Und derjenige, der grün hatte, hat dann den Schlüssel mitbekommen und hat dann den Schlüssel auf die andere Seite mitgenommen, wo das Gegenkästchen stand, wo man dann auch wieder mit dem Schlüssel und diesem Schienen und haste nicht gesehen das System da wieder das Signal umstellen konnte. Also irgendwie, auch schon in den 50er, 60ern gab es Lösungen.
Aber die haben das sozusagen mechanisch gemacht, dass zwei Sachen nicht gleichzeitig...
Irgendwie so, ja.
Eine Simaphore.
So eine State-Maschinen-Mechanik sozusagen.
Ja genau, so eine Simaphore, so mit Schlüsseln.
Heißt ja auch Ampel auf Italienisch, oder?
Ja klar, aber ich meine, das waren natürlich auch Systeme, die sehr viel langsamer sind und für die hohe Zugdichte und die hohe Zuggeschwindigkeiten von heute jetzt nicht...
Ja, aber wenn du eine einspurige Strecke hast, dann hast du an den beiden Enden der einspurigen Strecke eine Weiche, wo zwei Züge auf zwei parallelen Gleisen aneinander vorbeifahren können. Das heißt, du musst, bevor du auf die einspurige Strecke fährst, eventuell warten, bis der Gegenzug rauskommt. Und an der Stelle hast du dann irgendeinen Mechanismus, der verhindert, dass zwei Züge auf einer einspurigen Strecke sind.
Das wäre zum Beispiel schon mal so eine Sache, dass eine einspurige Strecke dann eben ein entsprechendes Kabel haben müsste, um die beiden Einstiegspunkte miteinander zu sehen.
Haben sie ja, deswegen war die Ampel ja rot, oder?
Nehme ich mal an, ich kenne auch keine Details.
Weiß ich auch nicht. Im Chat heißt es, sowohl das Zugradar keine Echtzeit ist, aber irgendwo kommen diese Daten ja her, und dass es da wohl tatsächlich keinen GSMR gegeben habe. Aber auch dann sage ich halt, ok, wenn es da keinen GSMR gibt, dann darf man da auch keinen Override machen. Also das ist halt das, was ich meine. Das System ist wirklich eine schwierige Geschichte. Gar keine Frage, ich will das jetzt auch hier nicht als Vorwurf in den Raum stellen, dass jetzt irgendjemand da versagt, es ist eher ein Systemversagen, und das ist ja offensichtlich, dass es hier versagt wird.
Wenn es ein System geben würde, dann würden wir ja auch da einen Manual Override einbauen, weil sie sich auch nicht leisten können, dass das System irgendwann rumzickt und die ganzen...
Das ist ja das System, das System ist alles. Es sind Menschen mit Override-Genehmigungserlaubnis, das ist alles Teil dieses Systems. Und das System hat halt versagt, weil es ja zu etwas kam, was sie eigentlich verhindern wollen. Und mir will nicht so recht in den Kopf, dass das nicht gehen soll. Also das muss einfach ausschließbar sein, dass Züge zusammentreffen. Flugzeuge, Autos und so weiter, mega komplexe Scheiße. Aber Züge, nee. Bei Zügen muss das einfach gehen. So große Dinger mit so viel Energie und so viel... Weißt du, die haben alles, was man braucht, um zu strahlen und kommunizieren. Die haben mit Kontakte und Infrastruktur gehört, so wie du so dazu, damit die sich überhaupt nur bewegen können. Dann muss das sozusagen auch gehen. Ich halte jetzt schon das Maul. Wahrscheinlich habe ich schon wieder sehr viel dummes zu euch geredet, aber das war mein Hintergrund, mein Füß.
Hätten die Funk wie so Trucker einfach mal durchgefunkt, ey yo, ist hier wer auf meiner Strecke? Dann hätte er gesagt, ey yo, alter, ich bin da gerade, verpiss dich. Oh, scheiße, alles klar, ich leg mal einen Rückwärtsgang ein.
CB-Funk.
Hab ich alles schon gesehen. Also im Straßenverkehr wäre der Zugführer schuld gewesen, ne? Weil egal, wer dich einweist, der am Steuer sitzt, ist schuld.
Naja, bei Flugzeugen hast du halt auch immer diese Diskussion. Die Pollutenvereinigungen wollen immer nicht, dass es schnell auf den Piloten geschoben wird. Und die Flugzeughersteller, für die ist es natürlich, wenn man jetzt böse ist, ein einfacher Ausweg zu sagen, naja, der Pilot hat halt scheiße gebaut, aber unser Flugzeug ist eigentlich in Ordnung.
Und sie können später einen Silent Patch rausschieben.
Und ich will der Bahn jetzt natürlich nichts unterstellen, aber ich kann mir vorstellen, dass es dieses Spannungsfeld da auch gibt.
Ja, bestimmt.
Und wenn dann schnell in der Presse zu lesen ist, ist menschliches Versagen gewesen, naja.
Die Bahn war bestimmt erst mal happy, als es rauskam, dass es menschliches Versagen war, aber am Ende wären die Leute jetzt trotzdem weiterrum meckern und wären sagen, ey, ist uns egal, ob das menschliches Versagen war. Wenn euer System da nicht funktioniert, dann ist das schlecht. Also menschliches Versagen sollte man halt auch versuchen zu verhindern.
Machen wir die Heizung an, Tim, jetzt.
Die Heizung ist schon lange an.
Das stimmt nicht.
Doch, du machst das Fenster auf und willst hinterher die Heizung anhaben.
Ja, weil ich mich darauf verlassen hab, dass die an wäre, aber sie ist es nicht. Es gibt da eine Dissonanz zwischen deiner gewünschten Realität und der Realität.
So was kommt schon mal vor.
Gut, legen wir das beiseite. Reden wir über Sachen, von denen wir genauso wenig verstehen.
Mindestens genauso wenig.
Na, ich könnte, also ich hab noch zwei dicke Dinger. Die Frage ist, wann wir das...
Zwei dicke Dinger, na dann.
Es sei denn, ihr wollt irgendwas anderes vorher haben.
Ja, ich will jetzt über Bitcoin erzählen, weil du hast mich letzte Woche schon vertröstet. Und zwar, ich hab ja schon öfter erzählt, vielleicht, unsere geneigten Hörer erinnern sich, dass bei Bitcoin... Nicht gehen, Noke, das ist nicht gemein.
Nee, nee, nee, geneigter Hörer, bingo. Ich muss an das Bild denken.
Dass es da gerade Diskrepanzen bei den Bitcoin-Developern gibt. Und zwar sind die einen der Meinungen, man müsste die Blog-Size erhöhen. Die Blog-Size ist das, wo die Anzahl der Transaktionen drin sind. Wenn die Blog-Size voll ist, dann kann die Transaktion nicht rein, muss auf den nächsten Blog warten, wenn der dann auch voll ist. Das ganze Geschäft, das man abschließen will, wird ein bisschen langsamer. Die einen meinen, man muss die Blog-Size erhöhen. Die anderen meinen, das ist nicht gut, weil das hat beim Mining Schwierigkeiten. Mal die Chinesen hinter der dicken Mauer, die kriegen die Blöcke nicht so schnell. Das hat andere Auswirkungen. Man will das klein halten. Da streiten die sich gerade. Der Gavin Andresen, der das damals von dem Nakamoto übernommen hat, der ist jetzt so ein bisschen aus der Hauptgruppe ausgeschieden. Er hat jetzt einen Bitcoin-Client, der sich Bitcoin Classic nennt. Dort erlauben die gerade diese größeren Blöcke noch nicht, aber sie wollen eines Tages dahin. Das ist jetzt so eine Art Fork. Das heißt, jeder, der sich lange mit Bitcoin beschäftigt, kann sich überlegen, ob er auch größere Blöcke will oder nicht. Da muss man sich halt lange, lange reinlesen, bevor man der Meinung ist, dass man diese Entscheidung treffen kann. Und dann kann er sich sozusagen für den Bitcoin Core oder für den Bitcoin Classic client... Ich will entscheiden, aber jetzt fragen wahrscheinlich auch alle, was meine Entscheidung ist und ich finde den Gavin Andresen ganz gut, aber ich glaube, die Leute, die hinter dem Classic stecken, die haben nicht die geballte Developer-Power, die hinter dem Bitcoin Core stecken. Deswegen bleibe ich erstmal bei Bitcoin Core und warte ab, was da passiert. Die andere News ist, dass jetzt gerade Bitcoin 0.12 rausgekommen ist. Also gerade gestern, glaube ich, oder so. Und eine der Neuigkeiten da drin ist, davon abgesehen, dass es auch reichlich schneller ist als die alte Version, gibt es ein neues Feature, was die Leute brauchen, die immer sagen, diese Blockchain ist doch viel zu groß. Und zwar gibt es jetzt dieses Pruning, das gab es auch schon vorher. Aber jetzt funktioniert es auch, wenn man auch eine Wallet damit verwaltet. Das heißt, man kann jetzt einstellen, dass man eigentlich nur noch so zwei Gigabyte auf seiner Platte haben will und den ganzen Rest nicht. Und dann wird das alles nicht mehr so riesengroß. Das kann man jetzt da einstellen. Na ja, das kommt so an. Du musst das mal so sehen. Wenn du dein Bitcoin da am Laufen hast, dann das ist ja so ein Netzwerk an Nodes irgendwie, die sich alle untereinander connecten. Und zum Beispiel, wenn du jetzt dein Bitcoin startest zum ersten Mal, sagen wir seit einem Monat, dann willst du halt auch die Daten des letzten Monats haben. Das heißt, du willst die Daten aller Blöcke des letzten Monats haben. Und wenn du dich nur zu Leuten connectest, die auch Pruning anhaben, dann haben die eventuell die Daten, die älter sind als zwei Wochen waren es, glaube ich. Die haben die dann nicht mehr. Das heißt, du musst jemanden finden, der kein Pruning anhat. Das heißt, wenn die ganze Welt Pruning einschaltet, dann würde auch Bitcoin nicht mehr funktionieren. Das heißt, das können halt auch nicht alle machen. Es müssen schon so ein paar Piers geben, die irgendwie die gesamte DB da haben, um die einmal rausschieben zu können. Und man kann bei Pruning auch einschalten, dass man ein bisschen mehr hat als nur 2GIG. Also man kann die Menge halt regeln. Ich glaube, das Minimum haben sie so geregelt, dass man glaube ich die Blöcke der letzten zwei Wochen da hat. Bin mir jetzt aber nicht ganz so sicher, aber irgendwie so. Aber grundsätzlich für Leute, die nicht so viel Platz haben oder nur das auf dem Raspberry Pi laufen haben oder all sowas, die können halt mit Pruning machen. Leute, die ein bisschen dickeren Rechner haben, die das nicht stören, die machen halt einfach die gesamte Blockchain und dann ist gut.
Also ich habe hier, ich opfer hier gerade 60, 70 Gigabyte.
Ja, wie gesagt, bei dir habe ich ja schon mal gesagt, dass man da noch irgendeinen Directory könnte man bei dir löschen, den braucht man nicht mehr. Da können wir einmal rüber gehen und hauen das mal weg. Na man braucht... Auf dem Mac ist es in Library, Application, Support, Bitcoin. Und da liegt bei mir nur noch ein Directory mit Blogs, einer mit ChainState und der Rest sind eigentlich Files. Wenn du da noch einen anderen Directory hast, dann kann das weg.
Database habe ich noch, aber das ist nur 1 MB groß. Aber das Blogs ist halt irgendwie 70 GB groß.
Warte, ich guck mal, wie groß das bei mir ist. Du-sh. Oh, das ist alles Stern. So, zack. Mein Blogs ist 62 GB groß. Warum ist das bei dir so viel größer?
68. Weiß nicht, hab mehr Geld, weißt du wahrscheinlich.
Und diese Files da, B, Blog, 00001.dat, guck mal, die sind von 2012, die kannst du mal wegkloppen. Also die nächsten vier Files da, jetzt hast du die Sortierung geändert.
Ja, nach Datum.
Die, die ganz alt sind unten, lösch mal.
13. Alles, was sozusagen nicht 2016 ist.
Nee, nee, nee, dieses Address-dat würde ich mal aufheben, Fee Estimates würde ich auch aufheben, aber dieses Blog 03.dat, Blog Index.dat.
Das sind so Blog-Dateien.
Ja, hau die alle weg. Du kannst eigentlich, so grundsätzlich, kann man immer alles weghauen. Das Einzige, was man nie weghauen darf, ist Wallet.dat. Alles andere ist sozusagen egal, dann würde Bitcoin zur Not halten, 1, 2, 3 Tage, sich alles wieder neu laden, dann spielt das keine Rolle, aber Wallet.dat da ist, sind eure Bitcoins drin, das dürft ihr nie wegschmeißen. Macht da Backups von, macht da alles von, das müsst ihr retten. Das ist aber, die größte Datemanncache ist was anderes. Ich weiß gar nicht, wo man im GUI das Pruning einstellt. Vielleicht geht das noch gar nicht über das GUI, sondern nur im bitcoin.conf im Command Line. Vielleicht haben die das noch nicht ans GUI durchgeschoben, weil GUI ist noch ein bisschen hinterher. Ja, das haben die, da sind schon ganz viele Features, die die erstmal auch in das Protokoll einbauen. Dass sie grundsätzlich so Payment Provider und so weiter können, weil die nutzen ja nicht dieses GUI Tool, die nutzen ja andere Tools. Und das ist ja nur für den End-User hier, deswegen ist das da eventuell nicht alles immer gleich so drin. Ja, kommt sicher noch. Da musst du mal an die Anleitung gucken von der Version 0.12 und vielleicht steht das ja da irgendwo, wie man das macht. So, und da kannst du ja auch mal gucken, ob du da uralte Files drin hast. Auch 2013, aber das ist eigentlich okay. Du hast das halt seitdem so am Start, ne?
Na, das sind halt die Blöcke.
Ach so, da hat er die ganz unten. Da weiß nicht, ob dieses, oder? Ja, doch, das muss eigentlich passen.
Ja, man kann sich irgendwas sparen, aber nicht wirklich.
Aber man muss wissen, was.
Na, ich guck mal kurz bei mir rein, wann meine ältesten Dinger sind. Oh doch, die sind auch von 13. Juli 2012. Blog blk000000.dat. Bei mir haben die fünf Stellen, bei dir auch.
Ja, also kann man einstellen, aber keiner weiß wie.
Da gibt's ein Readme zu dem 012, da steht das alles.
Echt?
Und auch genau beschrieben, warum, weshalb, was auch das Minimum ist. Ich glaub, Minimum sind irgendwie so 540 MB oder so. Das sind halt die letzten, keine Ahnung, ich glaub zwei Wochen an Blöcken, damit man mindestens die da hat, damit man den Leuten, die halt die Blöcke bekommen, in was rüber schieben kann.
Heizung ist übrigens immer noch nicht an.
Da ist doch 20 Grad in diesem Raum.
Meinst du, das ist ja so warm, die braucht einfach gar nicht angehen. So sieht es nämlich aus. Such mal nach Pruning eventuell. Also ein Feature sets auch, dass wenn, da ist es, dass wenn sie merken, dass man Tor auf seinem Rechner hat, also da ist wohl ein Port offen dann irgendwie, dann wird, dann nutzt das Bitcoin jetzt automatisch das Tor-Netzwerk. Ja, und der Minimum-Value ist 550. Das heißt also man hat mindestens 550 Megabyte, wobei noch so ein paar Daten extra gespeichert werden, also das, aber ja, man kann das schon ziemlich gut runter regeln. Na, die ist in Library, Application Support, Bitcoin, da liegt die drin. Ja, das wird dann in der nächsten GUI-Version oder in der nächsten 0.12.1 wird das dann auch im GUI irgendwie durchgereicht. Das ist kein fix, das ist ein User.
Die ist wahrscheinlich in den Präferenz.
Bei mir ist da eine. Das Ding ist auch, mit der Version 0.12 braucht man eben diese Bitcoin-Conf nicht mehr. Früher brauchte man die immer, weil die da einfach mal so randommäßig so ein Passwort eingetragen haben, damit sich lokal keiner an dein Bitcoin-Demon connecten kann. Inzwischen machen sie das aber anders und starten halt irgendwie mit so einem Random Key im Speicher, wenn du das nicht von Hand einträgst und man braucht keine Bitcoin-Conf mehr.
Das war's?
Das war's erstmal, glaube ich. Und ansonsten können sich alle freuen, weil sie jetzt diese neue Security-Lib benutzen, die reichlich schneller ist. Also 5-7 Mal, sagen sie. Die haben jetzt mal OpenSSL rausgeschmissen und haben das durch was Eigenes ersetzt. Mit genau nur dem Kram, den die brauchen.
Immer eine gute Idee.
Ja, nee, man will auch bei Krypto nicht alles selber machen, besonders wenn man keine Ahnung hat, aber die bei Bitcoin haben sich da wirklich, glaube ich, schon seit zwei Jahren beschäftigen sich damit und haben unendlich Tools und Tests am Start. Haben auch schon mehrere Fehler in OpenSSL gefunden dadurch, weil die das natürlich dann auch gleich getestet haben, also parallel. Und ich denke immer, die haben das da im Griff.
Also wenn irgendjemand Krypto im Griff hat, dann wohl Bitcoin.
Sonst wär es ja auch schon im Arsch, weil da sind halt, Marktwert ist gerade, weiß nicht, sechs Milliarden Dollar oder so. Wir nähern uns übrigens gerade dem 400.000. Block.
Wird dann wieder halbiert?
Nee, halbiert. Kann man bei Bitcoin, bei der Bitcoin Clock gucken. Da gibt es eine Webseite. Ich guck mal kurz, wie die heißt noch mal. Hat man hier glaube ich auch schon mal eine Sendung. bitcoinclock.com. Da kann man sehen, die nächste Halbierung wird vorausgesagt für den 13.07. dieses Jahr. Da wird dann halbiert. Dann gibt es nur noch 12,5 Bitcoins pro Block.
Muss man sich dann auch so spezielle Brillen kaufen und so, wenn man der Block-Halbierung zuschauen muss. Nee, nee. Weil das halt so ein spezieller Event ist, der jetzt schon so weit im Voraus angekündigt wird, wie so eine Sonnenfinsternis oder so.
Ja, die können das nur einigermaßen vorausrechnen. Ich würde sagen, der wandert sogar noch weiter in Richtung Anfang Juli, weil die Miner gerade deutlich schneller werden, weil wieder neue ASIC-Chips irgendwie rauskamen und dann meinen die ja voll schnell und dann wird uns der Zeitpunkt noch ein bisschen entgegenwandern.
Ja, aber passt sich das dann nicht wieder an?
Ja klar, aber es ist immer nur nachkorrigierend, aber der korrigiert nur die Zukunft, aber er korrigiert nicht die Vergangenheit. Also was du mal zu schnell gemeint hast, das wird nachträglich nicht mehr korrigiert, sondern nur das, was du dann in der Zukunft meinst, wird angepasst.
So, wollen wir mal Podcast reden? Naja, verschiedene Implikationen.
Wir haben ja noch viele andere Themen, du vergisst das nicht.
Sorry, wenn da jetzt mal Dinge passieren, müsst ich da auch drüber reden. Das sind Klettbänder, Kabelklettbänder.
Den man primalkrach auf dem Podcast machen kann, um zu testen, ob Orphonik das auch ausfüllen kann.
Also, ihr werdet ja sicherlich euch noch ein wenig an die Klage erinnern, die hier schon mehrfach erhoben wurde, wiederholt. Bezüglich der Qualität des iTunes Podcast Verzeichnisses. Unter anderem versagt das ja bei HTTPS. Und es hat auch schon immer versagt, was so überhaupt Features betrifft. Im Wesentlichen bestand es darin, dass man dort halt ein Feed submitten konnte. Dazu musste man sich mit einer Apple ID anmelden. Und dann wurde dieser Feed geprüft. Gegebenenfalls auch händisch, auf jeden Fall auch automatisch. Und irgendwann war er dann approved. Und dann ist man in diesem Verzeichnis. Und alle Informationen, die in diesem Verzeichnis auftauchen, kommen aus dem Feed. Das war eigentlich auch eine sehr gute Idee. Nicht so eine gute Idee war, diesen ganzen Backend-Klimbim mit Web-Objects und Java 6 zu machen. Was dann dazu führte, dass sie halt mit dieser ganzen HTTPS-Welle der letzten Zeit irgendwie nicht so richtig klar kamen. Und es war so ein bisschen unklar, was denn Apple dazu tun gedenke. Und überhaupt tat sich halt in diesem ganzen Bereich herzlich wenig. Man erinnert sich auch, sie haben ja mit dem iPod das mal sehr massiv gemacht. Dann hatten sie Podcast-Support in iTunes. Haben sie auch bis heute. Das hat sich dann so vom Glück und Viel immer so ein bisschen gewandelt. Aber im Wesentlichen ist es eigentlich immer noch dasselbe in grün. Dann haben sie vor ein, zwei Jahren angefangen, Podcasts auch über iCloud zu sinken. Die Podcast-App haben sie neu gemacht. Nachdem sie ja auch am Anfang mal von vornherein dabei war, haben sie sie dann rausgeschmissen, haben sie wieder reingemacht. Also es hat sich die ganze Zeit so dieses, ist das jetzt eigentlich cool und wichtig?
Es war ja auch zwischendrin auch so ein Tape-Optik, oder?
Ja, das war dann, ja. Aber dann, also zumindest haben sie was dran getan. Und es war auf jeden Fall lange Zeit nicht so richtig klar, wie das so mit den Prioritäten ist. Und wer Apple so ein bisschen kennt, weiß, das kann bei jedem Projekt und bei jedem Produktbereich, bei denen auch jederzeit sich ändern. Jetzt hat es sich offensichtlich mal wieder geändert und sie haben in letzter Zeit eine ganze Menge Aktivität gemacht. Aber so richtig beim Podcaster oder beim User ist davon nicht angekommen, weil das eben auch alles ein bisschen Halbseiden war. Dazu kamen jetzt noch diese Probleme. Nun, letzte Woche hat Apple angekündigt, und das ging so in Stufen, sprach sich dann aber schnell rum, dass sie wohl jetzt an ihrer Podcasting-Verzeichnis, Struktur und Installation nennenswerte Maßnahmen ergreifen werden. Und diese Maßnahmen sind zunächst einmal Kleinkram, nämlich, dass sie irgendwie wieder mal die Anforderungen für Podcast-Cover hochgedrückt haben. Jetzt auf 3000 x 3000 Pixel. Nach dem Motto Retina is coming und die iPad Pro is coming. Find ich jetzt nicht so schlimm, hab ich auch ehrlich gesagt mit gerechnet. Ich fand vor allem schon die letzte Cover-Size-Empfehlung mit 1400 x 1400 Mega-Obscure. Das war einfach so eine Zahl, die irgendwie nirgendwo reinpasst. Jetzt mal also bei 3000 x 3000, meinetwegen. Dann haben sie noch angekündigt, dass es jetzt eine E-Mail-Adresse gibt, wo man hinschreiben kann, wenn man ein Problem hat. podcastsupport.apple.com Interessant ist, es gab schon immer eine E-Mail-Adresse mit irgendwas mit Podcasts, nur die wurde nie öffentlich kommuniziert und schon gar nicht haben sie empfohlen, da nochmal was hinzuschreiben. Und sie haben angekündigt, dass sie jetzt HTTPS-Support machen, wie sie meinen. Sie hätten also jetzt HTTPS für Episoden, für Cover Art und für XML, also auch für die Feats, also mit anderen Worten. Irgendwas haben sie in ihrem Backend gemacht. Wahrscheinlich haben sie einfach was neu geschrieben, um, wie sie sagen, HTTPS-Support zu bekommen. Klingt ja jetzt erstmal soweit nicht schlecht. Dann gab es noch etwas. Und zwar haben sie ein neues Portal eröffnet. Das heißt Podcasts Connect. Das geht so in dieser ganzen Serie von anderen Connects. Entwickler kriegen da wahrscheinlich schon auch so leichte Schweißausbrüche. Developer Connect und iTunes Connect sind ja auch so Systeme, die sehr hoch im Kurs stehen.
iTunes Connect heißt das Ding, wo man seine Apps verwaltet.
Womit auch diese ganze Signature-Geschichte gemacht wird?
Nee, das Signing machst du ja auf dem Client, also in der Entwicklungsumgebung. Aber du trägst da diesen ganzen Metadaten-Fuhr ein und sagst, das ist jetzt ab 18, weil da sagt jemand ficken. Und, weiß ich nicht, in der letzten Version hat sich... Und in der letzten Version sagt jemand Hitler. Nein, also diesen ganzen Scheiß und das Icon und dieses ganze Zeug, das ist Connect. Da steht dann auch immer Waiting for Review für 10 Tage und dann für eine halbe Stunde in Review und dann Ready for Sale und ja, dieses ganze Zeug.
Ja, und jetzt gibt es noch Podcasts Connect. Also schon mal ein kleiner Zungenbrecher. Und ich fragte mich, okay, Apple, was, was, erlaube. Nicht was erlaube, sondern was wollt ihr von mir? Ist schon mal ganz geil, wenn du jetzt auf Post, Podcasts connect.apple.com gehst.
Ich versuch das gerade.
Dann kriegst du erstmal die Meldung Podcasts Connect ist temporarily unavailable. Das ist jetzt seit ich das kenne.
Ist das so? Ich krieg hier ne Seite gerade.
Ich krieg hier ne Seite, steht Podcasts Connect erfordert einen iTunes Store Account.
Oh, bei mir sieht das gerade so aus.
Ja, da hast du schon den nächsten Schritt geklickt, nämlich...
Ich hab auf den Workflow Link geklickt.
Der leitet nämlich dann automatisch weiter auf itunesconnect.apple.com. Da kann man sich dann auch tatsächlich anmelden. Und wenn du schon mal ein Podcast submitted hast, Ohuckel...
Hab ich.
Und du dich da jetzt mit der entsprechenden Apple ID, mit der du das submitted hast, einloggst...
Probier ich mal.
Dann kriegst du so ein mega sophisticated User-Interface.
Mein mega langes Passwort eintippen.
Ist natürlich nicht mega sophisticated. Spoiler.
Alter, Spoiler. Freak. Ja, lockt sich ein, lockt sich ein, denk, denk.
Auf jeden Fall ist das unexciting. Man kriegt eine Liste aller Feeds, die man mit seiner Apple ID schon mal submitted hat. Und wenn die mittlerweile wieder gelöscht sind, dann steht da Deleted. Wenn die aktiv sind, dann sind sie Active. Und wenn sie abgelehnt wurden, aus irgendwelchen Gründen steht da Rejected. Und vielleicht gibt es noch ein paar andere Stati, die ich nicht kenne, weil die bei mir nicht auftauchen.
Aber das ist übrigens das gleiche Design und Toolkit, was sie da verwendet haben, was iTunes Connect auch ist. Also es sieht relativ ähnlich aus, es ist nur viel mehr Zeug.
Ja, ich mein, da sind zwei Sachen zum Anklicken. Einmal das Cover und dann, wenn du da bist, kannst du noch klicken. Achso, und dann kannst du wieder zurückklicken.
Genau. Das einzige, was du dort einstellen kannst, ist die Adresse des Feeds. Das ist insofern neu, als dass du jetzt quasi die Feed URL selber ändern kannst. Das heißt, du bist nicht gezwungen, eine Weiterleitung zu machen, sondern wenn du noch die Kontrolle über den alten Feed hast, kannst du sozusagen diese Weiterleitung innerhalb dieses Verzeichnisses selber vornehmen. Das mag manchmal ganz praktisch sein, ist allerdings jetzt auch nichts, was man jetzt täglich macht. Also bevor ihr da irgendwas einfach mal ausprobiert und abspeichert, bitte nicht, das könnte gefährlich werden. Auf jeden Fall war das Lustige, dass ich von meinen 10, 12 aktiven Feeds dort gerade mal zwei gesehen habe. Nun ist es aber auch so, dass es für privilegierte User schon seit längerem die Möglichkeit gab, mit einem anderen, ganz anders aussehenden User-Interface im Hintergrund seine Feeds auf eine andere Art und Weise zu verwalten. Und das betrifft die Leute, die von Apple als ausreichend wichtig angesehen werden, dass man ihnen sozusagen eine eigene sogenannte Artist-Page einrichtet.
Wie du sie hast.
Wie ich sie zum Beispiel auch habe, weil sie mir mal angeboten wurde, ohne dass ich das irgendwie initiiert habe. Das kam einfach so auf mich zu und da hab ich natürlich nicht nein gesagt. Aber so ARD, BBC und so weiter, also jeder Radiosender in Deutschland, der irgendwie Rang und Namen und Förderkohle hat, hat sowas und verwaltet das über den sogenannten Site Manager, was auch ein geiler Name ist. Im Site Manager habe ich aber vollkommen andere Funktionalitäten. Alles, was ich da machen kann, ist, dass ich meine Feats in so Gruppen aufteile. Das wird noch spannend, keine Angst, Fucke.
Nee, ich bin generell nur müde heute.
Ich versuche das nur mal so komplett zu erklären. In dem Site Manager tauchen wiederum alle anderen Feats, die ich auf der anderen Seite habe, auf. Das heißt, es gibt jetzt zwei Systeme mit unterschiedlicher Funktionalität. Und ein Teil meiner Feats ist in dem einen System und ein Teil meiner Feats ist in dem anderen System. Und es gibt irgendwie weder irgendeine gemeinsame Verbindung, dass man das irgendwie vereinen könnte oder rüber schicken oder so weiter könnte. Und da hatte ich schon so den Eindruck, ich werde Bedarf haben, bei podcastsupport.apple.com mal ein paar Fragen zu stellen.
Ich wollte schon fragen, ob du diese E-Mail-Adresse schon zur Anwendung gebracht hast.
Ich bereite ja sozusagen erst mal nur den Boden für die eigentliche Geschichte vor. Dann schaute ich mir meine ganzen Feats mal so an und stellte fest, das sind überhaupt gar nicht die Feats, die ich abgelegt habe. Und ich weiß sehr genau aufs letzte Zeichen, auf jeden Slash genau, welchen Feed ich im iTunes Store stehen habe seit zehn Jahren. Und die waren jetzt anders. Es waren trotzdem noch meine in gewisser Hinsicht, aber es waren die URLs, auf die meine Feats zuletzt temporär verwiesen haben. Also aus irgendeinem Grund hat iTunes Store die Feats, die da vorher waren, ersetzt durch die Feats, auf die ich temporär verlinke. Temporäre Verlinkung, das mal kurz zu erläutern, ist halt so was wie Feedproxy benutzen, ein anderes System, was für einen die Feats ausliefert, damit man nicht die Last auf dem System hat und die Statistiken macht. Also sowas wie Feedburner oder wie ich in letzter Zeit verwende Feedpress. Ich hab ja Feedburner rausgeschmissen. Und jetzt waren sozusagen nur noch die ganzen Feedpress URLs da und nicht meine, aber ich hab die ganz bewusst nur mit einem temporären Link versehen, weil ich halt nach wie vor die Kontrolle haben will über meine Feats, sie sollen unter meiner Domain sein. Dem war jetzt nicht mehr so oder ist nicht mehr so. Ich bin jetzt nur so halbalarmiert, weil ich schon so klug war bei Feedpress, meinem neuen Dienst, mir quasi alle Feats auf ein Subdomain von mir einzurichten. Das heißt, die sind jetzt alle Feats Metaebene ME. Die ist zwar bei denen gehostet, aber das ist sozusagen immer noch meine Domain. Das heißt, wenn ich jetzt wollte, könnte ich mir die einfach durch einen Domainwechsel auch wieder schnappen und dahin weiterleiten, wohin ich es gerne möchte. Aber ich hab mich natürlich gewundert, warum sind die überhaupt alle geändert? Weil das hat einfach mal nichts zu sein. Während jetzt auch alle diese Feats in dem neuen Interface, in dem Podcast-Connect, könnte ich die ja auch alle Hände sogar ändern. Ich hätte das selber in der Hand. Ist aber nicht so, weil ich ja auch noch den Zeitmanager habe, der ein komplett anderes User-Interface hat. Na ja, also fing ich halt an, an Podcast-Support zu schreiben und gesagt, irgendwie, was denn?
Erstmal RFC zitiert für Temporary und Permanent Redirects.
Ja, ich hab ja gesagt, hier Temporary Links, was ist bei euch los? Irgendwie viel zu all falsch. Dann kamen sie zurück und so, ja, ne, du hast ja da ein Redirect drauf. Hier guck mal, wenn du Curl machst und so weiter, kommen auch diese Uls bei raus. Also Leute, lest ihr meine Mails überhaupt durch? So, Temporary Link und erst mal so Quot von der HTTP-Seite, was ein Temporary Link ist und dass ein Subsystem dieses Nichts zu speichern hat und so weiter. Und so geht das jetzt irgendwie seit Tagen. Dann hab ich sie nochmal explizit mit diesen Beispielen der Freak Show drauf hingewiesen, hab gesagt, guck mal, das ist die Freak Show Feed-Adresse, das ist die Adresse, die ihr habt. Ja, kein Problem, hätte er jetzt geändert. Für die eine von zehn, die jetzt im Prinzip in Frage kommen. Hätte er jetzt geändert, wär jetzt okay. Müsste ich vielleicht 24 Stunden warten, bis ich das Ergebnis sehe. So, kein Problem, 24 Stunden gewartet. Ergebnis?
Wieder zurück geändert.
Nein, Freak Show ist jetzt überhaupt nicht mehr im iTunes-Direktorie. Freak Show existiert derzeit nicht im iTunes-Direktorie.
War die 24 Stunden schon um?
Ja, da waren schon 48 Stunden um. Ich hab das dann vor allem dadurch gemerkt, dass mir Leute geschrieben haben, dass wir auf einmal nicht mehr abonnieren können, weil die finden es halt nicht mehr. Wenn du jetzt eine Freak Show suchst, dann ist es halt nicht da. Das war sozusagen das Ergebnis dieser Maßnahme. Kannst du dir vorstellen, mit welcher Tönung die nächste Mail von mir kam. Es wurde langsam alles etwas hitziger.
Lass dir einfach mal eine Telefonnummer geben.
Der Sport ist... ja, ich... Also, soweit wollte ich noch nicht kommen. Ich hab's ja natürlich bombardiert. Ich hab dann vor allem auch noch irgendwie das zweite Problem angesprochen. Weil in diesem neuen System, was mir so frech, alle meine URLs listed, die ich ja mal submitted habe, außer denen, die in diesem alten System sind, tauchten auch zwei auf, die mir gar nicht gehören. Die hatte ich wohl tatsächlich mal submitted, aber es waren halt nicht meine. Ich hab die aber nur submitted, weil die Leute halt sich keine eigene Apple-ID anlegen wollten oder sonst irgendwelche Probleme hatten. Weil ich damals einen sehr guten Kontakt zu diesen Podcast-Hinies hatten, die natürlich auch am laufenden Meter wechseln, hab ich die halt irgendwie submitted, um da einfach so technische Probleme zu lösen. Jetzt hab ich zwei Feats in meiner Gewalt, die ich jederzeit ändern könnte. So einfach, naja, frag ich mich halt, wo meine Feats mittlerweile gelandet sind und wer die da jetzt machen kann. Also es ist halt alles ein bisschen Gaga und Apple. Ich weiß ja nicht, ob irgendeiner von euch zuhört, aber so geht's nicht. Also nur weil ich wirklich sehr, sehr, sehr vorsichtig war, ist es nicht schon eine Katastrophe. Und dass jetzt in diesem ganzen Prozess man halt auch noch aus diesem Verzeichnis wieder rausgeschmissen wird, macht mich auch nicht wirklich.
Versteh ich gar nicht.
Dann gibt's noch die Sache mit dem HTTPS. Das hab ich mir selber noch nicht so genau angeschaut, aber der erste Test war, mal gucken, ob das auch mit Let's Encrypt funktioniert. Weil, wenn sie jetzt sagen, HTTPS geht, ne? Hab ich jetzt nicht selber gemacht, hat Dennis gemacht, ging nicht. An Support angeschrieben, ja, Sie würden ja Let's Encrypt, würden Sie ja noch nicht unterstützen. Und hier wären ja sechs Provider, wo man sich ein Zertifikat holen kann, mit dem's ginge. Hier. Kriegt man natürlich auch so ein bisschen schwere Schnappatmung.
bugreport.apple.com Einfach Bugs schreiben.
Und dann?
Ja, dann geht es zumindest irgendwann seinen Weg.
Ich schreib Bugreports, ich schreib denen täglich Mails.
Nee, nicht Mails, du musst sie in den Bugreporter reinkippen. Und dann? Weil, wenn das einmal im Apple-Bugreporting-System drin ist, dann gehen die auch nicht so schnell wieder raus.
Das ist das Problem.
Ja, genau. Und die Apple-Engineers müssen sich irgendwann darum kümmern. Gut, es kann ja passieren, dass sie 5 Jahre später irgendwann meinen, das archivieren zu müssen. Aber die bleiben erstmal im System.
Ja gut, das hilft mir ja nichts, wenn die da im System bleiben.
Der Podcast soll im System bleiben.
Ja, erstens muss der Podcast wieder auftauchen und zweitens, ich meine, was ist denn das bitte für eine Antwort? Hier sind 6 Provider, wo du dir ein Zertifikat kaufen kannst? Ich meine, wie viele Provider gibt es da draußen? Heißt, es geht nur mit den Zertifikaten von diesen 6 Providern?
Hast du mal zurückgefragt, ob dem so ist?
Ja, natürlich haben wir das gefragt. Das befindet sich jetzt sozusagen gerade im Flow. Und ehrlich gesagt fällt mir kein guter Grund ein, warum, wenn sie das hier sowieso neu gemacht haben, warum sie als ausgerechnet mit letzten Crypt-Zertifikaten nicht klarkommen sollen, wenn sie eh dabei sind, alles zu modernisieren. Also was überhaupt diese Aussage soll, dass sie nur mit Zertifikaten bestimmter Provider klarkämen. Weil das kann ja wohl nun nicht der Maßstab sein. Dann gibt es noch einen schönen Nebensatz. Nämlich, dass sie nicht nur meinen, dass sie jetzt HTTPS unterstützen würden, nein, sie würden halt unter Umständen es auch requiren. Also nicht morgen, wahrscheinlich auch nicht nächste Woche. Ich vermute mal auch noch nicht nächstes Jahr. Aber das schreiben sie da so rein. Das finde ich wiederum ganz gut. Das wäre natürlich definitiv zu früh, jetzt schon dann Enforcing zu machen. Aber der Trend geht zu HTTPS, was sehr interessant ist. Weil die RSS 2.0-Spec, worüber alle Podcast-Feats definiert sind, ist ein Scheißstandard. Dave Weiner hat sich das mal geil ausgedacht, aber diese Spezifikation ist für einen Arsch. Vor allem definiert sie alle URLs nur explizit für HTTP und nicht für HTTPS. Und dann kommen sie halt auch irgendwie von iTunes mit. Ja, und Feedvalidator, kannst du ja mal überprüfen, feedvalidator.org. Hölle! Weil die Leute, die das gemacht haben, haben auch so richtig so einen Stock im Arsch und haben den natürlich genau so geschrieben, dass er genau dieser bekloppten Speck entspricht. Mit anderen Worten, wenn du eine HTTPS URL in deinem Feed hast, dann ist das ein Fehler in dem Feedvalidator. Weil, steht ja nicht in der Speck. Das heißt, Leute HTTPS 2016 irgendwie, nein, du musst dir zu Dave Weiner gehen, der muss dann die Speck ändern. Weil wir sind ja nur der Validator für diesen Feed, das ist wirklich irre. Und so, das ist jetzt die Landschaft, in der sich dieses ganze Podcasting befindet. Und jetzt geht es irgendwie auch gerade los, dass einfach so dieser Plattformdruck irgendwie steigt. Insofern jetzt mal ganz gut mit dem HTTPS, aber es wird halt auch schnell Kafka S gewinnen oder irgendwie wie so ein Trottel E-Mails schreibt. Und vor allem das geilste ist, du schreibst dir eine Mail. Eine wohlformatierte 30 Jahre Internet-Gedächtnis-E-Mail in Plain Text. Und was kriegst du zurück? Eine gebrandete HTML-E-Mail. Schreibst Text hin, kriegst wieder eine HTML mit. Können nicht quoten, ja? Du musst selber immer gucken, was ist denn hier gequotet und was ist hier nicht gequotet. Also wirklich wie Anfänger. Wie wirklich so... Volkshochschule, Internetumsteiger, die jetzt irgendwie so einen Kurs gehabt haben, wie sie mit Word-Mails schreiben können.
Und die setzen die da in den Support ran. Da würde ich aber nicht die Leute am Support anmachen, weil die meisten benutzen irgendein System, das spuckt halt dieses Zeug aus. Also du kannst davon ausgehen, dass die nicht vor ihrem E-Mail klein sitzen, sondern...
Das ist mir egal, ist ein systemisches Problem. Wer von denen da jetzt konkret schuld ist, weiß ich eh nicht. Ich kann ihn nur als Ganzes anschreien.
Jetzt sind wir wieder beim technischen Versagen gegen menschliches Versagen.
Ja, das ist da auch dasselbe. Also auch bei Apple könnten sie...
Fahren die Züge aneinander.
Da ist definitiv systemisch... Ja, da sind definitiv ein paar Leute auf eingleisigen Faden unterwegs, vor ihnen irgendjemand ganz schnell entgegenkommt. Und wenn sie da nicht mal ganz schnell eine Notbremsung einleiten, dann geht's da schief.
Aber Freak Show nochmal submitten willst du auch nicht?
Ich fange jetzt nicht an, deren State noch komplett durcheinander zu bringen, weil er meint ja, das wär ja da. Das müsste ja auch auftauchen, tut's halt nur grad nicht. Und jetzt hab ich halt diesen typischen Mails über den Ozean-Delay und schauen wir mal, was dabei rauskommt. Also noch hab ich jetzt keinen Anlass total durchzudrehen, aber wenn er sich das noch weiter so fortsetzt, vor allem das wirkt halt alles wieder jetzt wie so eine Verschlimmbesserung. Da wünscht man sich fast dann immer schon wieder den alten Zustand herbei.
Ja, schlimm.
Vor allem nicht Apple, die immer so wenig Ahnung vom Internet haben.
Achso, ja, okay. Hinweis an alle Podcaster da draußen. Abonniert mal eure Podcast-Feeds und exportiert das vielleicht mit iTunes in eine OPML-Datei. Guckt euch mal an, welche Feeds da tatsächlich sind. Insbesondere, wenn ihr Feedburner verwendet. Insbesondere, wenn ihr ganz bewusst mit temporären Links gearbeitet habt. Ich bin mir verdammt sicher, dass mein System nie einen permanent redirect rausgeworfen hat, weil der Code, der das macht, ist seit 2 Jahren nicht angefasst worden und ist eine Änderung, die da durchgeschlagen hat, die jetzt eigentlich erst in den letzten 6 Monaten erfolgt ist. Das kann eigentlich nicht sein. Also kann eigentlich nicht sein, heißt ich, was weiß ich, welche erratischen Zustände mein Server vielleicht dann doch mal gehabt hat, aber das macht aus meinen Augen alles keinen Sinn. Wer also aktiv in diesem Weiterleitungsbusiness unterwegs ist und der Meinung ist, es müsste eigentlich die URL sein und keine andere, schaut bitte mal nach und wenn ihr dasselbe Problem habt, kackt die an.
Mit Anlauf.
Genau. Und ansonsten müsst ihr euch wahrscheinlich mal auch Gedanken darüber machen, wie ihr eine HTTPS Migration macht. Derzeit kann man leider immer noch nicht empfehlen, einfach mal auf Let's Encrypt zu gehen, solange Apple sich da jetzt so komisch verhält. Sie schrieben auch gleich dazu. Nein, und wir können euch auch keine Timeline sagen, wann das soweit sein wird.
Wahrscheinlich weil alle fragen.
Die können das, ich meine, was ist denn das für die Reden von wir unterstützen jetzt ein Internetstandard und dann schicken sie mir Links auf sechs Firmen?
Ganz ehrlich, also als ich noch Wir unterstützten HTTP von Google und von Facebook. Als ich noch Support gemacht hab, hab ich auch nie ne Timeline rausgerückt. Du weißt nie, wie lange das dauert.
Du hast aber auch nicht so eine bekloppte Antwort rausgerückt, oder?
Na ja, manchmal musst du halt damit leben, was das Marketing da verschissen hat. Ja, ist doch so.
Two drink minimum. So, das war's jetzt von mir zum Thema Podcast-Feeds.
Nächste Thema. Ja, was ist denn denn bei dem Podcast? Da steht doch hier was von, mach doch mal wieder kurze Minithemen, bevor wir wieder ein Monster-Thema machen.
Wir können ganz kurz über Swift reden.
Wo wir gerade bei Web sind.
Genau, wo wir gerade bei Web sind. Wir können nur kurz über Swift reden. Heute ist irgendwie die vierte Beta von, ach was ist das jetzt, Xcode 2.7.2 oder so. Oh, das war gestern. Das ist ja auch jetzt nicht so. 7.3 Beta 4. Da steht das doch immer. Erschienen und das Lustige ist, dass jetzt langsam diese ganzen Änderungsanträge, die da öffentlich diskutiert wurden bei Swift Evolution, dass die jetzt alle durchschlagen und inzwischen in dem Swift Compiler für Swift 2.2 eigentlich alle Änderungen, die Breaking sind bei Swift 3 schon drin sind als Warning. Also wenn jetzt dann irgendwann die neue Xcode-Version für alle verfügbar draußen ist, wird der Compiler für alle Konstrukte, die in Swift 3 rausfliegen, ordentlich Warnings rauswerfen. Sowas wie i++, also der++-Operator und das Oldstyle-Fourloop, also C-Style-Fourloop und noch so ein paar Kleinigkeiten. Genau, also da das finde ich gerade sehr lit.
Ja, den LinkedIn hatte ich eigentlich schon zur letzten Sendung drin. Ich weiß gar nicht mehr, wie ich da drauf gestolpert bin, wahrscheinlich über Hacker-News. Also ich bin ja seit eh und je großer Freund davon, meine Privatseiten ohne WWW zu hosten. Das ist ja auch im Kurs bei den Studenten immer wieder so eine shocking News, dass dieses WWW eigentlich nur eine Konvention ist und gar nicht fester Bestandteil des Protokolls sozusagen ist. Und so, dass man auch www.meinegeileseite.de machen könnte und so. Na ja, da flippen die mal ganz aus und denken sich, können wir auch 23 www. Ja, geht auch. Man kann auch www.www.www.ww.com und so weiter und so fort. Naja, auf jeden Fall fahre ich das schon immer schick, das www.meinegeileseite.de auch wegzulassen. Und dann bin ich über so einen Artikel gestolpert, der da heißt, kannst du mal kurz hochscrollen, wie der korrekte Titel ist, www.meinegeileseite.de ist. Und da wird sozusagen einmal erklärt, warum diese www.meinegeileseite.de Subdomain halt durchaus sinnvoll sein kann. Und speziell auch gerade für größere Plattformen und Webseiten. Und wenn ihr euch auch schon immer mal die Frage gestellt habt, wieso und warum, dann empfehle ich das Studium dieses Artikels. Denn es hat tatsächlich so diverse Implikationen, die man nicht so direkt auf dem Radar hat. Also ich würde sagen, für eine eigene private kleine Seite macht nach wie vor keinen Unterschied. Aber wenn man halt irgendwie ein Domain hat, wo mehrere Sachen drauflaufen, oder ihr mehrere Subdomains sozusagen habt, wo auch Web-Services gehostet werden, dann kann das durchaus Sinn machen, auch das www unter einer eigenen Subdomain zu packen. Hat so Cookie-Implikationen zum Beispiel und DNS-Management-Implikationen. Ich kann den Artikel jetzt gerade nicht so super snappy zusammenfassen, weil das wie gesagt jetzt schon in diversen Wochen her ist, dass ich den mal gelesen habe. Der ist ja in den Show-Notes immer so ein bisschen weitergewandert, aber ich wollte ihn zumindest mal erwähnt haben, weil das mir auch irgendwie gar nicht so präsent war. Ich schick mal hier diesen Link. Ach, den habt ihr schon in den Show-Notes gepackt irgendwie. Irgendjemand hat das schon gefunden. Super, ich mach das. Ich pack das nochmal hoch.
Obwohl, ob es unbedingt www sein muss.
Ja, das ist natürlich, klar, muss nicht sein.
Was sie eigentlich sagen, ist, es gibt technische Gründe dafür, ein Subdomain zu haben, wo ich meinen HTTP-Content hoste.
Aber der ist halt nun mal traditionell und so.
Ich weiß nicht, ich mag das nicht mit dem www.
Ich mag das auch nicht mit dem www, aber zumindest bei Facebook oder so macht das halt Sinn, dass sie zumindest ihre Webseite noch mal subdomainen. Und zudem ist halt www, das ist einfach so im Sprachgebrauch drin. Also mittlerweile guckst du halt deutsches Fernsehen und die sagen URLs mit Schrägstrich an und sagen halt Slash. Und da ist halt auch dieses www, das weißt du noch.
Das klingt ja auch scheiße, vor allem auf Englisch.
Ja, vor allen Dingen, das ist eine Abkürzung, die sich länger ausspricht als wenn man es ausspricht im Englischen. Das ist völlig absurd.
Das stimmt wohl.
Das war's?
Ja, das war nur eine kurze Erwähnung.
Eine kurze Erwähnung.
Wer will? Was mit dem Shure Wireless-Microphone? Geht ja anscheinend auch bestimmt schnell, oder? Ja, da oben hast du aber. Mich interessiert das.
Dich interessiert das?
Ja, das ist doch bestimmt noch eine Kleinigkeit.
Wo steht denn das?
Da, drei Zeilen über deiner gestrichelten Linie.
Oh, da hab ich das hingeschoben. Na gut, das ist mehr eine Frage. Vielleicht weiß ja da jemand eine Lösung. Das ist nicht unbedingt was Akutes, aber es ist etwas, worüber ich schon öfter nachgedacht habe. Und zwar fällt das auch in den Bereich Podcasting rein. Und zwar mache ich mir immer so Gedanken darüber, was man noch so für Setups machen könnte.
Weil es bestehen ja so reibungslos, immer seit Jahren funktioniert und es wird langsam langweilig.
Erstens das und zweitens gibt es halt einfach so bestimmte Situationen, die ich halt auch ganz, wo ich halt auch ganz gerne so MyStyle aufnehmen könnte, wo ich derzeit einfach noch keine technischen Lösungen für habe. Also stationär ist ja alles möglich, so hier im Studio. So, kann man sich beliebig bequem machen. Aber wo es halt wirklich knifflig wird, ist halt so unterwegs. Also im Sinne von portable, da musst du halt kompakt sein. Aber was ich halt noch interessanter finde, ist halt so richtig Mobile Recording. Gut, Mobile Recording, sagt man, kein Problem. Kaufe ich mir irgendeinen Zoom, hast du nicht gesehen? Tralala, da habe ich doch meinen Mikrofon, das kann ich doch irgendwie in der Hand halten und durch die Gegend latschen. Kann man machen, aber dann ist halt scheiße.
Und auf Phonik fixst du das nicht?
Auf Phonik kann ich überhaupt nichts dran machen, weil es geht ja sozusagen um Folgendes. Was ich gerne machen würde, ist, ich würde gerne mit meinem Headset auf dem Kopf. Mit anderen Leuten mit dem Headset auf dem Kopf. Also zum Beispiel wir. Stellen wir uns vor, wir würden jetzt nicht hier so Sesselpupsend hier in der Mittalebene rumsitzen, sondern wir wären jetzt mal unterwegs. Auf einer Messe zum Beispiel. Oder auf irgendeinem Event. Oder auf einer Demo. Oder auf, keine Ahnung, auf irgendeine Party oder auf einem Camp. Angenommen, wir würden auf einem Camp ein Podcast aufnehmen wollen, während wir über das Camp laufen. Wenn du jetzt so ein gemeinsames Mikrofon hast für alle, dann müssen halt alle immer in so einer Traube durch die Gegend laufen.
Nee, jeder hat sein Headset und wir machen dann so einen auf Rattenkönig, wo dann alle Schwänze in der Mitte zusammengebunden sind an Mischbrit.
Oder hast du halt noch Kabel? Ich will keinen Kabel haben. Ich möchte, dass man auch 10, 20 Meter auseinanderlaufen kann, dass man von verschiedenen Positionen aus irgendetwas begleiten, besuchen, beobachten kann, aber sich im Prinzip genauso miteinander unterhält, wie wir das jetzt auch tun.
Naja, Wireless Monitoring, Wireless Mikro. Und los geht's.
Und diverse Millisekunden Latenz.
Nee, nee, nee, nee, das geht relativ latenzarm.
Womit? Womit? Ich kenne kein Produkt auf diesem Markt, mit dem man das machen kann. So, das erste, was ich jetzt überhaupt...
Jeder Musiker benutzt das doch, also das muss doch geben.
Jeder Musiker benutzt genau was?
Naja, irgendwelches Zeug, was weiß ich.
Ja, was heißt irgendwelches Zeug? Die Musiker stehen auf einer Bühne und haben dann irgendwie fünf 19 Zoll Racks, die da irgendwie an der Seite stehen, die den ganzen Scheiß haben. Ich rede von mobil. Und nicht mobil im Sinne von mit so einem Bollerwagen, wo irgendwie noch ein 19 Zoll Rack drauf steht mit irgendwie einem Generator.
Mobil ist relativ.
Mobil heißt, ich kann das mit mir rumtragen.
Wir fahren übers Camp in der Dreisine.
Was ich vollkommen okay finde, ist, wenn einer einen Rucksack auf hat, wo der Scheiß drin ist, meinetwegen auch noch mit einem Akku, aber im Wesentlichen soll eigentlich jeder nur einen kleinen Transmitter und Empfänger haben und ein Headset auf. So, lange lange Zeit dachte ich, da gibt es irgendwie gar nichts. Und dann habe ich durch Zufall, als ich in Holland war, auf so einer Audiomesser, habe ich halt hier auf dieser komischen, wovon ich letztes Mal erzählt habe, wo die dann mit ihrer Sicherheit und so, egal. Es gibt von Shure, gibt es so im Konferenzbereich tatsächlich ein decktbasiertes System. Muss mal kurz den Namen raussuchen.
Hä, aber das hat doch Latenz ohne Ende, oder?
Ja, das hat, also natürlich hat es Latenz.
Na gut, vielleicht nicht ohne Ende.
Im Idealfall.
Es hat nicht ohne Ende. Genau, MXW1 heißt der ganze Kram. Und das ist leider sehr teuer, aber Preis ist jetzt erstmal, ist mir jetzt erstmal egal.
Wie immer.
Na ja, ich wollte jetzt erstmal überhaupt irgendwas haben, was funktioniert. Das Coole ist...
Taschentransivor.
Genau, das ist der Taschentransivor, der gehört zu diesem ganzen System dazu.
Oh, 700, ja, okay.
Und dieser Transivor hat aber sozusagen nicht nur die Möglichkeit, jetzt ein Mikrofon abzusenden, sondern er hat auch noch einen Ausgang. Und die meisten Funk, Wireless, Mikrofonlösungen sind halt alle One Way. Du hast keinerlei Rückkanal. Und was der allerdings auch nicht hat, ist... der hat auch keine ordentliche Phantomspeisung. Also die haben nur 5 Volt, also diese sogenannte Plug-in-Power, 48 Volt kriegt der nicht. Das ist aber noch ein lösbares Problem, weil man ja 48 Volt auch zur Not noch mit dem lokalen Batteriepack machen kann. Also Phantomspeisung muss ja sozusagen nur so eine Grundspannung liefern. Das hat ja nichts mit Remote zu tun. Das heißt, da könnte man sich mit einem entsprechenden Adapter wahrscheinlich behelfen und theoretisch würde es halt damit gehen. Vielleicht kennt ja jemand auch noch irgendeine andere Lösung.
Vielleicht nimmt man für so einen Fall auch einfach Mikrofone, die nicht unbedingt eine Phantomspeisung brauchen, mit 48 Volt, oder?
Nein, ich will genau die Headsets aufhaben, die ich jetzt auch aufhabe. Exakt genau diese Teile und keine anderen, weil es gibt ja keine anderen.
Nicht auch noch die Diskussion. Na gut.
Ja, oder meinetwegen deine Variante, die 797, aber diese Art von...
Ja, die haben die gleichen Mikros drin, insofern ist es egal.
Genau, also ich möchte sozusagen korrektes Material haben. Gegebenenfalls, wenn man sich draußen bewegt, kommt auch noch ein anderer Aspekt mit rein, dass geschlossene Kopfhörer und Umstände nicht unbedingt, also ein bisschen hören, was um einen herum passiert, will man vielleicht auch noch. Weil diese Außenwelt tendiert ja immer dazu, mit einem zu interagieren.
Ich glaube, ein weiteres Problem ist, du musst dann aber auch ein Mikro haben, was halbwegs windgeschützt ist.
Ja gut, ich meine, da machst du halt einen dicken Muschel dran.
Sonst rennen deine vier Leute um die Ecke vom Zelt und kriegen alle ins Mikro.
Na gut, ich meine, das ist sicherlich noch ein Problem.
Es gibt ja auch diese Lavalier, wie heißen sie?
Lavalier.
Die sind ja eigentlich ganz gut so im nicht windempfindlich sein, wenn die halt nah dran sind.
Naja, da musst du halt einen Puschel drauf haben. Egal, wie das Mikro ist.
Einen kleinen, aber halt nicht so ein...
Die Lavalier, die sind schon raschelempfindlich wie blöde, da kommst du halt die ganze Zeit mit der Klamotte dran und irgendwelche Reißverschlüsse, Schaben da dran. Also Lavalier verbessert jetzt überhaupt nichts. Lavalier heißt nur, dass du es dir woanders hinsteckst. Du willst es aber im Prinzip, dass es halt direkt vor deinem Maul ist. Und wenn du da halt viel Wind hast, dann musst du halt mit so Puschelkram arbeiten. Das ist halt das Ding, das könnte man mit dem, was ich hier habe, eben machen. Dann mach ich halt einfach die Kugel, die ich jetzt dran habe, ab und ersetze sie dann halt durch so einen wilden...
Was einen in der Nase kitzelt.
Ja, so ein Schaf, was da halt irgendwie geschoren wurde. Und dann geht das schon. Aber das eigentliche Problem ist sozusagen die Lösung. Wie kann ich für vier Headsets sowohl lokale Phantomspeisungen machen, ok, das ist im Prinzip separat lösbar, und vor allem einen Rückkanal mit niedriger Latenz. Weil ich hab die Latenz bei diesem Teil ausprobiert und die war wirklich niedrig. Also es war, sie meinten zwar die ganze Zeit und ich hab's auch gemessen, es ist irgendwie 8 oder 9 Millisekunden sei, aber es hörte sich irgendwie nicht an wie 9 Millisekunden. Ich weiß nicht warum. Normalerweise reagier ich da sehr diffizil drauf. Leider ist das Problem hier, dass diese ganze Backend-Technologie, die du dafür brauchst, um das zu treiben und so weiter, einfach nicht mobile ist. Also das ist sozusagen von der Idee her schon mal das einzige System, das überhaupt so einen Rückkanal hat. Aber in der konkreten Ausführung ist es irgendwie zu teuer und es ist zu unflexibel. Weil dann kommt das Internet raus, ein bisschen noch einen Switch dabei haben und noch mal irgendwie Netzteile und so weiter. Also es ist halt irgendwie alles nicht für mobile gebaut. Ich will sowas mobile haben. Und ich stell mir das ziemlich cool vor, wenn man einfach so an Orte rangeht. Ich meine, erstmal würden natürlich die Leute einen anschauen, als würde man vom Mond kommen. Vier Leute, die alle mit so Headsets rumlaufen. Einer vielleicht noch mit dem Rucksack oder alle.
Darum geht's dir eigentlich, ne? Willst angeguckt werden als kämpfst du vom Mond.
Ja, natürlich geht es mir darum. Vor allem, man kann ja dann auch den Rucksack entsprechend machen. Vielleicht halt auch in so einem Alu-Weltraumanzug. Oder so einem weißen Overall.
Mit so pulsierenden LED-Streifen.
Ja genau, da steht dann nicht NASA drauf, sondern irgendwie Metaebene.
So wie bei Back to the Future, wo er in der Scheune damit so im Anzug dasteht.
Genau, und das irgendwie so als Rucksack. Und dass man einfach so mobilambulant einfach auf irgendwelche Events geht, Flohmärkte, was auch immer. Und von dort dann halt eine Sendung macht. Vielleicht auch live, nicht unbedingt. Muss natürlich erstmal aufgezeichnet werden. Aber ich stell mir einfach die Situation ziemlich cool vor. Vor allem, man wirkt halt extrem wichtig in so einem Setup. Weiß ich jetzt nicht sagen, weil ich jetzt der Meinung will, ich will jetzt wichtig rüberkommen, sondern weil das diesen interessanten Nebeneffekt hat, dass die Leute dadurch so dermaßen verwirrt sind, dass du denen halt auch alles erzählen kannst. Ja, wir sind vom ZDF, könnten Sie bitte kurz mal Ihren Stand beiseite räumen und so weiter. Oder hier kommt gleich Frau Merkel. Die glauben ja dann alles. Und das könnte irgendwie lustige Effekte erzielen. Nein, weil ich natürlich einen Overall anhabe, mit einem spacigen Rucksack und einen Kopfhörer aufhabe. Und weil um mich herum noch andere drei wichtige Typen oder Mädels rumlaufen, die auch mit so einem... Verstehst du, wenn du alleine bist, dann bist du ein Idiot. Aber wenn du zu dritt oder zu viert kommst, dann wirst du wie...
Dann bist du eine Idiotentruppe.
Dann bist du zwar eine Idiotentruppe, wirst aber nicht als solcher Waage. Dann bist du eine Guckentruppe. Nein, dann bist du ein SEK.
Ein Sendeeinsatzkommando.
Ein Sendeeinsatzkommando, so sieht es nämlich aus. Okay, das wär auf jeden Fall Kunst. Du wolltest das hier wissen, Dennis.
Ich konnte ja keine Ahnung haben, dass...
Dass ich da wieder so ein Universum entfaltete.
Ich denke da schon sehr lange drüber nach, das ist so ein Thema, was mich irgendwie seit zwei, drei Jahren schon beschäftigt.
Und wahrscheinlich hat er das schon 23 Mal auf die Themenliste geschrieben und wir haben es immer überlesen. Und jetzt dachtest du dir so, was ist eigentlich dieses...
Das Grundproblem ist, du willst Kopfhörer haben, die mit so einem Taschentransceiver verbunden sind, der wireless an deiner Basisstation funkt.
Das gibt es ja alles schon. Es soll so kompakt sein wie möglich, aber es kann auch so viel Platz wie nötig. Wie gesagt, wenn ich so einen kleinen Rucksack mit dem Zeug fülle, im Sinne von Akkuaufnahmegerät, Fernbedienungseinheit und jeder hat halt nochmal einen mobilen Receiver und vielleicht noch einen kleinen Akku-Pack für die Phantomspeisung, dann ist das okay. Dann hat halt einer die Kontrolle und über denen läuft halt auch der Mix. Und die Latenz ist insofern eigentlich kein großes Problem, weil man hier auch mit größeren Latenzen irgendwie halbwegs klarkommen würde wahrscheinlich, die aber auch niedrig sein kann. Und wenn man das halt so aufbaut, dass ich für meine eigene Stimme lokales Monitoring habe, ist das eh kein Problem.
Kann man sowas nicht mit Bluetooth bauen?
Bluetooth hätte glaube ich nicht die Reichweite.
Wie ist denn das? Kann man überhaupt mehr als irgendwie ein Bluetooth-Headset-Gerät koppeln?
Aber ich sag mal so, die Musiker, gerade die Sänger, die haben ja diese In-Ear-Monitors und das ist aber alles nur in Rek Hardware available.
Sind die In-Ear-Monitore denn wireless?
Natürlich. Schau dir doch mal die Videos von Vankanto an. Da rennen sie zu sechst mit In-Ear-Monitoring kreuz und quer über die Bühne und haben jeder auch ein Funk-Mikro dabei.
Was sind die Empfangsgeräte denn dafür?
Das weiß ich nicht. Ich könnte das in Erfahrung bringen, wenn es dich denn interessiert.
Ja, es sollte halt kein großes 19-Zoll-Unit sein. Wenn ich sozusagen für zwei Kanäle eine 19-Zoll-Unit brauche, dann...
Naja, aber einen 19-Zoll kriegt man auf dem Rucksack.
Einen 19-Zoll würde man vielleicht noch hinbekommen, aber das braucht dann halt meistens auch 220 Volt. Und es müsste halt schon auch so auf einem Akku-Pack laufen. Also wenn es auch irgendwie mit 48 Volt oder sowas laufen würde, wäre das schon besser.
Das Gerät macht ja aus den 220 Volt oder 230. Inzwischen macht es ja auch nur irgendwas kleineres, weil da drinnen, das braucht ja keiner 220. Musst du auseinanderbauen und bastelst dir die um.
Ja, das ist halt so. Ich wollte jetzt nicht unbedingt damit anfangen, dass ich erstmal alles auseinanderbaue.
Da willst du jetzt aussehen wie vom Mond oder nicht?
Oder willst du aussehen wie aus dem Data Center?
Man muss schon auch ein bisschen basteln dann. Und du hast doch die Leute am Start, die das können.
Nee, ich sag ja nur, ich finde, das wäre einfach eine Situation, die so bisher noch niemand gemacht hat.
Na ja, außer, na gut, das mobile ist halt...
Nee, es läuft keiner mit Headsets in der Gruppe rum, ohne dass du da einen Ü-Wagen noch im Rücken hast. Also vielleicht gibt es einen Ü-Wagen im Rücken, gibt es tatsächlich die Ausstattung? Ja, kann ich mir durchaus vorstellen, aber dann haben sie halt noch keinen Podcast rausgemacht. Vor allem nicht so ein Guerrilla-Ding.
Das sieht doch ganz schick aus, passt auch nur 1300 Euro.
Ja, hat aber irgendwie hier hinten so einen neuen Volt-Eingang oder so was. Ja, das kosten alle relativ viel, aber das würde man hinkriegen. Ja, das ist aber nur die Monitoring-Seite.
Einfach die Mumble-App aufs iPhone, guten Kopfhörer dazu, bumm, fertig.
Ja, also inwiefern man das halt irgendwie, hier kommt auch schon der Vorschlag, hier so Studio Link, LTE, Akku, das wäre alles ganz interessant, wenn man das damit vielleicht in Zukunft lösen könnte. Dann wäre ich da auch voll dafür. Ob LTE dann genug Latenz hat, dass man sich da auch, ja, hat es ja eigentlich, stimmt. Aber du musst halt auch so eine 1 zu N Situation irgendwie hinkriegen.
Also hier sieht es zumindest bei den ganzen Monetary-Dingern, da hast du halt keinen richtigen Kopfhörer, sondern hast halt diese oplappen Dinger.
Ja.
Dazu gehört das Teil, was du Gürtel hast, was so Walkman-Größe hat ungefähr. Und die Empfänger sind alle so ein halbes 19 Zoll. Also 19 Zoll halbe Breite.
7 Zoll.
Genau. Und dann haben die aber auch alle irgendwie ihr Steckernetzteil. Das heißt, du könntest das irgendwie mit dem Akku faken. Also das würde man schon hinkriegen. Das ist halt die Frage, ob du, wenn du vier Leute hast, brauchst du halt zwei, wo du irgendwie zwei Empfänger hast. Du bist halt schon auch mit relativ viel Geld dabei.
Na gut, Geld ist ja dann sozusagen ein nachrangiges Problem.
Da fragt Tim einmal im Podcast, ob jemand noch so was rumliegen hat, was er vielleicht nicht braucht. Und dann nächste Sendung türmen sich hier die Sendheiser.
Wenn was cool ist, dann kann man ja auch was einfallen lassen. So, ich wollte da gar nicht so viel drüber reden.
Dennis hat ja so interessiert gefragt.
Dennis wollte jetzt unbedingt wissen, jetzt hat er es bereut.
Das passiert mir nicht nochmal.
Dann können wir jetzt wieder ein längeres Thema nehmen, oder was?
Ich hab noch eins. Zwei. Nee, eins. Drei. Mehrere.
Was haben wir denn da noch Schickes?
Wir können was aus dem Bereich Kultur, aus dem Bereich Wissenschaft.
Wissenschaft.
Hier die Gravitationswellen.
Habt ihr mitbekommen?
Na ja, sie haben sie jetzt endlich entdeckt, nachdem irgendwie sowieso alle mehr oder weniger angenommen haben, dass es sie gibt. Wo ein Feld ist, ist auch eine Welle. Also es ist jetzt irgendwie... Ja, na ja, oder?
Irgendwo stand, dass sie so 99,5 Prozent eh schon davon ausgingen sind, aber jetzt sind es halt 99,99 Blaprozent und deswegen ist das nochmal ein dicker Move. Also jetzt sind sie sich schon ziemlich, ziemlich sicher und nicht nur noch sicher.
Sie haben es das erste Mal direkt detektiert. Also gab es halt vorher so Sachen, wo man sagt, ok, gewisse Phänomene verlieren Energie und die einzige Erklärung, die es gibt, sind Gravitationswellen.
Hat euch jetzt nicht so umgehauen.
Naja, sagen wir mal so, nicht so sehr, wie das in den Medien hochgehängt wurde, ehrlich gesagt. Also klar, das ist cool, dass man das jetzt kann oder zumindest, dass man jetzt mal bewiesen hat, dass es geht. Also ich meine, das ist ja jetzt noch kein... Wie die erste Fotografie, die ist halt extrem unscharf.
Nein, nein. Das ist ja nicht... Also das fand ich ja das Bemerkenswerte. Also hätte man jetzt nur irgendwie was nachgewiesen, was eine Gravitationswelle sein könnte oder vermutlich ist, aber man wüsste nicht so genau, was jetzt eigentlich.
Nee, nee, schon klar. Sie haben relativ genau erklären können, was das ist, was da diese Gravitationswelle gemacht hat.
Mit einem relativ, was wirklich mit einem sehr großen oder kleinen Faktor, je nachdem wie Roman Schäuble ausgestattet ist. Also ich meine, was sie getan haben ist, sie haben vor 10 Jahren überhaupt erst eine mathematische Methode herausgefunden, wie man simulieren kann, was passiert, wenn zwei schwarze Löcher, von denen man nicht wusste, ob sie das überhaupt tun im Weltall, aber wenn sie es täten, wenn zwei schwarze Löcher aufeinander prallen, dann müsste das vermutlich so und so aussehen. Und der Grund, warum sie sich ziemlich sicher waren, da die richtige Methode gefunden zu haben ist, weil es zwei Teams gab, die das gleichzeitig mit unterschiedlichen Lösungsansätzen auf exakt dasselbe Ergebnis gekommen sind in einem Abstand von einem Monat.
Das ist ja schon mal nicht schlecht.
Genau, und das ist so vor zehn Jahren passiert. Daher hatten sie sozusagen die Mathematik am Start und damit haben sie eine Vorhersage gemacht und das Geile an dieser Vorhersage war...
Da wussten sie, wonach sie suchen.
Da wussten sie unter anderem, also das war, sagen wir mal, von den Ereignissen, von denen sie annahmen, dass sie sie vielleicht beobachten können, war das eine der fettesten. Also so zwei schwarze Löcher, die aufeinanderprallen, ist schon so eher aus der energetischeren Abteilung und das besonders coole an diesem mathematischen Modell war, dass sie an dem empfangenden Signal direkt ablesen können a. es handelt sich um zwei schwarze Löcher, die aufeinander geprallt sind und b. wir wissen auch, wie weit sie weg sind und c. wir wissen auch, wie schwer beide sind. Also wie viel Masse in diesen schwarzen Löchern tatsächlich vorhanden war zum Zeitpunkt des Aufeinandertreffens. Das ist sozusagen etwas, was du da herauslesen kannst und das haben sie sozusagen entwickelt vor zehn Jahren, ohne dass sie jemals sowas beobachtet haben, weil schwarze Löcher entziehen sich halt leider, wie wir wissen, der Beobachtung. Insbesondere die schwarzen Löcher, die sie jetzt quasi beobachtet haben, entziehen sich der Beobachtung, weil die halt so wenig Masse hatten, die waren irgendwie sowas wie 30 Sonnenmassen, dass dieser Gravitationslinseneffekt nicht auftritt, den man jetzt so bei den dicken, fetten, millionen-Sonnenmassen-schweren schwarzen Löchern in der Mitte von Galaxien hat, wo dann so drumherum alles so verzerrt wird wie mit so einem Fischauge. Also es sind so pissschwarze Löcher.
Gibt es denn schon eine Vorhersage, wo die ungefähr sein müssten?
Ja, also wo die beiden waren. Dadurch, dass sie nur mit zwei Messstationen haben messen können, können sie nur so Pi mal Daumen in eine Richtung zeigen. Also es gibt zwar einen eingeschränkten, aber doch noch viel zu großen Bereich des Alls, wo das irgendwo ist, aber das ist sagen wir mal nicht so klein, dass du jetzt anfangen kannst, da mit Teleskopen drauf zu schauen, ob du vielleicht irgendwas anderes noch siehst.
Und wie ist es denn, da müsste doch eigentlich auch andere Arten von Energie dabei frei werden, die man vielleicht auf andere Arten dann messen kann. Radiowellen, Röntgenstrahlung, Licht?
Also wenn ich das richtig verstanden habe, das weiß ich jetzt nicht so ganz genau, gehen sie davon aus, dass das nicht unbedingt so ist. Und dass sie hier etwas beobachtet haben, was eben nicht mit anderen Methoden zu beobachten gewesen wäre. Wahrscheinlich weiß man das erst, wenn man es dann auch wirklich mal beobachtet hat, ob das dann auch wirklich so ist. Aber so habe ich das verstanden. Nicht nur, dass sie jetzt Gravitationswellen gefunden haben, sondern sie haben so gute Simulationen vorher gehabt und sie haben vor allem exakt genau dieses vorhergesagte Signal bekommen. Sie haben ja diese zwei Messergebnisse, wenn man die übereinander legt, dann waren die sozusagen identisch mit wenigen Nanosekunden Abstand, weil zu unterschiedlichen Zeitpunkten Empfang. Und dann haben sie halt dieses Simulationsergebnis darauf gelegt und es passte exakt. Also es war einfach genau diese Linie exakt genauso, wie sie das aus ihren Simulationen rausbekommen haben. Und deswegen fühlten sie sich ja auch so verarscht, weil sie ja den ganzen Apparat, der wäre ja sozusagen Next Generation, also sie haben ja sozusagen am 13. September haben sie das erste Mal dieses Advanced LIGO an Start gebracht, vorher hieß das LIGO und dann Advanced LIGO war halt die neue Technik aus Hannover mit jetzt zehnmal so viel Auflösung. Und jetzt müsste es doch eigentlich klappen. Einen Tag später geht ihnen irgendwie diese Messung ins Netz und die haben sich alle nur so angeguckt und dann das ist kaputt, wer will uns verarschen? Irgendeiner will uns jetzt verarschen. Irgendeiner, weißt du?
Na wollen wir hoffen, dass es nicht dabei bleibt.
Und deswegen haben sie halt jetzt auch so lange dichtgehalten mit der ganzen Geschichte, weil sie wollten sich wirklich sehr, sehr sicher sein. Und sie sind sich halt jetzt sehr, sehr sicher. Das heißt, sie haben A, definitiv mit einer sehr, sehr hohen Wahrscheinlichkeit Gravitationswellen entdeckt und zweitens mit derselben sehr, sehr hohen Wahrscheinlichkeit das erste Mal schwarze Löcher beim aufeinanderprallen, beim kopulieren zugeschaut. Und das ist halt der Beginn, also abgesehen davon, dass Einstein wieder mal recht gehabt hat, ist das im Prinzip der Beginn einer komplett neuen Astronomie-Form.
Jaja, schon klar.
Weil bisher haben wir halt nur Astronomie auf Basis von Elektromagnetismus, also Licht, Radiowellen und so weiter, Infrarot und jetzt gibt es halt noch eine Astronomie, nämlich die auf Gravitationswellen basieren kann. Die was ganz anderes sieht als die anderen, also die einfach Dinge sehen kann, die du mit den anderen Methoden nicht sehen kannst und die vor allem in der Lage ist, unglaublich weit und unverfälscht zu schauen. Was denn?
Neutrino.
Neutrino?
Ja, das ist das erste Mal, dass man quasi in die Kernfusionsvorgänge der Sonne gucken konnte, weil man aus den detektierten Neutrinos zurückschließen konnte, in welchen Verhältnissen welche Kernfusionsreaktionen stattfinden.
Das macht Sinn. Das zählt ja nicht als Elektromagnetismus.
Ne, das sind ja ungeladene Teilchen.
Vielleicht muss ich gar nicht so viel erzählen. Ich kann ja an der Stelle nochmal einen Podcast planen. Ich habe für Raumzeit ein langes Gespräch über diese ganzen Gravitationswellen-Kram gemacht. Ist da auch schon im Chat gelandet, sehe ich gerade. Und da kann man sich mal ordentlich schlau machen.
Ich hatte ein bisschen das Gefühl, dass du dieses Konzept welle, dass du da Probleme mit hattest. Insgesamt. Weil irgendwie die Fragen waren so und der Gesprächspartner wusste auch nicht so recht, was er antworten soll.
Jaja, das sind ja immer die schwierigen Sachen.
Na ja, sagen wir mal so. Ich hab halt irgendwie das Gefühl, dass ich schon wusste, wovon er redet.
Ja, das ist dann immer einfach.
Ja, das ist immer einfach. Also ich weiß nicht, ob das jetzt für jemanden, der jetzt nicht so richtig... Also es gibt ja dieses Dualismus-Welleteilchen und diese ganzen Inferometer, diese Inferenzsachen, die man halt in der Schulphysik später so macht. Da muss man halt seinen Hirn so drum rumkriegen. Also wie halt so Wellenphänomene funktionieren. Also ich finde, wenn man so Wellenphänomene an sich verstanden hat, dann ist jetzt auch die Vorstellung, dass sich jetzt beschleunigte Massen eine Gravitationswelle erzeugen, nicht fürchterlich weit hergeholt. So wie halt eine beschleunigte Ladung eine elektromagnetische Welle erzeugt. Oder ein beschleunigtes Luftteilchen, eine Schallwelle.
Ja, das habe ich jetzt auch nicht in Abrede gestellt. Worum ich ein bisschen gekämpft habe, ist sozusagen eine etwas bessere Definition von Gravitation. Aber da muss ich dann einfach einsehen, dass sozusagen die Wissenschaft an der Stelle selbst einfach nur mit Modellen arbeitet, weil sie halt einfach keine konkrete Erklärung dafür haben, wie die Gravitation in den Raum krümmt. Man weiß nur, sie macht es.
In dem Zusammenhang gibt es einen Omega-Tau-Podcast, den ich zweimal angehört habe und ich glaube, ich höre ihn auch nochmal drittes Mal an, über die String-Theorie. Der geht ganz schön heftig ins Detail.
Das Thema habe ich ja bisher aus denselben Gründen vermint. Da braucht man echt eine gute Basis.
Das ist extrem spannend, aber da hört es dann auch auf. Aber der Mann kann das wirklich gut erklären. Man hat das Gefühl, mit so einer soliden Schulfysik-Leistungskurs kommt man da einigermaßen durch, ohne dass man nach einer halben Stunde schon nicht mehr weiß, wovon er redet. Der ist auf Englisch. Na ja, bei Omega Town machen die es gerne mal, dass sich zwei Deutsche dann auf Englisch unterhalten. Aber er macht das gut, also wirklich.
Ja, mal gucken. Ich darf mir ja bestimmte Podcasts gar nicht anhören.
Weil?
Na dann weiß ich ja schon was da drüber.
Das stimmt, aber für die Hörer als Tipp. Der ist schon geil.
Er ist in dem Chat gelandet. So, jetzt können wir den Part auch abschließen.
Im Lexikon oder im Wörterbuch neben dem Wort Kultur ist ein Bild von Dennis. Kultur nehmen wir mal Star Wars.
Star Wars, haben wir schon lange nicht mehr darüber geredet. Ich dachte ja, das Thema wäre jetzt mit der letzten Sendung dann auch irgendwie durch. Mitnichten.
Schalten sie auch nächste Woche wieder ein.
Wenn es heißt, bei Weekly Star Wars.
An der Stelle schönen Dank an Jason, der hat in der letzten Sendung einen Kommentar platziert, der mich sofort entfachte und mir dann wieder eine Nacht raubte. Und zwar empfohle er ein Review oder vielmehr drei Reviews von einer Kunstfigur Mr. Plinkett. Und dieser Mr. Plinkett arbeitet sich sozusagen in Review zu Review durch Episode 1, 2 und 3 durch. Und wenn ich vorher so ein bisschen den Eindruck gemacht habe, ich hätte die nicht gut gefunden und die hätten mich nicht so begeistert und es gäbe Dinge, die mir nicht gefallen haben, nach Konsum dieser drei Reviews, die ausgesprochen unterhaltsam sind, muss ich anerkennen, diese Filme sind wirklich ein totales Trainwreck. Also das ist noch schlimmer, als ich das selber bisher so gefühlt habe und das wird einem durch diese Reviews wirklich klar und man weiß auch, wer schuld ist. Ich meine, das wusste man wahrscheinlich auch schon vorher, aber er zeigt es halt einfach, George Lucas hat es einfach verkackt. Und zwar nicht George Lucas hat es geschehen lassen, sondern er selber hat es verkackt, selber hochpersönlich.
Mit wehenden Fahnen quasi.
Warum hochpersönlich?
Weil er einfach eine faule Sau ist. Er sitzt einfach die ganze Zeit da, trinkt Kaffee und macht alle seine Einstellungen irgendwie mit AB-Kameras und irgendwie das erzählt er dann auch. Das ist nämlich sehr interessant. Also er macht so dieses Review, zeigt viel aus den Filmen, zeigt so Sachen, warum das irgendwie langweilig ist, warum sich da alles wiederholt und bei 1, 2, 3 wiederholt sich das auch am laufenden Meter. Ich meine, allein wie viele Szenen es gibt, wo die auf dem Sofa sitzen und reden. Ich habe das Gefühl, der halbe Film besteht aus Szenen, wo die entweder auf dem Sofa sitzen und reden oder im Flur stehen und reden. Und immer ist die Kamera links, rechts, links, rechts, links, rechts, links, rechts. Immer so von Schreck vorne irgendwie. Keine Kamerabewegung, einfach nur ab Kamera, einfach nur immer hin und her schalten. Überhaupt keine besondere Kamera. Und das wurde mir dadurch erst klar. Das ist natürlich der ganze Film. Du kannst ja überhaupt nichts merken. Also der Punkt, wo es wirklich vernichtend ist. Er hat dann Leute diese Filme gucken lassen und hat sie danach interviewt und hat sie gebeten, die Charaktere der einzelnen Protagonisten dieser Filme zu beschreiben, ohne dabei zu sagen, was sie konkret da tun und was sie für Klamotten anhaben und noch so ein, zwei, drei diskriptive Sachen rausgelassen sein. Er wollte sozusagen nur, dass sie sagen so, was sind das für Charaktere? Was sind das für Typen? Und dann hat er das auch mal so hin und her gemacht mit Charakteren aus Star Wars 4, 5, 6. Und Charakteren aus 1, 2, 3. So, Han Solo. Ja, und ein Draufgänger und irgendwie witzig und dann will's irgendwie immer sein, this way haben und so, aber dann doch irgendwie für Freundschaft zu haben. Also alle wussten sofort, was sie zu erzählen haben, um Han Solo zu beschreiben. Und dann so, ja, beschreibe Prinzessin Amidala. Ja, also so, ja, oder Obi-Wan-Knowy, ja, alle wussten überhaupt nicht so richtig, was sie sagen sollen. Und ich dachte mir auch so, ja was eigentlich? Weil die haben alle keine Charaktere. Die sind einfach vollkommen blasse, ausauschbare Püppchen in diesem Film. Und zwar alle. Also es gibt da einfach überhaupt nichts. Und auch das Ganze, er nimmt alles auseinander. Auch dieses ganze Nichtwerden von dem Anakin Skywalker und diese ganze Sinnlosigkeit. Ich kann jetzt diese Reviews nicht zusammenfassen. Ich glaube, jedes Review ist, glaube ich, eine dreiviertel Stunde lang bei jedem Film. Also es ist nicht mal so eben. Ja, es ist ein Video Review. Das ist richtig so YouTube, ein langer Play, das besteht aus mehreren Teilen und ist so richtig lang. Aber es ist totally worth watching. Also ganz groß. Allein schon deshalb, weil das auch diese Reviews und diese, er schneidet dann auch mal so vollkommen absurde Sachen damit rein, wo er dann irgendwie selber auf einmal in seinen virtuellen Keller reingeht, wo irgendwie irgendwelche gefesselten Frauen rumliegen und um Befreiung schreien, was sozusagen ist. Verstehst du? Also es gibt dann auch noch so einen Film in diesem Review und es ist alles total irre. Also es ist sehr geil. Es ist wirklich absolut episch und kann ich nur sehr empfehlen und danach bleibt leider nicht viel übrig von Episode 1, 2, 3. Ja und dann gab's noch für die richtigen Hardcore-Fans gab's noch mal ein Release, nachdem wir neulich hier schon die Specialized Version vorgestellt hatten, die auf Basis des neuen Materials durch Editiermaßnahmen versucht hat, den alten Film wieder herzustellen, das aber in HD. Gibt's jetzt auch den Original-Film in quasi HD, also auf jeden Fall in 16 zu 9. Ich weiß gar nicht, was das für eine Auflösung ist. Also es ist schon auf Full HD gemacht, aber man merkt, das ist halt jetzt ein unautorisierter Scan von einem 35mm Originalprint. Also es gibt da irgendwie eine Truppe, die hat ihre Hände an den Original-Zelluloid bekommen, der halt mal in einem Kino abhanden gekommen ist.
Der eigentlich für tot erklärt wurde, weil Lukas hat gesagt, die Änderungen für seine Special Editions da wurden durch Zerschnipseln des Originals gemacht. Na, diese Änderung mit diesem, wo die halt nochmal so CGI-Kram da einbauen und so. Das hätten sie wohl gemacht und dabei das Original auch zerstört, weil er meinte, das brauchen sie eh nicht mehr, weil sie haben jetzt das neue.
Nein.
Stand irgendwo, hab ich heute gelesen. Hat er gesagt! Stimmt ja anscheinend nicht.
Das ist ein Print aus einem Kino.
Aus einem Kino, das ist mal irgendwo so auf einer Rolle gewesen und ist irgendwie nicht retourniert worden. Was normalerweise so... also das ist ja jetzt kein... das Original ist ja auch kein 35 Millimeter Ding, oder?
Ja, es wurde nicht alles in 70 gedreht, damals.
Weiß ich auch nicht, aber es ist ein Print, also es ist sozusagen eine Kopie und die haben sie halt genommen und die hat jetzt nicht so die mega... also erst mal ein bisschen... ich hab noch nicht so richtig viel reingeschaut.
Das ist sehr grainy, also man sieht schon die Filmkörnung so, aber der RIP, ich pumpt mal hier einen Torrent in den Chat. Das Ding ist wie viel groß? 26 Gigabyte, also Apple Gigabyte. Also sie haben wirklich da so ein high quality RIP draus gemacht und mehr konnte man wahrscheinlich nicht rausholen aus so einer alten Filmrolle. Aber ich denke mal, wer die alte Version guckt, dem ist das auch egal, da geht es dann nicht mehr darum, weil da geht es dann eher, dass es halt da original ist, so wie man es damals im Kino gesehen hat.
Ja, also das ist halt vor allem, ist es jetzt gut, weil das eben die erste digitale Version ist, von dem Originalfilm in 16 zu 9, die nicht die Laserdisc-Variante ist.
Da stand auch auf der Blu-ray oder irgendwo auch dieses noch...
Die 4 zu 3 Version noch drauf hatten.
Ach, das war nur als 4 zu 3, das war so Letterboxx.
Ja, ich glaube, das war nur diese VHS-Version. Das wusste ich nicht. Na ja, könnt ihr euch angucken. Ich glaube, das war's dann auch zu Star Wars.
Final.
Ich kann mir jetzt nicht vorstellen, dass ich zumindest zu 1 bis 6 noch was sage, aber man könnte ja noch mal zu 7 was sagen.
Nee, ich hab den noch nicht gesehen.
Was willst du denn zu 7 sagen?
Du spoilst mich sonst wieder.
Du hast den immer noch nicht gesehen. Du, mit deinen 1700 Filmen hast du den besten Film des Jahres noch nicht gesehen.
Das ist deutlich nicht der beste Film des Jahres. Vor allem war das letztes Jahr, da gab's wohl deutlich besseres. Du bist nur gerade im Star Wars-Hype. Das ist alles.
Ja, natürlich. Aber das ist halt Star Wars und das ist definitiv...
Naja, ist vielleicht besser als 1, 2, 3.
Besser als 1, 2, 3 ist kein Maßstab. Also 1, 2, 3 sind richtig schlechte Filme. Und 7 ist sozusagen die Rettung von Star Wars.
Ich fand ihn aber auch nicht... Also da sind viele Leute anderer Meinung.
Ich fand ihn von der Handlung doch erstens sehr vorhersehbar, bis auf jetzt einige Details. Bis auf die Handlung? Nein, also 80 Prozent der Handlung war einfach sehr vorhersehbar. Weil es ist nichts Neues. Und dann fand ich viele Sachen waren halt auch so, so Nummerngirl-Theater, weißt du so. Das müssen wir jetzt noch abhaken, und das müssen wir jetzt noch abhaken, und das müssen wir noch abhaken. Und dann wieder die Rebellen, und dann wieder die Bösen, und dann wieder das, und dann wird da noch was gesprengt. Und also das ist irgendwie so, ich weiß nicht, ich fand den.
Du hast den doch nicht oft genug angeguckt, glaube ich.
Ja, ich wollte ihn mir auch kein zweites Mal angucken, nein.
Also ich will ihn definitiv noch ein drittes Mal anschauen, weil der Film hat halt genau das, was 123 halt nicht hat.
Das mag ja sein.
Hervorragende Charaktere. Also Rey, die Protagonistin, das Mädel. Das ist einfach eine fantastische Person. Also ich meine, das ist einfach einer der geilsten Charaktere, den ich seit langem im Kino gesehen habe. Ich will jetzt nicht so viel rumspottern, weil dann dreht Dennis irgendwie durch. Aber dieser Charakter, den sie dort entwickelt haben, das ist eine Frauenrolle, eine Hauptrolle in einem Blockbuster-Film, Like No Other, die gab es so noch in keinem Blockbuster, hast du jemals so eine Frauenrolle gesehen.
Nein, bin ich aber auch noch ehrgerig.
Ja, Fifth Element vielleicht. Ich weiß nicht, also wer denn?
Das ist auf jeden Fall schon mal eine steile.
Wer war denn die Hauptrolle in Fifth Element?
Ich weiß es nicht mehr so genau. Aber ich kenne auch nicht so viele Filme. Aber ich fand auch diese ganzen Ausflüge zu Herr der Ringe und dann wurde es irgendwie ganz abstrus, mystisch und so. Es war alles ein Gonglomerat von Merkwürdigkeiten. Na, wie dieser Typ da auf seinem Thron sitzt und so. Also, hör uff, hör uff. Hör uff, was eine Scheiße.
Oh Gott, da sitzt jemand auf seinem Thron.
Ich schaue den ja irgendwann mal.
Mach dir mal deine eigenen Gedanken.
Also, ich finde die Charaktere super. Ich finde Finn super. Ich finde Rey super. Ich finde Han Solo spielt gut seine Rolle.
Ja, aber es ist so vorhersehbar, so vorhersehbar. Da kriegt der eine Stormtrooper irgendwie einen Blutschmier auf den Helm.
Verstehst du denn das nicht?
Du denkst dir sofort, warum hat der jetzt einen Blutspritzer auf dem Helm?
Du spoilst. Man kann das auch anders erzählen, doch?
Ich müsste das gar nicht erzählen.
Ich sage nur, sieben ist der Anfang.
Ja, von was?
Von acht und neun.
Ach so. Ja, meinetwegen.
Und die Story, was auch immer du als vorhersehbar empfindest, ich meine, du magst vielleicht gedacht haben, der Film müsste sich an der Stelle jetzt so und so entwickeln. Ja, vielleicht hat er das getan. Ist auch deshalb schon so vorhersagbar, weil das halt immer so ist in den ersten Filmen, weil es halt einfach so ein zyklisches Element gibt, was sich eben in Star Wars auch immer so abbildet. Trotz allem, die haben eine ganze Menge...
Gab es auch wieder abgehackte Hände und so?
Ich spoil nicht. Es gab auf jeden Fall Dinge, die sich wieder erholt haben, aber die haben sich ja auch bewusst wiederholt.
Ja, um nicht zu sagen, es gab eigentlich wenig Neues.
Naja, es gab vor allem...
Sehr wenig Neues.
Es gab hervorragende Charaktere.
Wenn es ein Teil von Storys gibt, dann kommt da auch nicht mehr viel.
Aber wie kommt dir denn auf die These, dass Star Wars noch in irgendwas besserem als 35 Millimeter existiert?
Er meint das, ich nicht. Weil es 70 Millimeter gibt und Timme davon aussieht, dass alle tollen Sachen in 70 Millimeter gedreht wurden.
Die allerwenigsten Filme sind in 70 Millimeter gedreht.
Das war auch nur eine gewisse Zeit lang, dann haben die das nicht mehr gemacht.
Ja, also zumindest würde es ein Original gegeben haben, aber wenn es das jetzt nicht mehr gibt, dann gibt es das halt nicht mehr.
Das Original war aber auch in 35. Also es gibt wirklich nur, 2001 zum Beispiel der Blu-ray-Rip, der sieht halt wirklich mega krass fantastisch aus, weil der wurde halt in 70 Millimeter gedreht. Hier, Tron. Tatsächlich, uuuh. Ja, es gibt in der Wikipedia eine Liste der Filme, die in 70 Millimeter gedreht wurden, das sind, was weiß ich, 30, 40? Und war das nicht so, dass bei 70 Millimeter damals war das Bild halt noch anders als bei IMAX? Also bei IMAX haben sie es quasi noch so, wenn die Rolle so hoch geht, also vertikal, dann war bei 70 Millimeter normal, war das dann quasi horizontal. Und bei IMAX haben sie es dann halt auch vertikal entlang der Rolle gelegt, um noch mehr Filmgrain sozusagen zu kriegen.
Eine Sache noch, dann bin ich fertig. Wer Star Wars 7 schon gesehen hat und Lust hat auf ein gutes deutsches Review, davon empfehle ich jetzt mal hier den Podcast Picknick am Wegesrand von Caspar und Gregor. Die letzte Folge 40 widmet sich genau Star Wars Awakens mit Gast Patricia Camarata und das ist ein faszinierendes, großartiges Review von diesem Film, das ich jedem nur empfehlen kann. Ihr müsst ihn gesehen haben und vielleicht zweimal auch schon, dann lohnt sich das sozusagen richtig.
Kleine Sache noch, wenn wir schon bei Filmen sind. Ein Kickstarter und zwar gibt es da einen Film, den Leute gedreht haben, Tex Montana Will Survive. Heißt der über einen Typen, der so Survival, also der Film ist über diesen Typen, der so Survival-Shows macht und irgendwann kommt heraus, dass er gar kein Survival-Typ ist, sondern dass das alles nur gefaked ist und dann geht er in die Wildnis, um zu beweisen, dass er doch Survival kann und so, was wohl scheinbar ganz gut schiefgeht. Das interessante ist, der Film ist gedreht, der ist fertig und die sagen, wenn wir jetzt bei dem Kickstarter so und so viel Geld abgreifen, dann könnt ihr den alle für umme aus dem Internet laden. Ansonsten geht er die normalen Distributionswege.
Hier fehlt ein Link.
Ja, der ist jetzt da.
Da muss er nicht hin.
Ja, ist ja gut, ich tu den auch noch in dein Dingens da.
Nicht in dein, in unser Dingens.
In unser Dingens.
Workflow unser.
Du musst hier mal den Community-Aspekt unterstreichen.
Leute. Ach so, ja, und das sind jetzt noch einige wenige Tage. Und sie haben es so halbwegs fast geschafft. Aber eben noch nicht so ganz.
48.000 Dollar? Um den Film komplett zu produzieren?
48.000 von 50. Naja, es könnte ja noch klappen. Nein, produziert ist er schon. Also sie wollen jetzt, ja, keine Ahnung, scheinbar. Das ist jetzt das Geld. Wenn sie das zusammen kriegen, kann jeder den runterladen. So habe ich das verstanden.
Mit dem Typen habe ich schon einen Film gesehen, der heißt The Blue Ruin.
Ihr könnt euch auf jeden Fall mal das Preview angucken. Das ist sehr lustig.
Doch, da habe ich doch was gesehen.
Aber wie haben sie denn den Film finanziert? Haben sie den einfach so gemacht oder?
Ja, scheint so.
Also The Battery habe ich gesehen von dem Typen. Ja, ganz witzig. Da kann ich gleich wieder bei Letterboxd klicken. Wie sagt man? So ein Small Budget-Movie.
Ja, der ist sicherlich Small Budget, weil es ist nur der eine Schauspieler.
Dabei The Battery war einst zwei, war auch schon ganz witzig.
Ja, wo wir gerade bei Crowdfunding sind, Nachtrag zu dem hier vorletztes Mal besprochenen Projekt All Creatures Welcome. Der Doku über das Camp und den Kongress und Chaoskultur und so weiter. Das ist gestern, ist die Phase 1 abgelaufen. Und es hat dann auf den letzten Metern auch funktioniert. Was sehr schön ist. Das heißt, das Ding ist jetzt sozusagen noch im Rennen. Ich werde jetzt mal nicht die ganze Geschichte mit dem Film aufrollen. Wer sich das noch mal genauer anhören will, weil noch nicht so richtig geschneit, worum es geht. Wir haben es hier beim Freak Show besprochen. Und es gibt in der vorletzten Logbuch Netzpolitik auch ein längeres Interview zu dem Thema. Auf jeden Fall sind jetzt 27.000 Euro zusammengekommen. Und das ist jetzt sozusagen erstmal der Schritt gewesen, um jetzt die weitere Produktion zu unterstützen. Am Ende allerdings, um dasselbe Ziel zu erreichen, wie jetzt der Film, den du jetzt gerade erwähnt hast, nämlich den Film komplett freizumachen, weil er dann eben sozusagen keinerlei Fördergelder mehr in Anspruch nehmen muss auf Kreditbasis. Und erst dann ist man sozusagen frei von diesen Distributionsanschränkungen. Müssen dann nochmal irgendwie 115.000 zusammenkommen. Dafür ist aber jetzt auch noch Zeit. Das heißt da kann man jetzt sozusagen dieses Jahr schauen, wie es jetzt weitergeht. Ich vermute mal, da werden jetzt weitere Clips auftauchen, etc. so häppchenweise das ganze Ding. Ja und hoffe, dass wir das noch weiter promotet bekommen. Aber soweit hat es auf jeden Fall schon mal geklappt. Und wer hier noch keine Unterstützung geleistet hat, aber vielleicht auch in die Credits kommen möchte, der kann ja dann hier nochmal auf den Link klicken, den wir in den Schonutz packen. Und dann hoffe ich, dass das klappt.
Adel verpflichtet. Ja, war spannend vor allen Dingen. Das ist ja immer bei diesem Crowdfunding dann doch so, dass immer auf den letzten Metern dann nochmal so einen Schwung kommt. Und irgendwie, das war ja wirklich denkbar knapp. Da hab ich tatsächlich auch so ein paar Mal zwischendurch immer nochmal Reload gedrückt und geguckt. Na, tut sich noch was?
Irgendwie klappt das dann immer.
Also bei den Newton-Sachen.
Genau, bei Indiegogo ist das halt so, da kann man halt, das funktioniert ein bisschen anders als bei Kickstarter, da gibt's jetzt nicht nur so Projektziel erreicht und fertig, sondern jetzt ist es sozusagen Projektziel erreicht und jetzt läuft das sozusagen in so einem On-Demand-Ding weiter. Das heißt, alles, was jetzt noch gespendet wird, kommt obendrauf und das ist dann zeitlich unbegrenzt, oder läuft zumindest ein Jahr, ich weiß nicht ganz genau, wie das definiert ist. Ja, und dann werden wir uns sicherlich nochmal zu Wort melden. Wo wir gerade bei Hacker-Kultur sind, ich war gestern in Hannover. Sehr kurz entschlossen, weil am Montag überhaupt auf Heise erst diese Nachricht aufpoppte und ich hatte davon bisher noch nichts gehört. Und zwar hat jemand einen Theaterregisseur in Hannover, hat sich das Buch genommen von dem Hans Christian Schmid, was der geschrieben hat, gleichzeitig mit dem Film, den er irgendwie über die Story von Karl Koch gemacht hat. Also die alte KGB-Hacker-Story. Und der Regisseur meinte, er habe den Film auch nicht gesehen. Das fand ich irgendwie besonders interessant. Der Regisseur des Theaterstücks hat sich den Film nicht angeguckt.
Ja, vielleicht so wie du, warum du den anderen Podcast nicht anhörst.
Ja, genau. Deswegen wurde ich extra hellhörig. Und dann guckte ich auf die Webseite. Da waren noch ein paar Plätze frei. Da habe ich mir Atod geschnappt und bin nach Hannover gefahren. Und dann waren wir dann da und haben uns das irgendwie angeschaut. Es war wirklich ganz anders als dieser Film. Kann man jetzt überhaupt gar nicht vergleichen. Versuchte überhaupt nicht dasselbe zu erzählen.
Na, wenn er nicht gesehen hat, geht das ja auch nicht.
Na gut, aber es war ja dasselbe Buch. Also sozusagen die Faktenlage, die Story, die Informationen, die dort zusammen recherchiert wurden, das war zumindest schon mal dasselbe. Und ich habe mich vor allem, weiß nicht ob ich das vorher gemacht habe, aber zwei Sachen fand ich sozusagen bemerkenswert. Oder waren auf jeden Fall so eine Art Benchmark für das gesamte Ding. Ich muss gleich nochmal einen Disclaimer vorausschicken. Ich bin überhaupt kein Theater-Nerd. Ich weiß nicht, wie es euch geht, aber ich und Theater, keine Freunde. Also ich hasse es nicht oder so, ist mir nur meistens egal. Ich gehe nicht bis nie ins Theater. Das sind immer nur so Anlässe, wo mich andere Leute mitschleppen, überreden, was auch immer. Theater, wie ist das bei euch? Wir können jetzt stundenlang über Kinos reden.
Theater könnte ich gar nicht eine Minute voll kriegen.
Weil ich zu Schulzeiten öfter.
Ich gehe gerne zu gutes Wedding, schlechtes Wedding, weil die eigentlich immer sehr witzig sind. Aber ansonsten ist Theater nicht so meine Welt. Soweit ich weiß, ja.
Haben wir das hier schon mal vorgestellt? Vielleicht mal einen Moment. Bleiben wir erstmal bei 23. Ich schiebe das nur so vorweg, weil ich jetzt hier keine... Ich fühle mich überhaupt nicht befähigt, hier irgendwie eine Kritik oder auch nur so ein Review dieses Theaterstücks zu liefern. Ich fand das an sich ganz beeindruckend gemacht. Das war auf jeden Fall gut gespielt. Und für mich hat natürlich interessiert, wie wird diese Hacker-Kulturgeschichte hier aufgegriffen und vor allem, wie werden zwei... Interessant fand ich, wie zwei Sachen umgesetzt wurden. Das eine war erstmal, das war ja im Film auch ganz wichtig und für meinen Geschmack auch sehr gelungen, dieses auf die 80er Jahre intunen. Weil man kann ja diese ganze Story nicht verstehen, wenn man nicht zumindest so ein bisschen versucht, dieses Lebensgefühl der 80er Jahre auf den Tisch zu legen. Und im Gegensatz zu so, weiß ich nicht, 60er, vielleicht auch noch 70er, ich finde, so die 80er Jahre sind noch so ein bisschen unterrepräsentiert. Das ist irgendwie...
60er, 70er, lässt man einfach ein paar Oldtimer-Auto, so Ami-Cars in den Ami-Autos da rumstehen und dann sieht das schon nach 70er aus. Bei den 80ern geht das schon nicht mehr, ganz so easy.
Ami-Cars, Deutschland, weiß ich nicht. Also wenn ich jetzt versuch's 70er Jahre Deutschland...
70er Deutschland würde man halt hier so einen Käfer da rumstehen lassen und so ein Bulli und all so ne Autos. Ja, 70er auch. Der Hippie-Käfer.
Hippies, ja gut, 60er, 70er, hast recht. Auf jeden Fall 80er, da setzt es dann irgendwie aus. Und im Film haben sie es halt so gemacht mit so...
Weizäcker, der da irgendwie was erzählt gerade, oder?
Auf jeden Fall dieses ganze Demo-Ding, dieses ganze, diese ganze aufkommende Widerstand. Und das war da irgendwie so drin. Und hier haben sie es halt irgendwie mit Matthias Rust gemacht zum Beispiel.
Das war der, der auf dem Kreml da gelandet ist?
Genau, das war ganz interessant.
Nachdem diese Programmiersprache benannt ist.
Wer von euch da draußen tatsächlich Matthias Rust nicht kennt, das könnt ihr jetzt gleich mal hinterherklicken. Das ist wirklich eine irre Geschichte. Das haben sie wirklich schön gemacht. Und sie haben sich dann eben auch sehr auf den Illuminatus eingeschossen und so ein paar Elemente aus dem Illuminatus-Buch so mit in dieses Theaterstück reinbekommen. Unter anderem Howard, den sprechenden Delfin. Das fand ich ziemlich lustig gemacht. Ja, dann kommen natürlich dann ganz viele Sachen, werden natürlich da erwähnt, natürlich auch der CCC, der Kongress, findet da irgendwie alles so seine Rolle. Und dann sind aber auch immer wieder so Sachen drin, wo man nicht weiß, ist denen das jetzt passiert oder ist es egal, wenn sie irgendwie von 1984 und Laptop in einem Satz reden. Eurythmics with Dreams war irgendwie auch so ein Ding, was irgendwie so ein bisschen die 80er-Jahre gemacht hat. Also auch so viele Lieder aus der Zeit, die dann irgendwie immer noch so ein bisschen mit aufschwappten. Also da waren schon wirklich gute Sachen drin. Es ist jetzt kein Theaterstück, wo man dann rausläuft und sagt, jetzt kenne ich die Hacker-Geschichte, wie es damals gelaufen ist. Weil das ist einfach auch nur so eine szenische Interpretation im Prinzip. Aber den Wahnsinn kriegen sie irgendwie dann am Ende doch auch sehr gut hin. Also das ist das andere Ding, so dieser Wahn, es gibt ja verschiedene Wahn-Ebenen, die man hier hätte reflektieren können. Man hätte so den Drogenwahn nehmen können, aber das ist vielleicht zu naheliegend, zu einfach oder zu schwierig, weiß ich nicht. War auf jeden Fall nicht das Ding. Man könnte den Computerwahn machen, aber den kriegt ja immer keiner nachgestellt. Und tatsächlich ist so dieser Computeraspekt, den wir jetzt vielleicht so primär suchen würden, der ist da zwar auch drin, steht aber nicht so im Mittelpunkt.
Ist ja auch langweilig für so Beobachter.
Weiß ich nicht. Kommt drauf an, wie man es hinkriegt. Hätte ich jetzt auch noch für eine interessante Handwasservorlage.
Aber ich sag mal so, ich war im Chaos Computer Club Berlin schon oft und viel und lange und hatte auch schon oft so das Gefühl, dass jetzt da alle irgendwie total in ihrem Wahn, in Anführungsstrichen, drin sind. Und dann kommt halt Donnerstag oder so und dann kommen halt so irgendwelche Aliens rein und denken so, oh wir sind jetzt im Chaos Computer Club und jetzt hacka hier und krass und so und dann sitzen die halt da wortlos da vor ihren Büchsen und für die ist das halt Wahn, aber für die Zuschauerperspektive ist das, was machten die hier?
Ja klar, wenn man von außen schaut, ist schwierig, man muss halt irgendwie gelingen, dass das innen, das was sich da drinnen abspielt, das muss man halt irgendwie umsetzen und...
Genau das mein ich, das ist halt relativ auch knifflig, weil das ist irgendwie auch so eine sehr spezielle...
Genau, das ist super schwierig und das gelingt auch wirklich nur den wenigsten Kulturproduzenten. Die haben es eigentlich auch gar nicht probiert, sondern sie haben es eigentlich sehr viel mehr über diesen wirrenden Roman und diese ganzen Konstellationen gemacht. Aber am Schluss war es dann auch wirklich verrückt. Also 23 Nächste, so wie es scheint, Ballhaus 1 in Hannover. Kann man sich jetzt klicken. Gibt es jetzt die nächsten Wochen läuft das? Ich weiß nicht, wie lange das läuft, aber läuft jetzt. Es läuft. Es läuft. Ich hab natürlich immer so nach links und nach rechts geguckt, weil es war ja so der Premiere in der Abend, ob irgendwelche Mitstreiter aus den alten Zeiten irgendwie... Da war noch einer.
Hatten wir den hier als Gast?
Wir hatten anderen Mitstreiter hier schon als Gast, aber... So, das war mein Ausflug in die Theater-Szene. Ich bin voll auf die Mütze für.
Warum?
Weil ich eigentlich keine Ahnung habe von Theater. Aber das geht euch ja auch so.
Hast dich da, glaube ich, nicht verfänglich geäußert.
Okay.
Ach so, gutes Wedding, schlechtes Wedding. Soll ich da noch irgendwas zu sagen?
Ja, sag mal was zu gutes Wedding, schlechtes Wedding.
Das läuft ja jetzt schon... Na, sieben Jahre, glaube ich, mindestens. Acht, zehn? Ich weiß es nicht genau. Ursprünglich mal gegründet von einem Pärchen, die so Comedy auf, wie soll ich sagen, so Serie machen halt. Das ist so Fortsetzungsgeschichte, wo immer wieder Berliner Typen aufeinandertreffen. Das ist mitunter extrem albern und klamaukig. Aber wenn einem das nicht stört, ist es sehr schön. Also ich war jetzt schon eine Weile nicht mehr da. So ein bisschen das Problem ist, dass die beiden, die das ursprünglich mal gemacht haben, die hatten halt geheiratet und jetzt sind sie halt nicht mehr zusammen. Das ist halt, da ich die beiden eigentlich auch ganz gut kenne, ist es irgendwie immer eine schwierige Situation, jetzt da hinzugehen, weil man dann da so zwischen den Stühlen sitzt und so. Aber eigentlich macht es immer einen unglaublichen Spaß. Es ist irgendwie so, ja, die nehmen da nichts ernst. Also insofern, das passt schon.
Das hast du wie gute Zeiten, schlechte Zeiten oder was?
Na, da ich gute Zeiten, schlechte Zeiten nicht kenne, kann ich dazu jetzt nicht ja sagen, aber im Prinzip vom Dönerverkäufer Achmed, der dann die Frau vom Arbeitsamt Wedding heiratet, hin zu einer Band, die sich die Friedrichshainys nennen, hin zu Claudio, dem Prenzlwichser, der irgendwie Regisseur ist oder zumindest meint zu sein und irgendwie nicht ohne seine Latte kann, also Latte Macchiato und in einer Folge hatte er auch eine Kuschellatte, weil es ihm nicht so gut ging und da musste er immer mit dem Ding kuscheln. Es sind ganz, ganz verrückte Typen, einfach auch so von den Charakteren her. Also das kann man wirklich mal angucken.
Und wenn das so eine Serie ist, wie oft wiederholt sich da was?
Ich glaube, so eine Folge hat inzwischen so eine Laufzeit von vier bis fünf Wochen. Die waren mal irgendwann, also als sie angefangen hatten, gab es irgendwie alle zwei Wochen eine neue Folge. Aber inzwischen sind die Abstände länger geworden. Allerdings sind die Folgen auch viel aufwendiger geworden. Also man hat dann wirklich zwei Stunden Theater oder zweieinhalb oder was das ist. Also es ist wirklich ein ganzer Abend, den man da verbringt. Und es ist eine Riesenstimmung im Saal. Also es fängt schon damit an, dass der eine Schauspieler da immer die fehlenden Plätze noch zuweist, weil es ist meistens ausverkauft. Also man muss da Glück haben oder lange Karten vorbestellen, damit man da auch reinkommt.
Primetime-Theater.
Primetime-Theater nennen die sich, genau.
So, Freitag um 20.15 Uhr, Premiere steht hier. GWSW, Folge 102, morgens um halb zehn im Wedding. Na bitte.
Ja.
Steht eine Premiere an. 102. Das ist natürlich auch irgendwie irre. Gab es das überhaupt schon so im Theaterwesen, dass man so was wie eine Fortsetzungs-Serie macht und sozusagen eigentlich mehr oder weniger immer im selben Rahmen spielt? Normalerweise kenne ich Theater immer so mit, da ist immer wieder was anderes. Aber nicht, dass jetzt so eine Serie ist.
Du, keine Ahnung, die sind auch schon an der dritten Location. Also, keine Ahnung. Aber es gibt auch immer ein Was-bisher-geschah. Also insofern ein Previously quasi.
101 Folgen fassen sie dann zusammen?
Nee, sie fassen nur das zusammen, was relevant ist, um dann die nächste Folge zu verstehen. Das können dann auch so Sachen aus mehreren vorhergehenden Folgen.
Aber das heißt ja, dass man jetzt gar nicht binge-botschen kann. Man kann ja gar nicht die alten Folgen sehen. Oder haben sie die alle aufgenommen? Hier gibt es Multimedia, sehe ich gerade.
Ich glaube nicht, dass sie die Folgen alle aufgenommen haben. Also es gibt Aufnahmen von gewissen Folgen oder Best-of oder so. Aber es gibt nicht ein komplettes Archiv. Das gibt es nicht.
Analog, Oldschool, ne?
Nicht einmal das.
Das ist doch Lärme. Okay, ich meine, dass man am Anfang vielleicht nicht geglaubt hat, dass das sozusagen... Hier gibt es einen aktuellen Teaser, wollen wir uns den mal anhören?
Kannste mal machen.
Vielleicht kommt was bei raus, vielleicht braucht man auch keinen Flash. Trailer. GWSW 101. Oder ich dachte 102 ist jetzt aktuell.
Oh ja, mit dem Internet.
Warte mal, wir nehmen hier ganz viele Buttons zum Klicken. Trailer. Klicken und kein Flash.
Hallo. Das letzte Jahr war für uns beide ein arg intensiver Prozess. Also wir haben beide echt gucken müssen, wo wir eigentlich stehen. Als Menschen. Als Menschen. Es war ein Hin und Her. Erst waren wir zusammen, dann waren wir drin, dann bist du zu Theresa, ich zu Jutta und oh, da war so ein riesiger Wirrwarr.
Das war auch für mich ein ganz intensiver Prozess in meinem Leben.
Aber es gab natürlich auch negative Ereignisse, deswegen würde ich ganz gerne gerade mal die Minusspalte aufmachen. Die Sache mit der Männerstil-Ohre.
Ich wollte mich an dieser Stelle auch noch offiziell entschuldigen, dass ich mich so vor den Weddinger ab über das Ohr hauen lassen.
Also, um ehrlich zu sein, ich fand das arg peinlich.
Und was für eine Richtung geht das jetzt gerade?
Eine negative, also die Aktion mit der Kaktusfalken-Lade-Makiado. Weißt nicht, was dich da krittert, sorry.
Du weißt ganz genau, dass ich eine ganz intensive Vorliebe- und Koffein-Getränke mit Kaktusfalken-Aroma habe.
Aber das war nicht einmal Biotom und verdreht auch nicht.
Entschuldigung, dass ich mich habe angreifen lassen.
Aber wir haben das Schlechte hinter uns, Klasse. Wir waren in Darmstadt im Esoterium und haben verschiedene Workshops wahrgenommen. Ich bin mit meinem Krafttück geschwommen, mit der Feuerqualle.
Wir haben Delfin-Yoga gemacht.
Endlich unseren Hexenschein, Klasse D.
Den Hexen-D-Schein, genau.
Jetzt kommt's, wir haben uns beide zur Hebamme ausgebildet. Das war so lang auf unserer Liste. Du hakst ja Dinge manchmal nicht ab.
Und jetzt haben wir es, jetzt sind wir es. Auf ein neues!
Gutes Wedding, schlechtes Wedding, Folge 101.
Auf ein neues!
Am 8.
Januar im Primetime Theater.
Das ist schon klar irgendwie. Okay, damit habe ich jetzt nicht gerechnet. Ja, das ist der richtige Ansatz.
Ja, so geht das den ganzen Abend.
Okay, verstehe.
Aber halt auch ganz, ganz unterschiedliche Charaktere. Aber jeder kriegt sein Fett weg.
Das ist ja auch, sagen wir mal, gut.
Und jetzt klicken wir auf Tickets, wie weit im Jahr muss man jetzt quasi, kurz vor dem Kongress, kriegt man noch. Ach so, steht nicht da.
Da gehst du einfach hin und dann kichst du an.
Tja, füllen sie dieses Formular aus.
Aber wenn du da mal guckst, wie die Kartenpreise sind, also das ist halt irgendwie...
Sonntag bis Donnerstag 15 Euro.
Also da weißt du, die sind halt immer ausgebucht.
Ist wie bei Union irgendwie.
Also das Theater ist jetzt auch nicht riesig.
Wenn da nichts ist, geht man halt zur Union.
Ja, und wenn man das noch nie gesehen hat, wenn das jetzt außer kauft ist, geht man halt in die nächste. Ist ja nicht so schlimm. Die machen das ja die ganze Zeit, ne?
Ja, offensichtlich. Schluss mit dem Theater hier. Aber wir können gleich weiterleiten zu einem anderen Ding, das hätte wahrscheinlich vorhin irgendwie ganz gut gepasst. Habt ihr dieses tolle Video gesehen? Ist nicht dein Ernst?
Welches denn?
Ich guck doch nicht den ganzen Tag YouTube.
Ich schon, aber nicht das.
Okay, okay, go, sagt euch was.
Hab ich schonmal gehört.
Das ist diese Combo, die immer sehr auffällig wird durch ihre mega aufwendig gemachten Videos. Das fing mal an auf dieser Treadmill, auf diesem Laufband, wo sie irgendwie also die machen so mittelprächtige Musik, sag ich mal. Wegen der Musik hört man es jetzt vielleicht nicht unbedingt so. Vielleicht auch ganz okay. Da bleibt auch der eine oder andere Tune mal hängen. Aber sie sind jetzt nicht unbedingt vor allem für ihre Musik bekannt. Aber sie sind extrem für ihre Musikvideos bekannt. Ehrlich gesagt, ich bin jetzt ein bisschen überrascht.
Ich hab die Videos auch schonmal gesehen.
Ist schonmal in der Twitter-Zeitleiste vorbei.
Also sie sind super mega kreativ, was ihre Videos betrifft. Und vor allem fallen diese Videos dadurch auf, dass sie eine unfassbare Koordination erfordern und eine unfassbare Detailplanung. Das fing schon an mit diesem ersten Video, wo sie halt auf diesen Laufbänder, diese Trainings-Fitness-Rennenbänder, Threadmill halt, da rannten sie halt irgendwie drauf rum und machten allerlei Spirenzchen, während sie halt sozusagen ihren Song präsentierten. Und das passte halt alles irgendwie wunderbar. Das Ding war irgendwie total der Hit. Dann gab es noch ein paar andere Sachen und sie haben auch so alle auch so alle künstlerischen Stilrichtungen ausgelotet. Zum Beispiel hatten sie zuletzt ein Video, wo sie in so einer größeren Industriehalle herumlaufen und immer so umherstehende Dinge Formen bildeten. Erinnerst du dich noch, Dennis? Du warst doch mal auf dem Kongress vor zwei Jahren. War doch von dir auch so eine Kunstinstallation. Wenn man sich das von einer Stelle anschaut, dann war das so dieses 21C3-Dennis-Querschnitt-Logo. Aber wenn du es von der Seite angeschaut hast, sah es halt alles aus wie nur irgendwie Zeug. Und genau diese Technik, damit haben die ein komplettes Video gemacht. Und sozusagen alles in Realtime. Das heißt, sie bereiten das alles so vor, dass es am Ende alles ein Take ist. Und alles ist irgendwie völlig aufeinander abgestimmt. Und du, dir platzt das Hirn, wenn du dir nur darüber Gedanken machst, wie auffällig das ist, das zu koordinieren, das zu machen. So, das ist OK Go.
Wir können jetzt gar nicht das Video gucken. Also können wir schon, aber...
Welches?
Na, das, was du da verlinkt hast.
Das können wir uns, das könnt ihr euch, das werde ich jetzt auch einfach mal abspielen, auch wenn das jetzt sozusagen keiner schauen kann, aber die Hörer haben das ja wahrscheinlich eh alles schon gesehen. Ja, da seid ihr jetzt echt die Letzten, weil das ging jetzt mal so rum. Das Geile ist, die haben jetzt in einem Parabelflug...
Das, was du da schonmal gemacht hast?
Das, was ich auch schonmal gemacht habe, aber nicht so, haben die ihr Video aufgenommen. Und das Lied heißt irgendwie Upside Down, Inside Out. Ich werd jetzt mal die Musik ein bisschen leiser machen, weil darum geht's ja nicht unbedingt, dann kann ich das mal so ein bisschen erklären. Und sie sitzen halt jetzt erstmal und sind halt ganz allein in diesem Flugzeug, hacken auf ihren Laptops herum, hat alles so ein bisschen Zeitraffer-Qualitäten. Jetzt fliegen die Laptops halt einfach durchs Flugzeug in Schwerelosigkeit. Und währenddessen singen sie. Jetzt fliegen sie auch selber herum in Schwerelosigkeit. Und das Irre ist, ich hab das Ding als erstes gesehen und dachte mir so, Leute, das wollt ihr mich verarschen? Schwerelosigkeit in einem Parabelflug ist 21 Sekunden lang. Und das sieht hier einfach aus, als wären sie im Weltall. Machen alle möglichen Sachen, halten hier irgendwie die Kette, fliegen da durch und sind dann auch immer alle wieder irgendwie auf ihren Plätzen. Und man merkt zwischendurch, jetzt ist zum Beispiel, guckt ihr mal diese Laptops an, die rumfliegen, mal fliegen sie, dann liegen sie wieder. Und alle möglichen unglaublichen Aktionen. Und das ist alles ein Take. Ohne sichtbare Schnitte, muss ich jetzt dazu sagen. Es gibt welche, aber du siehst keine. Und das Video geht jetzt drei Minuten zwanzig. Und sie machen irgendwie die abgefahrensten Sachen. Quirlen da irgendwie rum, fliegen durch die Gegend. Die Mädels hier im Vordergrund mit ihren Super-Pureten. Das ist einfach unfassbar. Und jetzt sind wir schon auf der Hälfte des Videos. Jetzt wird es richtig verrückt. Jetzt kommen natürlich die bunten Bälle, die jetzt irgendwie quer durch den Flieger fliegen. Und diese ganze Koordination ist einfach schon total irre. Und nebenbei singen sie halt auch noch die ganze Zeit. Und mit Musik wird da nicht so viel gelaufen sein, wahrscheinlich auch. Man merkt immer so an den Bällen, ob gerade Schwerkraft ist oder nicht. Aber gefühlt ist halt meistens Schwerelosigkeit. Und man fragt sich halt, wie haben sie das jetzt gemacht? Und das Ding ist, das ist irgendwie ein Deal mit der S7 Airline. Das ist vermutlich die Airline, die halt auch richtig die Parabelflieger für die russischen Astronauten macht. Das habe ich jetzt gar nicht recherchiert, aber wie soll das anders sein? Weil du machst nicht mal eben mit irgendeinem Flugzeug einen Parabelflug, sondern das ist schon ein Flugzeug, was genau dafür gedacht ist. Jetzt fliegen Spiegelkugeln durch die Gegend, aber es kommt noch härter. Und gerade die letzte Einstellung lässt einen halt wirklich zweifeln, wie sie das gemacht haben. Jetzt haben sie halt Luftballons mit Farbe gefüllt, die halt in Schwerelosigkeit durch die Gegend fliegen und irre zerplatzen. Es ist wirklich unglaublich, wie die das hinkriegen. So, jetzt sind wir hier auch gleich am Ende. Zack, jetzt Schwerelosigkeit weg, die ganze Farbe tropft aus der Luft wieder nach unten. Und fertig ist das Video. So, wie haben die das gemacht? Die haben das in einem Take gemacht. Und ein Take heißt, die sind immer 45 Minuten lang geflogen, haben in diesen 45 Minuten acht Parabeln gehabt. Und zwischen den Parabeln sind immer fünf Minuten Pause. Die fünf Minuten Pause sind wahrscheinlich erforderlich. Erstens, aus Sicherheitsgründen kannst du nicht eine Parabel nach der anderen machen. Das ist auch beim normalen Parabelflug der Abstand. Und außerdem müssen sie ja dann auch immer das nächste Set vorbereiten. Das heißt, sie sind mit der ganzen Filmcrew unterwegs gewesen, 45 Minuten, haben acht Parabeln und haben immer das Video im Ganzen gedreht. Und die fünf Minuten Pausen haben die im Prinzip regungslos auf ihren Sitzen gesessen, um wirklich die Continuity zu haben, um dann diese fünf Minuten rauszuschneiden, sodass das irgendwie alles, sodass sozusagen aus diesen fünf Minuten vielleicht drei oder vier Sekunden...
Aber die ganzen Sachen, die da rumfliegen, die sind doch dann an einer anderen Stelle. Die bewegen sich doch noch weiter, dann die ganzen Kugeln und so.
Na ja, ich kann dir das nicht genau sagen, wie sie das gemacht haben, aber es ist halt One Take und sie haben nur Bilder rausgelassen. Das heißt, sie haben vielleicht dann ein paar Bilder, also von diesen fünf Minuten ein paar Frames, die langsame, es wirkt ja alles so etwas beschleunigt. Etwas schneller ist es auf jeden Fall geworden.
Aber du hast durchsuchen, hast du die Schnitte gesehen?
Nein, das habe ich mir jetzt nicht Frame by Frame angeschaut. Das ist nur die logische Konsequenz aus der Beschreibung, wie sie es gefilmt haben. Also sie haben immer 45 Minuten gehabt, acht Parabeln und wenn du durchzählst, hast du halt auch genau diese acht Schwerelosigkeitsmomente in diesem Video. Und das haben sie dann 20 mal gemacht, bis es saß.
Also sie haben aus diesen ganzen Einzelcuts sozusagen sich die passenden Dinger zusammengesucht, da wo es immer gut war.
Nee, ich glaube sie haben so lange geübt, bis sie am Ende einen durchgehenden Cut haben, wo alles gestimmt hat. Verstehe. Und ich vermute mal, dass sie in den ersten, dass die ersten Flüge wahrscheinlich immer nur so, wo wir proben die erste Szene so lange, bis sie sitzt, dann proben wir die zweite Szene und die dritte Szene. Und dann irgendwann haben sie angefangen, alle hintereinander zu machen. Weil, was, was, also es ist auf so vielen Ebenen, ist das bemerkenswert dieses Video, weil das ist so anstrengend, was sie da machen. Also, oder anders ausgedrückt, das ist so schwierig, was sie da machen. Also das musst du überhaupt erst mal hinkriegen.
Na ja, wenn die so viele Flüge machen, irgendwann wird das halt zur Gewohnheit.
Ja, aber da musst du eine Weile flügen.
Das was die Mädels da gemacht haben, sah auch schon ganz schön professional aus.
Ja, ich meine, ich hab 15 Parabeln oder 13 Parabeln gehabt und irgendwann, klar, kommst du da irgendwie ran, aber das Maß an Koordination, was die da haben, mit irgendwie Salto nach hinten und quer durchs Flugzeug fliegen und dann irgendwie an der Wand rankommen und dann auch im richtigen Moment wieder im Sitz sein, ohne dass dir irgend einer dabei hilft, also es ist mind-blowing.
Nachher kommt raus, ist alles nur.
3D. Da haben sie aber auch richtig gelogen.
Alles mit dieser Masquerade-App gemacht.
Da gibt es noch irgendwie so eine zweite, wo du, wenn du zu zweit im Bild bist, dann tauschst du halt dir Gesichter.
Das ist auch fies, ja.
Es gibt ein Behind-the-Scenes-Video.
Ach wirklich?
Google dir eins.
Inside, upside down und inside out heißt das.
It was filmed during a parabolic flight with Russian airliner S7 Airlines. Also das stimmt schon mal. Das heißt, so viel geschummelt können sie gar nicht haben, weil, ja. Da sind zumindest reichlich Bilder, auch die Kamera, wie sie die da aufgebaut haben, dass sie da so vor und zurück rollen kann.
Teaser, Teaser, Teaser. Achso, das sind so hier diese Teaser, wo sie einzelne Sachen zeigen. Hab ich mir noch nicht angeschaut, kann man gleich nochmal mit dazu nehmen hier in die Liste. Ist auf jeden Fall geil. Und wer jetzt wirklich, wie ihr, noch überhaupt keine Ahnung hat, schaut euch mal die anderen Videos auch an. Musik, weiß ich nicht, würde ich jetzt nicht die ganze Nacht laufen lassen, aber die Videos sind auf jeden Fall der Brüller.
Die Uhrzeit ist auch der totale Brüller.
Oh, schon durch oder was?
Fast, aber jetzt muss man noch erklären, wir müssen ja wieder die alten Themen raussuchen, die Hucke sind immer so langweilig. Dieses Batterieladegerät.
Die alten Themen sind die besten. Einmal hast du nur dein Mikro erst mal.
Das ist hier ein bisschen weiter weg. Nicht so Reinwäder. Genug Star Wars für heute. Diese Technoline BC1000. Wir hatten das Technoline BC700 schon mal vor Jahren hier. Da wo Hucke einschläft.
Und hier steht das BC1000 daneben und es sieht genauso aus wie das BC700.
Was ist denn anders, außer dass es 1000 mA kann anstatt 700? Ja genau, aber sonst? Das reicht schon? Als Erwähnung? Du meinst dieses Gerät ist weiterhin das beste Ladegerät, was es gibt, außer dass es jetzt ein bisschen mehr Bums hat?
Und eine neuere Firmware und bestimmt viel intelligentere Ladeautomatik.
Also da es heute gekommen ist, kann ich dir ehrlich gesagt noch nicht so sehr viel dazu sagen.
Aber Bedienung ist genau gleich, oder?
Sieht so aus. Also ich sehe hier keinen Unterschied. Es ist nur das Gehäuse ist jetzt blau.
Das ist ja immer ein Grund.
Das ist auf jeden Fall schon mal was, auch beim letzten Teil übrigens. Es ist explizit für die Batterien mit höheren Ladeleistungen gepitcht.
Diese Panasonic XX oder was?
Diese 2500 mAh-Dinger.
Ich hab ja diese alte Version davon und ich lad meine Batterien immer noch mit 200 mAh. Dauert ziemlich lange, aber dafür werden die nicht warm, sondern schön entspannt werden die voll geladen. Das reicht mir mal bis zum nächsten Tag. Hier wahrscheinlich nicht so oft wie deine Wi-Fi-Controller, deine Wi-Fi-Controller leer sind. Du musst wahrscheinlich immer ein bisschen schneller laden.
Mir ging es jetzt erstmal nur darum, ich wollte einfach mal noch ein zweites Ladegerät, weil ich hier immer, wenn ich hier tauschen muss, muss ich immer gleich sehr viel tauschen. Ich hab nicht nur einmal Tastatur, sondern immer so alle Wi-Modes. Ich brauchte einfach mal mehr Ladekapazität. Deswegen hab ich mal geschaut und wollte mir eigentlich ein BC700 klicken.
Du hast gesehen, dass es ja Neueres gibt.
Und dann hab ich gesehen, es gibt jetzt das 1000er und dann dachte ich mir, winzle das nochmal, ohne dass ich da jetzt eine große Story zu erzählen kann. Bewertes gibt es jetzt auch in Blau. Genau, wir sind eigentlich auch schon durch, würde ich fast sagen. Eine Sache wollte ich noch erwähnen, weil das nämlich auch den Huckel noch interessieren könnte. Und zwar gibt es einen interessanten Artikel auf Medium von einem Ivan Wallace, der wohl jetzt eine Firma gegründet hat, mitgegründet hat, die heißt Figma, F-I-G-M-A, die noch nicht so richtig am Start ist. Also das ist sozusagen nur ein Coming Soon-Dingsbums. Sieht aber so aus, als ob die eine Vector-Software rausbringen werden, die halt so in der Tradition von, keine Ahnung, Freehand, Illustrator, was auch immer. Mir ist der Umfang dieser Software nicht klar, ob das irgendwie erst mal klein startet oder ob die da einen großen Wurf machen. Das interessante an dem Artikel ist aber etwas, er stellt eine Neuerung vor, die halt offenbar in dieser Software dann umgesetzt worden ist. Und es betrifft halt sowas Einfaches wie das Zeichnen von Linien. Beziehungsweise das Zeichnen von komplexen Linien-Grafiken. Und nun gibt es ja Vektor-Grafik seit, na, ok, womit ging das los? Also Freehand gehörte auf jeden Fall so zu den ersten. Es war glaube ich nicht das aller, aller, aller erste.
Da müsste ich jetzt auch mal gucken.
Aber noch tief in der schwarz-weiß-Ära.
Also ich meine, so die ersten Software-Applikationen, die hat ja noch Ellen K irgendwie vorgestellt und so, aber so, dass es mal richtig beim End-User war, das erste Mal, das ist eine gute Frage.
Also ich weiß jetzt auch nicht so ganz genau, aber ganz klar, also sagen wir mal, also dieser Software-Genre, was vor allem durch Freehand und Illustrator geprägt wurde, wo es zahlreiche Apps gab, die sich da bemüht haben, auch nochmal was zu machen, aber sagen wir mal, vor allem die, die eben so mit komplexen Pfaden daher kamen. Also nicht nur so, ich kann jetzt einen Kreis machen, sondern hier geht es mir jetzt konkret um Pfade. Und diese ganze Pfadgeschichte ist so ein bisschen komisch, weil jeder, der mit so was arbeitet, wird dann irgendwann mal so festgestellt haben, naja, so einfache Linien ist einfach, aber mach mal was Komplexes wie Sterne und Polygon-Dinger. Klar, nur um so eine Outline zu machen, ist das alles gar nicht das Ding. Und dann kommt man irgendwie auch mit diesen ganzen Bezierkurven klar, die dem ganzen zugrunde liegen. Aber wo es halt wirklich haarig wird, das ist dieser Bereich mit sich überlappenden Flächen. So ein A, wie kriegst du das Loch ins A? Wodurch ist sozusagen dieses Ausstanzen definiert. Und tatsächlich ist das eben in dieser Vektorzeichnungsgeschichte so definiert, dass es eben bei den Pfaden eine Richtung gibt und die Verquickung der Richtungen miteinander bestimmt, wo etwas rausgeschnitten ist und wo es sich irgendwie nur überlagert. Und keiner kommt damit klar. Ja, man gewöhnt sich so ein bisschen dran, wie man sich halt an einen geringen Sauerstoffgehalt gewöhnt, aber wenn du dir das halt aussuchen würdest.
Also warte mal, also Bezierkurven, achso, okay, die sind natürlich schon ziemlich alt. Aber das, verdammt, es gibt in der Wikipedia keine ordentliche History. Also Illustrator ist auf jeden Fall tatsächlich vor, Freehand released.
Aber Freehand war auf jeden Fall erstmal der Platzirsch.
War der King. So, und jetzt hier.
So, und jetzt haben sie für ihre Tool etwas Neues erfunden, was dieses Zeichnen von Vektor-Grafiken auf eine neue Basis stellen soll. Und sie nennen es Vector Network. Und was damit gemeint ist, ist, dass eine komplexe Grafik, die eben aus verschiedenen Linien und sich überlappenden Linien und so weiter und vor allem auch ausgestanzten Bereichen besteht, überhaupt nicht mehr dieser Pfadlogik folgt, sondern du sie im Prinzip ganz einfach nur als verbundene Linien zeichnest. Und überall wo du Kreuzungen hast, hast du dann einfach Kreuzungen. Und dann an der Stelle, wo eben diese Kreuzungspunkte sind, kannst du eben so ein Ding auch resizen. Und die Vector-Networks können automatisch auch genau das, was man so von anderen Pfaden gewohnt ist, also so diesen Joint-Styles und so abgerundete Ecken etc. Das ist drin. Also sie haben irgendwie so einen komplett neuen Ansatz zum Thema Bending, weil du eben jetzt die Kurven sozusagen auch wirklich an den Kurven anfassen kannst und nicht nur an den Bezier-Kurven, wobei das ging, glaube ich, auch bei manchen Zeichneprogrammen auch. Aber wo es wirklich anders ist, ist halt diese ganze Fill-Geschichte und dieses ganze rotationsorientierte...
Ja, mit den Winding-Rules.
Genau.
Das gibt es auch in Coco, wenn man da mit Bezier-Path arbeitet.
Genau, das hast du irgendwie überall. Und sie lassen das einfach sein. Und was sie machen ist, wenn du halt einfach mit so einem Vector-Network zeichnest, also ein Objekt aus verschiedenen Linien, dann hast du halt automatisch sozusagen ausschneidbare Bereiche und dein Vector-Network ist sozusagen einfach ein geschlossenes Ding, wo diese ganzen Linienwege gar keine Rolle spielen. Und du kannst einfach in einem speziellen Modus einfach die Löcher ausstanzen. Klickst einfach drauf und sagst einfach, du bist jetzt leer oder du bist jetzt voll. Und das speichern sie einfach in diesem komplexen Vector-Network-Ding. Und fertig ist die Laube. Ja, und das ist es eigentlich schon. Also keine Ahnung, wann diese Software kommt. Wird wahrscheinlich jetzt nicht mehr so lange dauern. Einen Grund werden sie schon haben, das hier mit diesem Artikel anzuteasern. Aber was ich so interessant fand daran ist, das sieht man wieder so nach etwas aus wie oh ja, warum haben wir das nicht schon immer so gemacht? Ja, so weit würde ich jetzt noch nicht gehen, aber es ist zumindest so ein Ding, was einen echt...
Die Ideen sind auf den ersten Blick relativ offensichtlich. Das stimmt schon. Aber ich muss mal sagen, bis zu dem Punkt, wo er anfängt mit seinem Füllzeug, ist da ja aber auch noch nichts Neues dabei. Also irgendwie...
Naja, so wie ich das hier aus diesen Beispielgrafiken herauslese, zeichnet es sich schon etwas anders. Weil du halt so automatisch diese... Du hast so ein Dreieck-Kreuzungsmöglichkeiten. Das hast du halt bei einem normalen Vektor nicht. Sondern da musst du dann verschiedene Linien aneinanderlegen und so. Aber dass dir wirklich von jedem Punkt aus mehrere Strahlen in alle Richtungen gehen können, das hast du so bei der normalen Vektor-Zeichnung nicht. Das erscheint mir irgendwie sofort logisch. Und in so Vektor-Programmen, da sitze ich immer so davor und denke mir so, warum ist das so?
Du musst halt immer einen geschlossenen Kreis machen. Und wenn der geschlossen ist, dann ist halt vorbei mit dem. Also dann kann man halt keine Punkte mehr da dran ketten, ohne weitere Entitäten.
Dann muss man wie Gruppen bilden und joinen und machen und tun. Und hier machst du einfach so viele Linien, die zu dem Network dazugehören. Und danach stand es so ein bisschen aus.
Also es schockt jetzt nicht so mega auf den ersten Blick, aber ich könnte mir auch vorstellen, dass das die Benutzung doch sehr ändert.
Na ja, die Frage ist halt, wenn sich das herausstellt, dass das eine gute Idee ist, dann können sämtliche Konkurrenten wahrscheinlich mit relativ wenig Aufwand das nachbauen.
Ja, die Frage ist, das stelle ich mal in Frage, weil er so behäbig wie Adobe mit seiner Software zum Beispiel umgeht.
Ja gut, aber das liegt dann mehr an Adobe.
Ja klar, aber ich habe letztens mal wieder Illustrator benutzt und ich konnte es echt nicht fassen, in welchem Zustand diese Software mittlerweile ist.
Also das ist auch wirklich alles broken und da muss wirklich was Neues passieren.
Also dieses Affinity-Designer und Affinity-Foto, die sind ja wirklich so die einzigen Tools, die es so zu einer ernstzunehmenden Alternative eigentlich schon geschafft haben. Ja, ich bilde mir einen, das Design ist der Vector-Klicker und Affinity-Foto ist der Photoshop-Klicker.
Das wollte ich mir vielleicht auch nochmal anschauen.
Das ist wirklich ziemlich schick, aber ja.
Ja, dafür Affinity Designer.
Das war ja die erste Software, die sie released haben. Also das Foto kam ja jetzt erst raus und mit dem Designer sind sie gelauncht.
Das hat doch auch relativ viel Welle geschlagen.
Ja, das hat viel Welle geschlagen. Auch dieses Fotoding hat viel Welle geschlagen. Und ich benutze ja gerade eine andere Software für meine kleinen Grafikoperationen, die ich so machen muss, nämlich Sketch. Was sich ja vor allem in diesem User-Interface-Bereich gerade umsetzt, weil es dafür auch wunderbar optimiert ist. Also zum Beispiel, ich weiß nicht, ob das bei diesem Affinity auch geht, was mir auch bei allen Programmen immer gefehlt hat. Du kannst halt bei Sketch einfach so mal ein paar Basis-Grafiktypen setzen und ein paar Farben definieren und die an verschiedenen Stellen verwenden. Und wenn du halt sagst, ich will jetzt nicht blau, ich will jetzt rot, dann ist es halt an verschiedenen Stellen in deinem Dokument auf einmal rot. Und musst die alles von Hand irgendwie eintarben und so.
Ich hab mit dem Infinite Designer noch nicht so viel rumgeklickt, muss ich zugeben.
Ja, aber die Sketches ist sehr schön, weil du kannst dann eben auch, was weiß ich, wenn du so, das wird ja vor allem sehr gerne für so User-Interface-Sketches benutzt, also wenn du so Apps machst, dann kannst du halt so alle möglichen Display-Größen und so weiter machen und dann gibt es irgendwie so eine App dazu, die heißt Sketch...
Was ist das? Sketch...
Sketch... Mirror, genau, Sketch Mirror. Und dann kann in so einer Session alle deine Devices, startest du einfach diese Mirror-Software und auf deinem Mac fummelst du an deinen Designs rum und es wird in dem Moment, wo du dran arbeitest, automatisch auf die iPhones gestreamt und du hast sozusagen immer gerade sofort während du dran arbeitest, siehst du, wie es auf deinem Device aussehen würde in einem bestimmten Modus oder in einem bestimmten Size.
Ja, hier, Roddy klickt gerade bei Finitec Designer nochmal auf der Seite rum und steht da unten Entworfen exklusiv für den Mac und dann so die Auflistung von allen relevanten Technologien, die es auf dem Mac zur optimalen Ausnutzung der Ressourcen gibt.
Na gut, OpenCL steht jetzt nicht, aber Grand Central Dispatch, na gut, das benutzt man sowieso. Force Touch, jo, 64-Bit, naja.
Nochmal eine kurze Frage. Also Tim hat ja so ein Phone nicht, aber ihr beide habt doch ein 6S, oder?
Es gibt eine geniale Funktion bei dem Force Touch, das ist, wenn du was schreibst und du Force Touchst unten auf die Tastatur, dann kannst du den Cursor schön verschieben. Das benutze ich, ja. Alles andere eigentlich nicht.
Ich benutze das nicht mal aus Versehen, weil ich drücke einfach nicht doll auf meine Scheibe, weil ja, wofür? Auch dieses Preview und so, das alles, dann drücke ich halt drauf, dann kommt es halt, dann gehe ich wieder zurück, der Move ist viel drinnen als doll zu drücken.
Ich würde das halt gerne als Kontext-Click benutzen. Also sozusagen so Copy. Ich würde ganz oft so Copy sagen und dann, weiß ich nicht, muss ich jetzt, wie muss ich jetzt touchen, um dieses Kontext, diesen einen Bobbel dazu kriegen und dann tappe ich mich halt, dass ich denke, Force Touch halt und dann kommt da irgendein Scheiß Preview und dann, ah, okay, vielleicht nicht Force Touch, aber Force Touch ist ja dann, also ein normaler Touch ist Klick, wie kriege ich diesen anderen Mode halt hin und dann sitze ich dann mal so da wie so ein Depp und denke mir, ich hätte gerne diesen, so ich Force Touch auf was und dann gib mir Copy oder gib mir so ein Kontextmenü, was will ich jetzt tun, statt mir so ein Preview zu nennen. Aber halt auch so was irgendwie, das wo ich drauf Force Touche, weiß nicht, öffne das in Maps und diese ganzen Geschichten halt. Es gibt ja dieses Menü gelegentlich, aber das kommt dann so von unten rausgefahren und ich krieg einfach, also das krieg ich so immer in dem Moment, wo ich es gerne hätte, falsch.
Ja, eine definierte Art dieses Menü aufzurufen.
Ich finde das ein ganz schönes Fail und dafür ist es ganz schön schade, dass sie so einen riesen Teil da einbauen, was, also meiner Meinung nach hätten sie die Batterie wahrscheinlich da unten reichlich größer machen können, hätten sie das nicht eingebaut. Also kostet auch Geld.
Ach, dieses Force Touche, das ist doch voll klein.
Nee, das ist nicht so klein.
Ach so, diese Prozessor da oder was?
Naja, der hat das halt, genau.
Achja, achja. Also, ich hätte wie gesagt gerne dieses Kontextmenü einfach überall mit Force Touch. Statt einfach mir irgendein Preview, den die meinen, der jetzt da passend wäre.
Also ich bin noch überhaupt gar nicht überzeugt von diesem Feature.
Naja, es gibt ja auf der Homescreen gibt es ja diese komischen für die Menüs.
Das ist auch voll für den Arsch. Bevor ich da überlege, da irgendwie Force Touchen machen, da bin ich schon dreimal drin in der App und hab das schon längst geklickt. Das ist alles schon so eingelernt.
Force Touch mal auf die Schleife da.
Ich mach mal Force Touch hier.
Force Touch du musst.
Bevor wir noch Force-Quatsch machen.
Okay, das war's mit 172.
Ja, natürlich. Was denn das? Das ist mein Eier-Entscheidungskomputer.
Der funktioniert genauso wie ein richtiger Computer, nur nicht mit Strom, sondern mit Eiern. Und er entscheidet für mich, ob ich ins Kino gehen soll oder nicht.
Ins Kino gehen? Ist gar keine schlechte Idee, wissen Sie, wenn ich... Naja, also ich weiß nicht.
Sie wissen nicht?
Dann ist es ein Fall für meine Entscheidungsmaschine. Sehen Sie die Bratpfanne da unten? Wenn das Ei in die Nein-Fanne fällt, dann bleiben wir hier.
Fällt es aber in die Ja-Fanne, dann gehen wir ins Kino. Ganz einfach. Wie?
Aber erst mal muss die Maschine was von uns erfahren. Wie ein richtiger Computer, damit sie sich entscheiden kann.
Haben Sie Lust, ins Kino zu gehen?
Also, ja.
Wenn es nein wäre, würde das Ei gleich in die Nein-Fanne fallen, nicht?
Also, ja. Haben Sie Geld? Nein.
Nicht? Das ist schlecht.
Nein. So.
Können Sie sich was pumpen?
Ja, von mir.
Ja.
Haben Sie den Film schon gesehen?
Der mit Sidney Worm?
Ne, ne, ne. Nicht?
Also, ja, das stimmt schon.
Nein. So, jetzt wird uns meine Maschine einen Haufen Denkarbeit abnehmen.
Jawohl. Sollen wir ins Kino gehen?
Oder nicht?
Achtung!
Fertig!
Haha, ja, hat er gesagt.
Richtig.
Und Computer irren sich nie.
Wir gehen also ins Kino. Das heißt leider, dass die Sendung aus ist. Ihr könntet ja jetzt abschalten oder auch ins Kino gehen, tschüss.
Bis dann, tschüss!